[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
remember
[Music]
foreign
anything
[Music]
foreign
already on day three of the 2023
Champions Chester we will get the match
that we're all dreaming of the two
biggest rivals in online chess Magnus
Carlsen versus Hikaru Nakamura in the
winners final of the air things Masters
but first two more players will be
knocked out of the tournament and Wesley
so is one of the players fighting to
stay in the game
really looking happy with himself the
king can't move wait wait wait wait wait
this move is breaking the rules whoa
everything under control but suddenly
the position has changed this just looks
glorious Big Choice from origin
irrigation there we go the Avalanche
continues
[Music]
there's a big threat on the board Magnus
Carlson is furious it's going straight
to the kill Wesley so has blundered he's
blundered his Knights and white king is
trapped this is track my abundant Magnus
Carlsen showing his genius
and Magnus Carlsen will have to bring
his very best today because in the
winners final later today he's gonna
face Hikaru Nakamura in an incredible
match we're looking forward to that and
to safely guide us through this day
three in the air things Masters
Grandmaster David Howell International
Master Tanya and Grandmaster Robert test
and David what a day it was yesterday
but I'm gonna tell you the Highlight for
me even with two armageddons
this
I need to hit the gym a bit more clearly
we got a little bit of a MTV Cribs tour
of your apartment seeing that nice gold
medal but the Armageddon David we had
three matches decided that armaged on
yesterday what do you think we did and
it was the first sight uh the first
Glimpse we've been given of this bidding
process I really liked it it added an
extra layer the Mind Games there that we
saw it added the strategy and uh it did
end up favoring the stronger players in
most of those or at least the higher
receipts on paper and I expect to see
more as we go through the tournaments it
was really dramatic yeah and Robin
you're a big sports fan so as a
sportsman do you like the direction
chess is taking now also with his
Armageddon bidding I love it you have to
break a tie somehow and you put it all
in the player's hands they chose the
amount of time they're willing to bid
they chose the color that they wanted to
play with so I think they were very
exciting games and we had three
Armageddon matchups yesterday it was
awesome yeah and today is going to be
another awesome day we're going to to
start out with a match between two
Indian teenagers Tanya ergassi and you
cash what you expect from that one I
can't wait for that one this is going to
be an epic fight it's going to be so
much fun because these two players are
absolute beasts and they play
uncompromising chess it's going to go
down to the wire no quick draws I am
expecting a tremendous effort from these
two who are good friends but on the
board they don't care about the
Friendship also looking forward to see
Kaya who India's rooting Focus they've
got such a massive fan base so I'd love
to hear from all the Indians who are
joining us for this one definitely
were you rooting for two players sitting
in India we have six players left in the
air things monsters spread out across
the world those two young Indians and
Magnus Carlsen one of the three players
sitting in the US Wesley Seoul playing
from his home in Minnesota today he's
gonna face Alexei serrana who yesterday
knocked out one of the biggest names in
online chess
if erosion doesn't move quickly
immediately Serrano replies again he's
hammering home the point wow no what
just happened oh North the attack on his
Queen and he counter-attacks against the
black queen now all of the queen side
pawns have disappeared but the Knight is
trapped that is what Alexis surround has
been and he brings his Bishop back the
Knight is stuck everything just happened
there in the blink of an eye and uh
there we go spurge is about to resign
White's porn Central Pawn did run
through promote and uh just in time to
stop black spot
Magnus just whitening his eyes
I think shocked by this last decision by
Eric icy it did feel to me like Magnus
was trying to provoke this move I think
Magnus would have happily invested two
or three moves to Baroque black to push
his Pawn to G6 oh discover checks all
over the shop here if Magnus once it's
just a nightmare everything is a
weakness in Black stamp right now a rook
trade and white will make a new Queen
Arjun is about to resign losing on time
as well and he looks off immediately now
feels like momentum is on magnus's side
five minutes though against nine and a
half he's got to speed up up
everybody at least doing the right
things breaking out asking questions
there's going to be blunders there's
going to be mistakes they're only human
but the Queens are off the board this is
great news for our generic IC look at
that black Horton in the center it's
tying down the white rook and the white
Bishop he's essentially playing up a
piece and Magnus gesturing wow he's gave
away the pond and he's lost he's giving
away the game it is looking dangerous
for both sides but this is Armageddon
and that's exactly what happens look at
what hikara has done he's throwing a
thorn into the white side this black H1
if you capture it your structure is
ruined the white king is going to be
weak forever Hikaru so focused up on the
clock up on the position yeah just a
master class Wesley so with a draw in
this game Morris Lee is knocked down to
the losers bracket Hikaru Nakamura makes
it through
and also in the studio we have
international Master Ivanka houska and
Ivanka you play chess almost your whole
life what do you think about what's
happening in chess with online chess
with rapid and Blitz chess and
Armageddon and bidding and everything
going on yeah I think it's actually
quite brilliant because you get maximum
drama maximum tension and everyone out
there quite frankly loves it because
this is what sport needs
totally agree let's take a look at the
results from the winners the semi-finals
yesterday
Hikaru Nakamura it went all the way to
Armageddon against Wesley so and bidding
as low as 9 minutes and 28 seconds in
the Armageddon Hikaru still got the draw
he needed to win the match with the
black pieces but that is a little bit
that is a loud lipid but I have to say
Hikaru was a man with a plan because he
actually wanted to play an Armageddon he
had worked out in the break exactly how
low he could go to make that bid and he
decided okay he wanted the black pieces
and this was the maximum time he could
give Wesley and it worked out what can I
say he was a perfect strategy from
Hikaru and then Magnus Carlson he also
won his match in Armageddon but he did
lose his first game of the 2023
Champions chess tour season he's not
unbeatable no he's not unbeatable and I
have to say it was a bit surprising to
say because Magnus started the day on
such good form you know he looked
Unstoppable and then of course he just
took the foot off the paddle for the
those games two and three and then again
Magnus is the king of comebacks and when
it came to the Armageddon Magnus was
just again back on unbeatable form
still on the winners bracket Magnus
Carlsen but then the losers round won
yesterday two players were knocked out
Ali Raza farusha and the Ralph mama
dogesh and Serana making it through to
today's losers quarterfinals and we're
gonna follow the winners final between
Magnus and Hikaru later today because
first it is the losers bracket and the
losers quarterfinals with Wesley so
against Alexa Serana and Arjun ergassi
against gukesh Wesley so fighting to
survive in the tournament and he's
playing a lot of online chess yeah
Wesley he's in the Last Chance Saloon
but you know that doesn't bother him
because yesterday you know before the
match against Hikaru Nakamura he plays
the early title Tuesday won that 10
points out of 11 and then after his
match against Hikari perhaps needed to
burn off some frustration and he also
played the late title Tuesday won that
with nine and a half points out of 11.
completely unbeaten yesterday so he is a
man in form
and fighting to survive today Wesley so
yesterday with all the drama going on we
also enjoyed a very nice puzzle that you
had with you Ivanka so we're gonna have
another puzzle for the viewers today and
uh let's reveal it yeah I mean this
puzzle I think is just amazing it's a
study composed by Vitali kobelenko and
it's one of my personal favorites now it
looks quite simple it looks like a pawn
race but there is such a nasty Twist on
the board
that don't get confused don't get swayed
by those ghosts but I'm going to leave
out there it's white to play there's a
lot of twists and turns and uh it's the
kind of puzzle quite frankly which once
you've solved it don't cheat please
that's not fun but uh you kind of like
message your friends you message your
family and you share it with however
many people you like because it's just
amazing yeah
solve it together with friends family
maybe you're at work maybe you're at
school gather everyone around and try to
solve this puzzle that has a lot of
twists and turns very cool now Magnus
Carlsen he doesn't have a lot of Nemesis
but he certainly did struggle against
Indian teenagers on the tour last season
oh look at the bar yeah it's this clever
or is this madness Okay actually Prague
finds the best move I was about to see
stockfish the computer had three
suggestions there move I mentioned
taking that white Pawn would have been
fine for black but this is even better
okay Magnus does try and create that air
for his King but as you guys mentioned
the only Escape Square for that wiping
is pop the board on a light Square 8.5
on the bar Checkmate it's just coming
Cliff Edge yeah but oh wow what a move
black cuts the coordination between
whites queen and the second Rankin is
Magnus about to resign Magnus Carlson
the world champion loses to 16 year old
pregnant
women
is he getting his revenge
I I want to put wow I would never play
this move in a million years this looks
hopeless doesn't it for Magnus really do
you think he knows just yeah this is
expression leaning forward he knows it's
all out of control at least um
I mean he's just trying to make things
messy at the moment yeah pretty is off
you guys
he means business
oh but he's getting all the Rooks off
the board now and Magnus reacts surely
this is winning for white she is so
upset angry with himself and there it is
it's over Magnus Carlson he loses to 19
year old Arjun Eric icy
what happened Something's Happened
um it did feel a bit wrong for Magnus to
play this move I actually thought Magnus
had something a bit stronger is the
queen trapped wow Lawrence the queen is
actually trapped in the center and the
Queen on B6 protects the E6 Pawn that's
that's a crucial thing yeah oh that's it
that's the real threat just like a house
of cards his position does completely
fell apart it is over Magnus crawls and
loses to another Indian teenager
he actually became the youngest player
ever you catch to beat Magnus Carlsen
after Magnus became a world champion and
was a year young dukesh had last year he
played for the Indian B team in the
Olympiad
they took a bronze medal and uh playing
on the first board yukash also took the
gold medal this must have been huge in
India Tanya this was a big moment we
were hosting the Olympia and then we had
this a young India beat Team and they
were phenomenal alongside of course
Uzbekistan who took the gold medal but
gokish led the team he was the front
runner he won a gold on board one and
what a performance an absolute breakout
moment for gokish yeah and the other
young Indians as well had a fantastic
tournament in the Olympiad the Erica I
see on the Indian a team took an
individual silver medal on board three
prag took the bronze medal oh wow the
guy in the center looks really familiar
I know it's really good looking
taking the gold medal on boards with our
very own David I don't think I don't
think I see the metal I wonder if we
have something else so we can actually
see
[Music]
you got me again
it was a huge moment for you though
David taking that gold medal I do feel
guilty uh just kind of getting in there
ahead of very geissy and Prague to uh
players who are clearly going to be in
the top of world chest for a long time
but it was an honor to share the podium
with them yeah and talking about the
Prague mananda he's not playing division
one hair in the air thinks monsters but
he's playing on in division three and he
has a big match coming up today Robert
yeah he's performing excellently in
division three he takes on Sam Sevin by
the super Grand Master From America also
very young but no longer a teenager so
prognama with big opportunity to score a
victory and head on to the Grand Final
wow impressive stuff by Young Prague and
in division two
writing some interesting matches today
and it's especially interesting to look
on the losers bracket in division two
one very big match coming up here Jana
pomyachi against blood McCormick how did
they end up here Robert you would expect
to see that in the winners final in the
top division by Jana Palmer he didn't
play yesterday I think he was in transit
Vladimir chromic lost the match in this
rapid format not always his best friend
but we see another all-russian matter
Dimitri on Drake and Daniel dubo that
too could be a division one winners
final so division two super strong as
well definitely and remember the winner
of division two qualifies for division
one in the next event on the Champions
chess tour now we are going to follow
division one today starting out with the
losers quarterfinals it is best out of
two rapid games and if they are tied
well then we know it's going to head to
Armageddon it's Wesley so against Alexa
is Serana and then Arjun Eric icy
against bukash you're not not rooting
for any of them are you Tanya I'm so
torn in this one I'm Gonna Keep the
unbiased approach here and it's a bit
bittersweet because one of them will go
forward but it will be the end of the
road for one of the Indians and their
friends they know that and I think uh
they will be happy whoever goes through
they will feel slightly bad at the same
time yeah and you brought with you some
some cool footage of these two there as
you mentioned good friends what am I
seeing here is this good cash in a
boxing room this happened and then we
have the face Ruby this was a death
match organized by chess space India and
it was a huge event there were thousands
of people who were watching and there we
see Arjun walking in with his uh with
his boxing suit on they really went at
it with each other in this one what a
match this was uh just so much fun to
watch they play different formats and in
the end just in the last moment the last
game Arjun took this Championship away
what cool cool event that was the credit
to uh chess face India for sharing that
footage with us and here they are ready
for the big fight Arjun aragaisi 19
years old against new cash 16 years old
best attitude rapid games the winner
will make it through to tomorrow's
losers semi-finals
and it is Arjun starting out with the
white pieces
what should we expect from this match
well Aldrin plays pretty much every
opening Under the Sun and he plays them
all extremely well so it will have been
hard for kukesh to prepare for this game
looks like the clock has started we
don't have the moves coming in yet try
and get that refreshed as soon as
possible but yeah it's unclear who the
favorite is Eric I see a couple of years
older than his countrymen here slightly
more experienced you would say but
gokesh has had a fantastic year these
two met over the board in tata steel
just a few weeks ago it was a draw a
very hard for draw there
and um okay where are the moves yeah we
want an update ghost moves uh there are
some technical issues moves are coming
out do you have them up on your computer
yeah I think they're they're just
getting underway it started as a caracan
so hopefully the moves come up shortly
you can catch with the black pieces
there they are our generic I see playing
what is well regarded as the fantasy
variation of the caracon so let's see
what kind of fantasy it will continue to
be for the Indian fans who don't know
who to root for and it's already a
fascinating position why is it called
fantasy variation
I understand it's quite hard to know the
answer to them I'm not sure it's like
the genre it's not like a Lord of the
Rings type of position but uh it's just
I guess it takes to create a bit of
creativity to push the white pointer F3
on move three against the Karo Khan uh I
should just explain we're ignore
ignoring the lifeboard for now that one
isn't updating so this is the analysis
board we're going to focus here because
it is uh the current position and um
we'll follow it here on the central
board for now until we get things fixed
but uh crazy coincidence just two days
ago I was up until 3am in the morning
studying the fancy variation preparing
notes for a student of mine in this
opening from the black side and I said
don't go into this it's too complicated
it's too much to learn and if you're not
careful you might get attacked on the F7
Square you're very weak so I chose a
different sub variation but uh this one
decent reputation do you soon listen
that's the big question uh that's yet to
be seen I've said go memorize these
notes I doubt uh no doubt that would
have been heard but uh meanwhile caricon
a famously solid opening and uh Arjun
just tried to take gokesh out of uh more
well-known Waters I must admit I'm not
used to seeing the white Bishop on E2
normally it goes to more active squares
and uh there we go the live board is
working again so we can't trust it and
uh arjun's last move was to centralize
this Knight Knight bd2 and both sides
now will decide where to Castle and
where to put their pieces
I think the opening approach is going to
be so important in this match because
both these players Arjun and gokish they
come from the Waka school which is the
West best Westbridge on and chess
Academy they've got the same trainers
the same mentors They Know Each Other's
repertoire so well so it's really
important to surprise uh the opponent I
think that's what Arjun has managed to
do with this fantasy variation of the
karakan so nice approach and we're
talking about their uncompromising style
of play and that's exactly what we've
been what we're seeing look at those
Central pawns they look like they've
given white so much space but on the
other hand they can also turn out to be
a weakness black can't stop putting up
piling up the pressure on that E4 and
the D4 Pawn both on open files I love
the activity that gokish has currently
the Bishops are out the knights are
developed it just looks like archon
might be slightly behind in development
and one of the big problems when you
have these pawns like this as soon as
you push one the square it was previous
music covering is now handed over to
your phone so if you push this one up to
E5 that Knight sinks into the D5 Square
you're not dislodging it you don't have
another Pawn to kick it so that Knight
is very happy to stand in the center so
I feel like these decisions being very
difficult for any player origin will
have to figure out an exact plan he's
going to have to come up is it right to
push the pawn can you just slide your
queen away you need to protect those
pawns and center and black is going to
aim his forces at those pawns that are
sticking out and what a nice classy move
there from kakash uh well okay I got
there a bit early we'll see that move
happen on the board in a second uh it
looks like Black's Bishop is about to
slide around and back and uh he wants to
eye up this White Queen it's all about
putting pressure on those Central pawns
I like the Symmetry and blacks position
right now with the Bishops nicely placed
and white also has these uh pawns that
you guys were mentioning but doesn't
really have the peace development to
back it up so we will at some point see
white race to get his night out of the
way of his bishop and still a middle
game that could go in either a Direction
but right now it does look like your
cash has got a healthy position as black
out of the opening that's all you can
ask for in these very short matches to
survive with black to get a playable
position and he has achieved that
speaking of a playable position it was
already on move number eight that we
were an absolute new territory so both
these players really just want to get a
game not go into any theoretical battle
and I think lukesh is happy about that
because we know the kind of opening
preparation that Arjun has it's
phenomenal so I I like this approach
where you go for a middle game where
neither of you are familiar and you
basically get get a position with
everything to play for all three results
possible Bishop H5 the move that you
were talking about I think we're going
to see it shortly on the board it shows
that gokish even though not so many
games here knows what he's doing
yeah it seems like he knows what he's
doing and uh Arjun meanwhile he's got a
healthy enough position if if he can
hold his pawns together so he'll be
figuring out just how to uh consolidate
how to get active again and uh in terms
of well we talked about both of them
being very strong players you're not
taking side to Tanya of course who do
you think on paper is going to be better
at this format this exact time format
with the elimination
it's just a Sprint here two games that's
a good question I think archon might
just slightly have a little more
experience he's uh been in the Champions
Chester we saw him in the finals but in
terms of strength I think it's really
hard to pick both these players have
this very energetic ambitious style of
play they don't go for the draws they
always go for the option that creates a
mess on the board Arjun relies a lot
more on intuition I think super good
calculator of course but he takes
decisions which are quite intuitive at
times kukesh meanwhile is a hardcore
calculations fan he can see lines really
fast so I think it's going to be a lot
about those time scrambles with Fighting
Chess we can expect a long game and in
this format it's going to be about who
can keep the speed and the nerves when
the clock runs down it's going to be an
exciting match and if you are rooting
for any of these two Indians then share
it with us either on Twitter using the
hashtag chess Champs or in the twitch
chat we will pay close attention to that
as well and uh really really enjoy it
when you guys join in if you do have
questions comments then share it on
Twitch we'll bring up as many questions
as we can for our excellent experts in
the studio here guy you're putting 1.3
billion people in a very tight spot
right now let me tell you that both
these players have this huge fan base
because they're so mild Manner and then
they're so humble and just really nice
kids actually but on the board there's a
different side of them that you see so I
don't think it's gonna be it's gonna be
easy for the Indian fans to pick a side
today and I think a lot of them are
going to be heartbroken a lot of
celebrations at the same time yeah yeah
I tried to push you Tanya I tried to say
who's the favorite you still didn't
choose you still didn't take sides and
uh yeah impressive uh the neutrality
there but I mean while the position has
changed somewhat black has parted with
the bishop pair but that was to provoke
one of the white pawns forward and that
strong night on the Rock Solid outpost
on D5 has been established the one that
Robert was uh pointing to earlier and uh
gukesh to me on the face of things looks
like he's done a very good job of uh
just Clinging On and uh kind of
eroding uh the white porn Center here
just getting great squares for his
pieces but the question is what next and
uh Arjun now in the move will be maybe
centralizing his Rooks bringing more
pizza to the center
and uh still anyone's game one really
interesting tactic here in the position
that white has but it doesn't work David
is this knight jump to G5 imagine you go
Knight G5 and you're already threatening
a huge mate on 87 you say one second the
bishop on E2 Hanks but what happens if
black actually picks that up Queen at
seven well it's not a mate yet but the
king side steps one move but that's as
long as it's going to survive because
the Rook jumps into the attack and after
Rook F7 it would be game over but
thankfully for Arjun after Knight jumps
to G5 the bishop on H5 is hanging the
pawn on 87 is hanging the bishop can
actually slide back to G6 taking care of
everything on the board attacking
White's Queen so attempting option to
jump with the Knight but not accurate
yeah that would certainly have been the
first thing that came to mind the first
thing he calculated argenteric IC but
instead going back he decided to use his
Bishop on this diagonal creating a
battery with the White Queen and
slightly surprising to me uh the pawn is
pushed forward to H6 covering any Knight
G5 jumps and uh taking the pawn off
please but now this bishop doesn't have
too many Escape squares so uh slightly
risky here Robert yeah definitely risky
and one of the common plays against the
structure is to throw in the check flick
that in Bishop H7 check to force the
king to the corner and then bring the
bishop back to F5 and now that move G2
to G4 is very threatening because the
bishop is not well defended on the G6
Square so I feel like white has the
upper hand here uh the king for black is
less safe than the white king but the
one thing that white needs to be pay
attention to is this Pawn on D4 it's a
backwards Pawn so if black is able to
bring the queen out to B6 eventually not
now there's a knight that would be loose
on D7 that pawn can be a bit tender
that's the hope that Lucas will have
here is that he can create counter play
against that pawn yeah so uh that
sequence looks very promising for white
at least it would ask him some awkward
questions of kokesh right now let's wait
to see what Arjun does if he just wants
to play an autopilot move maybe he'll
just centralize a rook but as you say
Robert there will be at least a time a
time out for black to start creating his
own counter play so it feels like
there's a bit of urgency in the position
uh both players have played relatively
quickly up to this point it's a very
tense middle game uh let's let uh Arjun
erag I see think and Ponder his next
move now guys it's kind of hard for me
to pick a favorite I'm I'm completely
torn but I have to ask you Kaya Robert
David you've seen these two on the door
uh what do you think about this matchup
and who would you think is maybe just
slightly slightly has a better chance
I'm slightly biased um I'm a huge fan of
both of these two uh but I'm biased by
my own experiences I've played gokesh a
few times first time I think when he
just became a Grandmaster he was 12
years old and I just uh played maybe the
most boring chess imaginable eventually
bought him to death and managed to take
the point I also played him in the world
Blitz last year and I managed to grind
him down in a rook end game but Arjun
aragaisy I've played in Blitz and I've
never been crushed so badly in my life I
played him last year and he barely spent
10 seconds on his he was just playing
every move instantly just out playing me
strategically not many people were
capable of doing that in such a fashion
but it was very one-sided and he
destroyed me uh so I'm gonna say Arjun
and I think I know better than to answer
the question because uh you said you
didn't want the Indian publisher mad at
you I don't want them mad at me so I'm
just saying both these players are
awesome we're ruin them both on but in
all seriousness they both have their
different strengths I mean they think
they're both versatile players and
despite the fact that they're teenagers
they've shown some great class they have
restraints and a lot of teeners struggle
with that they're afraid to go to the
end game because they think that in the
end game they haven't studied as as
deeply no these players the opening
middle game end game they're complete
well-rounded players and I think that
for our generic I see after the Tata
steel event it's hard to forget about
all those losses I know he is already
won a match here in the air things
Masters and he qualified for division
one which is an accomplishment in and of
itself but you want to get those wins
and gukesh beat him in tata steel that
was one of those losses he probably
wants that Revenge yeah probably we now
I'm definitely not gonna answer a
favorite but uh
but I will say one thing because Ivanka
brought my attention and I think this is
super cute uh sort of underlining the
age of these two uh players aragaisi uh
behind him is a shelf and in one of
those shelves is all his teddy bears
so I like that he has a lot of teddy
bear fans behind him at least yes
cheering him on bringing him luck
everyone has a lucky mascot right you
guys or just me I don't know
[Laughter]
um I I don't have it here with me annoy
actually but I have a Pikachu like a big
cuddly Pikachu really that's uh it's
been at the end of my bed uh in England
for like 15 years
Pokemon fan yeah big Pokemon fan yeah I
missed those days on the game boy
yeah when he missed those days you
probably still have that Game Boy dust
it off play it I know there are people
in my life who wouldn't approve these
days but yeah maybe after this
tournament did you did you guys practice
the throw Pikachu I Choose You
uh no even though I'm not that nerdy
hi Mr I miss the Pokemons yeah everyone
gets into games and uh sports or in
certain ways right and that was my way
into gaming in general just the
competitive aspect of Pokemon and nice
trying to beat my friends and uh that
kind of transported over to the Chess
World how about a chess set with only
Pokemons that would be super cool who
would be the king and the Queen
Professor Oak Professor Oak would be uh
would he be the king
Brock and Misty yeah Misty would be my
queen
back to the chest
so a few moves here Robert you predicted
the future White's Bishop did land up on
that F5 Square he's really forced black
to start retreating that glorious Knight
on D5 is forced to a passive post both
of those Black Knights now a bit tied up
defending what do we think of uh
developments here I mean I like White's
position you just have so much more
space the King on H1 it looks like it's
a bit Breezy vulnerable Queen D5 comes
in making use of a pin on the diagonal
but black is well defended for now the
knights are protecting their Bishop on
G6 that's of vital importance and the D4
Pawn remains a backwards Pawn a future
Target so I just feel like white
Exposition is a bit flimsy so if Arjun
is not careful things could fall apart
but for now he's controlled those dark
squares thanks to that beautiful Bishop
on B4 it covers the length of diagonal
can stick its teeth into the D6 square
at some point or trade itself off for a
night if the moment calls for it so I
like the look of White's position for
now I'm just worried how the trajectory
game might go if he doesn't be accurate
here and land some kind of attack there
have been some very dangerous and
committed Decisions by white we are
praising White's positions but I think
with every pawn move there have also
been a lot of weaknesses in White's camp
we see that D5 Square which was first
used by black snide and now the queen
lands there Rook has been moved to D1 to
defend that default keep on but we are
talking about how good whites Bishops
look I think it can be very dangerous to
play this kind of a position as well
imagine the Black Knight Landing onto E6
right now he's developed a final piece
the only piece that was not part of the
plan gukesh brings The Rook to the
center of the board as well always watch
out for threats like the Knight taking
the bishop forcing the white Pawn to
recapture and then the black Bishop
sliding back to H5 uh David where it
will hit this pin Knight now not just
pin to the king but also the rook and D1
I would be scared to play with white
hair yeah the key word there is
committal there's no going back now for
a guy said his pawns will not Retreat
he'll always be weak on the light
squares and in the current position as
both of you were alluding to there the
white king will always be weak so uh
yeah how do you proceed here if you're
aragaisy you need to justify those
commitments you've made you need to keep
stepping forward it's like a bike you
need to keep pedaling otherwise you'll
fall off and uh here I'm wondering how
we continue the attack it would be very
attempting to post up the bishop on this
night out nice outpost on D6
to be honest though I'm running out of
other ideas I really want to get my king
off this diagonal but it feels too slow
to take a time out and put it on a
slightly safer Square it feels like you
need to do something but he doesn't
really see what to do right now I don't
I've got to be honest and he's burning
time on the clock and black is maximize
right look at all the black's pieces
they're staring at the White Center at
some point their Knight on E7 will chop
off the bishop on F5 and then once the
pawn recaptures the bishop will take use
of the newly free H5 Square so I think
we could see a variation like this and
that would be a problem for white the
Knight is loose it's pinned in multiple
directions that's quite scary stuff so I
do think that gukesh has played
excellent chess and if I'm looking at
some Origins perspective maybe it's time
to get rid of that beautiful Knight on
E7 the bishop looks great but wow he
just had to push forward H4 he's showing
no fear whatsoever yeah but first
Roberts I think he made a very wise
decision he did get rid of that black
knight so at least now if there is a
bishop trade then no way to attack this
pinned piece and suddenly White's poor
another lunch they will start breaking
forward and storming the black king side
and uh yeah H4 it's middle again but
once you've said a you might as well say
B just throw them all towards the black
king in this case once you've said g you
might as well see it and there's really
terrifying to see White's position and
this is one of those games don't try
this at home your own Pawns in front of
your own King are supposed to be there
to Shield it now of course both these
youngsters they're super cat they're
super at calculating and they will pay
concrete variations but these can be so
dangerous I still like Black's position
it just felt feels like it's more safe
no problems on the black king all the
pieces are playing just so many loose
spots in arjun's position and I see that
our eval Bar says that everything's fine
but from a practical perspective I would
pick black any day of the week yeah
often in these positions especially in
this time format you just want a
position that's easy to play easy to
handle you don't have to calculate too
much here for kakash until white really
breaks open some lines some files
towards the black king it feels like you
don't have to work out too many things
first you need a plan though so that's
why gukesh is thinking bring out that
night that night needs to come into the
game and I like the idea of playing
Knight E6 it's a move that we've been
talking about uh notice that F4 square
is a weakness a nice spot for the Knight
to jump into what is really interesting
to see is how fearlessly Arjun is
playing he's also keeping control on his
clock and making sure that he doesn't
fall back behind too much but I think
this is the kind of position David where
you really need time on the clock to
navigate when things get tricky and I
see that kukesh has gone on to improve
that night really logical approach
you're also targeting the D4 Pawn so
watch out for all these weaknesses that
you have voluntarily created in your
Camp yeah and this is a temporary Pawn
sacrifice but I don't think once you get
tempted to capture this bishop yes the
White Queen can back it up and take this
Pawn but you have opened a line towards
this piece we've mentioned in a few
variations now that this Knight is a
huge Target due to the pin and yeah
Suddenly It's just going to fall off the
board it's attacked once If you defend
it again then okay all sorts of problems
here and Knight fork for example hitting
the white Rook hitting the White Queen
and you could also just slide across
your rook and eventually you'll
overwhelm White's defenses Suddenly It's
all backfired all those Pawn pushers so
Arjun he wants to maintain the status
quo he doesn't want to open up lines
because that will only uh be a sign of
trouble for the white king and therefore
he steps forward maybe even planting his
King on G3 behind the wall of Pawns uh
Brave stuff but yeah still nothing wrong
with it still in the balance the best
thing that gukesh has done is look at
that Clark management I feel like
throughout the everything's Masters he's
been ahead on the clock so he keeps that
lead and with the black pieces his King
is the safer of the two but I do like
that last move from origin he steps out
of any pins and we keep talking about
this trade the tension between the
Bishops on the light Square diagonal
black does not want to take the bishop
on F5 because it helps White Drive other
Pawn forward so black sufficient looks
excellent It's about coming up with
ideas maybe you'll try to break create a
pawn exchange at some moment but those
decisions are not easy so good cash is
leading the clock that's I think the
most important thing at the moment King
H2 a nice move just side stepping from
the fin and I think white has a threat
here you were talking about how Robert
black should not take that Bishop on F5
white wants to force black to do that on
the next move imagine advancing that
Harry the H Bond you go to H5 the bishop
and G6 will have no squares left and
have to take a call to trade on F5 and
now black would be super happy if white
was the one making that decision to open
that file but if black has to do it on
white stems then not such a happy
decision to be made so gokish now taking
a little bit of time here critical
moment a move like a night jump comes to
mind you know it's always so tempting to
get your knight into your opponent's
Camp yeah let's check out what happens
uh we're looking for ideas here for
gokesh his time advantage meanwhile all
disappearing now but if he does jump in
this is a call to just Advance the king
forward I'm hesitant to suggest it but
the similar ideas do appear in openings
like the French defense Robert's
favorite there you do often bring your
king up just uh nothing else to do you
have to kick away enemy pieces from your
half of the board you have to cover
squares and the King does at least Force
the Knight backwards just to show
Tanya's Point as well if we do nothing
for gokash if you just push a Pawn on
the other side of the board kind of a
relevant move here then white does get
the opportunity to break the tension in
uh arjun's favorite in this case and
suddenly the difference here is that the
Black Knight can't use the square
because the White Knight is no longer
pinned if you do jump white will be more
than happy to trade off and suddenly
these white pawns are stepping forward
uh suddenly it's bad news for the black
king suddenly that black king which
looked safe as houses it's uh all out in
the open after a move like F6 so uh
Potential Threat on the board and kukash
doesn't look too comfortable he goes for
this night jump you predicted it Tanya
will we see the king step forward to
kick it out
the one good thing about Knight to F4 is
that the idea of pushing that H bar now
might not be as strong because after the
trades of the bishop you're forced to
recapture with the queen I think because
you can't take it with the pawn as the
H5 bond is now hanging video move King
to G3 that is brave David uh if Arjun
finds it that's going to be super
impressive we've heard King is a piece
in the end game but in this position
how is it still just marching forward
like that and not getting checkmated I
think the knight's gonna have to hide
that after King up to G3 you'll swap
Bishops it doesn't seem like it's
something you want to do but now the G4
Pawn captures the H5 square is available
to the Knight and is white really going
to go King G4 don't do it David don't do
it it looks fun right the Knight is
actually kind of Trapped over there so
what does black do in response I mean
there must be tactics saving block here
we see the eval bar suggesting that it's
about uh level but that's dynamic
equality that you need to find a series
of only moves because your king is that
on G4 but on the other hand the Black
Knight is trapped in King G3 step one
has been played by Arjun eragisi he has
shown no fear of this entire game I
think that King is going all the way up
to G4 this is wild if we got that
position with the King to G4
I I I'll be speechless which doesn't
happen very often
wow very brave played from Eric icy and
uh now both players are around the four
minute mark this one is going to end up
in a Time scramble and it's still going
to be wild I think this position
guarantees a bit of chaos I can't
imagine the Queen's coming off and some
really stable end game it doesn't look
like that type of position but Robert
does he even have an option apart from
taking that bishop and walking into this
line that we're talking about with white
skin marching all the way to G4 to win a
knight on H5 because you got actually
fall back with the Knight anymore now
it's too late the bishop and G6 might be
hanging yeah and the H5 move that we've
been advocating for as well so I feel
like you're right it is the time has
come where you have to take this bishop
but what's troubling me and I was just
praising gukesh's clock management is
that something he's thinking he made the
night move and the King came up and now
he actually is retreating his Knight
back to E6 but spending a lot of time so
he does not feel comfortable right now
and we're saying chaos origin erige he's
kind of an agent of chaos he's gonna
throw that H Pawn up the board off for a
trade and the take with his Jeep on and
try to use it as a battering ram and
open up the black king yeah suddenly
he's going to be sweating gokash he's
not going to be feeling comfortable at
all still questions if the Knight moves
for example uh of whether you cannot
break things open with your king out on
such a vulnerable Square as well but it
definitely feels like things are turning
in White's favor and he doesn't hesitate
he's uh trying to speed up a bit on the
clock here I Regice he's trying to
hustle on the board as well and we have
that position in front of us look how
strong these pawns are a few moves ago I
agree with Tanya I thought black was
Rock Solid but not anymore and everybody
if he picks this moment well to push one
of these pawns forward he should be able
to launch a breakthrough it does feel
very strong for white not sure if now is
the moment or maybe it's time to run
away hide and then just get your Rook to
an open file first before we start
attacking matter of taste what would we
do here in the studio go through the
attack now I think such a big deal
though is that black doesn't really have
a follow-up you would love to put a move
C5 as black open up the position but the
D4 pawn and the queen cover the square
so I do think that with that being
unavailable to black white does have a
move so I think you can fix your queen
the queen on C2 looks good I might bring
it back to scene one and up to F4 just
making the king feel safer and going for
that H6 Pawn because if you throw in the
move F6 and black is unable to take it
that spells Doom for the black king in
the corner yeah just a sample variation
showing uh what could happen if things
go wrong for black the queen could jump
in and this one's gonna be game over
it's gonna end in chapter mate very very
shortly so that would be a very sneaky
move instead he centralizes his rook and
uh also looks decent to me preparing
potentially a pawn push a bit later on
but good catch now has a move or two to
try and uh keep things under control
maybe parking the night on the defensive
square like this one is what he needs to
do it's not pleasant it's not a great
Square aesthetically but
yeah go cash on the back foot at least
with a small time Advantage still wow
this one started off so so excitingly
super exciting and I'm just amazed that
arjun's nerves in this one advancing
those spawns and not stopping at that
also advancing the king all the way to
G3 he has decided to move the Rook to E1
so making sure all the pawns stay
defended at some point he can also look
at a lift with the Rook or getting the
queen to the centralized E4 Square it's
a really nice Square to put a piece on
to keep everything together it's one of
those super rare positions in chess
where white skin on G3 with no bond
Shield is absolutely safe yeah I guess
modern chess yeah if there are no pieces
around to defend to attack it then it's
not that weak surely but uh yeah it is
brave nonetheless and uh we're seeing
some comments here using sides who are
who are the fans supporting yeah I feel
like I haven't seen anyone actually
choose a song everyone except for you
David we know just to chill out and just
say hello great chess we do not want to
have an angry fan base on our heels
likes both of them it's so hard to pick
one you know they've got this similar
versatile style that you were talking
about they're so similar and that
strength both just amazing people off
the board and super strong on the board
you know playing playing ambitious chess
regardless of who they're playing
against they play fearlessly including
when they're playing against each other
and I think that's the reason it's hard
to pick and have a favorite
I did see a comment in the twitch chat
uh someone calling Arjun agent of chaos
yeah I said that yeah they're just
they're just taking my words and where's
the copyright somebody you know play
back the video
and I think Robert this game is such a
big example of Arjun being the agent of
chaos I mean he literally has created
chaos out of nothing there was no need
to go for any of this but he has just
made a mess on the board and right now
it looks like he's being rewarded and
he's in control of that message that
sort of his style as well it always
feels that way no matter how complex it
becomes he always seems to have
something up his sleeve he always seems
to have foreseen into the future uh
sufficiently to uh yeah to turn things
in his favor and if we think of Chess as
a battle game then it feels like white
is taking over the battlefield he's
stepped up to the fifth rank he's
controlling all the squares black is
just kind of huddling away in his half
now just hoping for the best and apart
from the black queen I really hate those
black pieces not well placed at all and
the Clark don't like that at all for a
good guess right now or generic icy I
mean he looks cool as a cucumber you
would not expect that he is in the
middle of a crazy position and look at
this move the Rook slides next to the
king it's both defensive and aggressive
in some positions because if that G7
Pawn just throw it off the board then
there's a rook in line with the white
king that's why the white Rook steps in
front so now we have defense mixed with
offense multi-purpose moves by both
players white has so much extra space
but black is defending very accurately
the clock though is going to be a weapon
for our generic IC yep he's so quick
he's so ruthless when he when he gets
the chance Arjun and I do fear for
gakesh this last move retreating this
Rook isn't one he would have made
happily and now how can we add extra
ingredients to this attack watch Rick at
the bottom of the board on F1 feels a
bit left out it wants to line up with
this fellow Rook on the G file and
finally that brave King that Intrepid
don't worry it steps back and clearing
the path for the G file but when you're
under attack on the side of the board
you have to strike in the center I think
black needs to push the beat Pawn to
push the C Pawn next and if black is
able to crack what's impressive Pawn
chain from D4 to E5 maybe then there are
some chances so I really think it's now
or never for gukesh because you can't
just sit and do nothing forever and oh
wow and he plays a pawn push on the
other side of the board and the
evaluation board doesn't really react
negatively so that's a an impressive
choice but if that white knight goes up
to G6 that would be Checkmate I guess
the Black Knight can't step out the way
but it's looking scary for the black
king yeah F6 is another Super Brave move
in this position I mean Imagine That
Knight on G6 it's game over but as
you're mentioning Knight H4 is an option
here threatening that ridiculous
smothered made on the black king but
then black has this defensive advancing
his own Knight to G5 blocking that G5
blocking that Rook on G4 and creating a
very important love for the King on H7
yeah not quite smothered mate here yeah
you do manage to escape and uh really
creative stuff it does kind of go
against conventional wisdom of touching
pawns on the side that you're weaker and
Arjun swings this queen across lining up
on the G file some tactics he's under 10
seconds now go cash and he has to plug
that g-file with his Knight and now
could we be heading towards an end game
if there's a nitrate suddenly the Queens
might disappear as well who do we think
this will favor I think if ever is white
because of the impressive Pawn chain uh
you could swap all the pieces and then
plant your Pawn on E6 that is going to
be a protected pass pawn and the
position is a bit closed for the moment
but that allows white the time to bring
that King play King of the Hill go to
the E4 Square then try to open up more
files for your Rooks so I feel like
black is really playing on the defensive
here However if those pawns are
blockaded then maybe black has enough
time to go after some of White's pawns
but I do think that white has the upper
hand yeah so ardrin potentially just
weighing up the pros and cons of going
into the end game he can keep the
tension for removal too longer if he
wants to but uh let's go back and see
what he's done okay he's pushed that
pawn forward first so the option of
trading the knights trading the Queens
still available to him could cash around
12 seconds he's playing purely on
Instinct right now yeah and uh okay he
does bring his Knight forward so
allowing a queen trade but he wants to
plant his Knight on this G6 Square cage
that black king for later on there will
be mating Nets there will be mating
patterns that gokesh has to fight
against for the rest of the game we have
the first result of today it's a great
start for Wesley so he has won the first
game with the white pieces against Alexa
Serana taking the lead in their match
and the loser is quarterfinals it is
best out of two rapid games to decide
these matches on the losers bracket it's
looking very good for Wesley Seoul right
now
yeah it's also looking good for Arjun
erag I see I think he's found a really
uh positive version of that end game we
were discussing a moment ago once white
tonight does end up on the G6 Square
after centralizing his King then uh yeah
he's got full control it's time for a
night sacrifice take those past Parts
Knight takes E6 you'll get two pawns
right there and then you'll also be able
to snag the H5 Pawn three pawns is worth
a night at least from a prospective
material worth but look at this
unfortunately for Google he just pushed
his a pawn now the trades it's not going
to be enough because that's has Pawn is
cemented there on E6 he's playing with
seconds look at the clock
just whoa seconds left we see the clock
really reacting here struggling to keep
up because they're playing 97 96 .
yeah Tanya it looks like a winning
tactic now you can give a check okay the
players they are not calculating they're
just relying on instincts and this looks
strong too he's just simply going to
advance his E Pawn forward bring that
white uh White Rook to the top of the
board and game over it's done he just I
just pushed the pawn then I think that
forces resonation on the spot yep and uh
here we go we see it guys yeah once Rook
is gonna reach that eighth Rank and
break the black defenses the bar reacts
and Arjun is going to take the win he's
been going in its favor for a long time
but there we go I think he's going to
confirm it go cash lean's back is he
gonna resign no defense now for black
there we go result wow Arjun Ergo I see
he strikes first in the big Indian match
against good Cash winning the first game
in their losers quarterfinals that means
gukesh has to win the next uh game game
two to take this one to an Armageddon
watch a game some Chaos on the board
entertainment David take us through the
highlights yeah some crucial moments in
this game but just want to highlight one
that Robert actually mentioned but
kokesh simply didn't have enough time to
calculate and it was this critical
moment white is trying to play King of
the Hill my favorite variant by the way
trying to get the king into the center
of the board but this did allow black
one moment to save the game Knight takes
porn getting rid of those strong white
pawns would potentially have turned
things around somewhat what black does
get two pawns for the night this is a
check and maybe a third Pawn would drop
off on the edge of the board later
suddenly you've got rid of the strongest
part of White's position and great
chances to save the game instead he let
the pawn survive he simply moved his
Rook to the wrong side of the board and
we've if we fast forward to the end now
we saw the final stages of this game the
white Rook centralized and uh once the
pawn started stepping forward in the
center there was no way to save the game
Rook d8 eliminating the blockader and
white was about to make a new Queen
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
starting off the day with two decided
games Arjun Eric icy takes the first
point against his fellow Indian what a
game it was an incredible game I have to
say I'm slightly disappointed with the
outcome because
the cash pay the caracon and I love it
he actually played the variation that I
recommended in my book but okay it was a
great game
so
I'm not sure very nice all right uh
we're gonna keep digging into uh the
games of uh the first set of games today
but if you're not a subscriber on Twitch
here is a twitch freak
[Music]
and we also have to talk about the other
game that happened Wesley so starting
out with the win against Alexa Serana
what happened in this one yeah it was a
very fascinating game actually it's
Alexis Arana came in with a plan he just
wanted to survive with the black pieces
he wanted to grovel for the draw
unfortunately he played a very imprecise
move and Wesley he took a long pause and
he used his time very wisely because
then he struck and it was
Alexi Serrano is King who was just
caught in the most Dreadful of positions
and Wesley I have to say his clock
handling was just magnificent because
often he was playing with less than a
minute on the clock and he just played
it perfectly wow so Wesley so seems to
be in top shape yeah absolutely you know
he's just not pulling a foot wrong
he's incredible Wesley so and he can't
decide the match in the next game Alexey
Serrano he has to win the next game to
take it to Armageddon any other result
and he is knocked out now you did bring
with you a very cool puzzle today as
well Ivanka are people getting engaged
they're a puzzle ah they definitely are
I see a lot of the right answers however
this puzzle this study is actually quite
multi-faceted because you have to
remember black has two pawns it's not
just one Pawn that can run so I'm just
gonna put that out there it's white to
play it's much harder than it looks but
when you find the solution oh my God it
will give you such a buzz wow
share your answer using hashtag chess
Champs on Twitter or share your answer
in the twitch chat gather friends family
whoever you are with and try to solve
it's a very it's a difficult puzzle even
for the title players like yourself it's
not difficult because it is the ideas
are quite straightforward but there's
just that one twist that keeps on coming
up and once you've figured out you'll
get it and you'll be like let me share
this with everybody I mean chess is like
that yeah best feeling to solve puzzles
and best feelings to win games as well
the second set of games on the losers
quarter finals is coming up
wow he just had to push forward H4 he is
showing no fear whatsoever yeah but
first Roberts I think he made a very
wise decision he did get rid of that
Black Knights the king G3 step one has
been played by Arjun eragisi he has
shown no fear this entire game I think
that King has been all the way up to G4
all right we're getting ready for game
twos on the losers quarter finals two
players they will have to win their
games right now to take it to Armageddon
two players can decide it now
withdrawals or wins yukash against Eric
icy and Alexa serranar against Wesley so
so Robert what should we expect now from
the second set of games here Alexa
Serana gets the white pieces we know how
strong he is his record is almost
impeccable so he does have a shot and
then the other matchup between the
Indian Juniors it looked like a great
game from originara geisey it's going to
be tough for googash to bounce back but
if anyone can do it I think go cash can
what what do you tell yourself Tanya
when you're heading into must win
situations you have to just stop
thinking about what's happened and you
don't have to think that it is a
must-win situation he's still got three
games in the day so he starts with the
white pieces that's a positive and of
course knowing acacia's style of play
once again we can expect a long big
fight here are not quick draws in this
match I think you just have to keep
going and make sure that you don't go on
tilt nothing has happened right now it
was a tough game could have gone either
way and I think kokesh will show what
he's made of he will try his best most
important is that he doesn't lose his
cool just yet in uh soccer or football
David we often say that two one is the
most dangerous lead to have in chess it
seems to be kind of dangerous to have
that one point lead when you only need a
draw that's when those blunders often
happen yeah we've seen it many times
before in previous seasons of the tour
it's even Magnus Carlsen can be affected
by this uh phenomenon normally the
players when they're leading they just
want a draw they take negative decisions
they take passive decisions and these
top players they're good enough to
punish you if you're not playing your
best so normally they do say the best
way to get the desired result to get the
draw that you need is to play your
normal game and it's incredibly hard to
do psychologically your cash has the
white pieces in this must win situation
something on here
who you expect ing uh to win this next
game okay guys this says gokish's last
chance it's just two games yeah it's not
four games and I just realized that I've
been saying he has three games but this
is a win-on-demand game for gokish
actually so there's no time to take
things easy he's gonna come out all guns
blazing this is his final shot yeah
it is must win for both Q cash and Alexa
Serrata and here we go yeah I was
wondering why you were looking at me
but uh yeah
I think she was looking to you because
you chose who you were rooting for and
everyone still is out to get you
I was right I should mention
you are gold medalist after all no
surprise that you're correct it's not
gonna be easy and we do have a Queen's
Gambit accepted in this game so it's
gonna be another big fight and the good
news for gokish is that well it is his
final game but he has the white pieces
and that's exactly what you want yeah
you want the white pieces and he did win
on Demand with white in the Armageddon
yesterday against Ralph memadov and can
he repeat that trick Arjun of course
very well booked up and it's the Queen's
Gambit accepted but it's not maybe the
traditional Queen's Gambit accepted
because White's Knight has come out to
the C3 Square very early that does
reduce your options often that white
note wants to find different squares or
you want to get your king castle first
and start attacking in the center
instead kukesh keeps maximum attention
he Retreats his bishop and says okay
we're just gonna get a game we're just
gonna play chess
and Arjun I doubt he'll have prepared
this exact position before can he get
that type of solid position that he will
be craving in this game bringing out his
Knight putting pressure on White Center
we might well soon see an iqp position
with an isolated porn for white yeah and
these positions they start off quietly
but even if the Queens get traded that's
not the end of the story a lot of people
play these types of positions for a win
despite some of the limited material so
at the current setup we see that white
has three minor pieces developed black
has just developed his second and this
move A3 it's a very clever move you're
getting ready to take the black pawn C5
and now after the bishop will recapture
you thrust that pawn forward to B4 so
that's sort of what's on the agenda in
this position is that you can expand
then develop your dark Square Bishop to
a useful diagonal by fan ketoing it and
that is what gukesh is looking for a
quiet start but there's more bite that
initially meets the eye yeah and often
it's a really tricky intricate waiting
game here because black doesn't have
that useful to move if you do move your
Bishop then white will force you to move
it for a second time by capturing as
Robert mentions and you've kind of lost
a Tempo if you moved the bishop twice in
the opening so do you release the
tension now Kakashi is saying please
take me please at least clarify the pawn
structure and now we get a classical iqp
position isolated Queen's pawn and uh
plenty of ideas there that we'll explain
if we get to that position but uh if you
don't go for either of those ideas what
else well one of the ideas that we
should point out is that black cannot
pick up that pawn on D4 even though
you've got the Knight and the queen uh
attacking it and white has only one
Defender but watch out David if you do
get greedy in this position eventually
there will be a massive discover check
and you end up losing your queen and the
game on the spot so the Queen the pawn
is actually not hanging very often
you're absolutely right what black does
is to decide the center you don't want
to waste that move with the bishop
taking it at once and then forced to
again move it the next time when you
have to recapture it on C5 so I wouldn't
be surprised if Arjun decides to
actually clarify the situation and then
develop his pieces so that at least he
doesn't lose that Tempo yep because
three one option I guess uh it would be
typical as well to push a Pawn on the
queen side but are you ready for that
you haven't developed too many pieces
okay he does trade off in the center we
see this isolated Queen's Pawn it's not
captured of course as Tanya showed that
and uh the position now uh is about just
getting pieces out to good squares I do
kind of have a bias again towards the
white position here just because I
played isolated Queen's Pawn positions
my whole youth but uh yeah it tends to
be out of fashion these days uh to play
this type of structure with white but I
played those positions my whole Youth
too and I often lost them so I have
become biased against them in a way but
look at the latest move that is just in
played Harry the H Pawn is thrown
forward that should be no surprise the
white Bishops are aiming in that
direction and now you're anticipating
well Arjun do you really want a castle
kingside where that pawn was just thrown
forward I'm not sure you do it looks
very dangerous so at least you're
putting that fear in arjun's heart and
he says well I'm not touching anything
on that side of the board let me throw
my Pawn for it on the queen side so it's
going to be interesting to see where the
Kings go from here wow H4 I was not
expecting that move but then once again
of course has to do everything to create
a mess on the board he has to win this
on demand so it is the approach that is
Guided by the math situation and Argent
takes no time at all to respond to this
well not the most popular move in the
position and immediately plays on the
other side of the board now this is a
very thematic idea to take out your
other Bishop you want to fiance tattoo
it on this long diagonal it's where you
want your Bishop it is ideally placed
Arjun stopping down before he decides to
Castle what Tanya what a move he's has
he Mouse lips
he's just played Kings F1 forgetting
that and castling is legal in chess but
I think his idea is to keep the Rook on
the h-file to attack this is just
revolutionary stuff Robert yeah it
almost looks like a mistake right can I
please put my H Pawn back and he says
well now that I've gone to H4 let's keep
it chugging along he goes to H5 and he's
just telling origin you are not castling
and if you do I am going to attack your
king so the question for Arjun and it's
actually quite a big one is do you stop
that pawn in its track it's gone far
enough he just answered my question as
soon as I uh released it he plays H6 and
you are going no further and he has a
rook lift so it's clear white is playing
for a win Tanya as you said it's because
the match situation
but going for it all costs often
backfires you need a solid setup a
strategy and I feel like he's just
playing for a win a little bit of
subjective Chess at the moment this King
F1 that was a shocker and one would want
to believe it's a mouse slip but once
you've made that H Bond move all the way
forward it could just be part of the
opening plan here for white you want to
now continue attacking on the king side
The Rook will eventually also land on G3
on the Open Fire Arjun meanwhile will
try to delay his castling as much as
possible because once you do that then
white gets a clear path and I think it's
going to be interesting to find out if
King to F1 the last move was that a
mouse slip or was it not cookies it's
also hard to tell with this camera I
mean
you have no idea what's going on yeah
definitely uh calling that some
revolutionary stuff earlier today Robert
you called the Arjun agent of chaos was
it and we do have a question for you on
uh in our twitch chat from dayuti asking
you what is the difference between the
playing styles of gokash and Arjun it's
funny because I'm reading the question
on screen it looks like the origin has
that's a compliment to me like if I
could be in the same sentence as Arjun
thank you very much
um what are their playing Styles I have
always felt that origen is quite a
restrained player as is I mean I do
think that there's quite a lot of
similarity between the two but I do feel
like Arjun he is shown in his most
successful tournaments that he will
punch you like he is ready to fight at
any moment and I do feel like gukesh the
style we're seeing in this match is an
arjun's favorite I just think he is the
more aggressive player of the two so
typically likes a bit more of a calmer
start to the games whereas arjun's
always ready to fight
actually I should mention of single cash
play H4 at the kind of most surprising
times before I know that he said in
interviews he didn't work with a
computer at all until he was about 15 so
about a year and a half ago and then
when he started working with an engine
he started realizing pushing the H Pawn
in all of these Queen spawn openings it
isn't it is a concept and and uh I
remember in red goesins he was starting
to play H4 in every position in Vienna
games he was starting to push uh H4 and
uh he's doing it here doesn't feel
correct computer won't really approve
but uh it's certainly going to keep
arching on his toes and sometimes
especially in these really tense
pressure-filled situations all you need
to do is ask your opponent a new
question that they've never faced before
and uh I must admit once I played a very
similar idea against Wesley so and after
the game Wesley was like what's up with
you you know King F1 is not good right I
was like yeah okay I didn't get an
attack and I lost I got mated but but uh
yeah if he if he pulls it off here go
catch them fairly and that's the worst
type type of kind of things to receive
Awards receives because it wasn't a nice
guy so if he's like asking you you know
you've done something wrong it's kind of
when I'm not angry I'm disappointed
exactly but then again if dukesh goes on
and wins this game if he gets a big
attack against the black king we'll say
this was just genius from the get-go and
uh yeah you wouldn't have seen these
ideas these types of ideas with H4 King
F1 15 20 years ago but uh this is modern
Jazz yeah modern chess and especially
with the alpha zero coming in upon
advances the Harry the H bond is the new
star of the Chess World but I have to
say with this bishop move it is a
natural looking developing move you do
defend your Pawn on D4 but it also
invites the Black Knight to jump in and
attack that Bishop with the tempo not
just that what this move does is it
locates the F6 Square for the black
Bishop to land on uh remember that
isolated Queen spawn that we were
talking about it does have the potential
to come under Fire once the bishop finds
it way to F6 so this looks like it could
be a difficult middle game for Archer
for gokish archon as a player loves the
initiative we always see him go for more
aggressive more attacking positions
whenever he has the option to create the
chaos he will take it with both hands
meanwhile gokish
he's a more solid player so I feel these
kind of positions like the ones where we
have where we've got no castling Kings
marching up the board pawns all over the
place they perhaps suit Arjun a little
more than gokish yeah you're taking
sights Tanya I'm impressed slowly but
surely
in and uh yeah just a solid queen move
there very sensible stuff getting ready
to bring the final piece to the party
that white Rook on A1 is going to slide
towards the center soon and with
isolated Queen's pawns uh in the
position watch out for a pawn break in
the center if white can ever
successfully throw his Central Pawn
forward play D5 open up lines especially
while the black king is in the center
then things will start to turn in this
favor
um I like this last move by gokash and I
have to say yesterday I was getting a
Ralph my meta of a lot of credit in his
game against good cash because he was
just playing for a win he needed to
muddy the waters and in this one that's
exactly what gukesh has achieved so uh
from the perspective needing a win this
is not just a solid position nothing is
symmetrical here chances for both sides
I think he's doing the right thing even
though king of one was surprising now
they look at the position I'm surprised
by how much I like it for white because
at some moment there will be that Rook
on H3 it lifted up the board it could
slide one square over to attack the
Knight and the pawn behind it the D4
Pawn is pretty well defended for at
least for the the time being and as you
were mentioning David if you're not
looking out for it that move d4 to D5
when you have an eyesight upon you
always think about pushing it forward
and with that black king in the center
you have to look out for the E file as
well so I'm nervous for the black king
even though objectively it looks fine or
the eval bar saying black is doing
pretty well I just see some problems for
origin to solve and it's not easy in a
rapid time control
wow and he's just castled into the eye
of the storm this is brave stuff again
from Arjun we saw him be adventurous
with this King in the last game but uh
wow he's really kind of waving the red
flag he's saying come at me and uh good
question now surely he's going to switch
his Rook across and start playing
towards the enemy King I think what
black is relying on is that if you do
make that move you of course are not
going to fall back with your knight
because then the H Pawn is hanging but
that F Bond and we know Arjun he doesn't
care about Pawn advances in front of the
king that F Pawn will move forward not
only defending that key Knight on G4 but
also blocking out White's Bishop on the
diagonal so I'm expecting the Knight on
G4 to stay there for a while yeah it's
actually surprisingly hard to get rid of
this piece it acts as a blocker just uh
controlling all of White's potential
activity so with this in mind maybe this
is not such an effective maneuver bring
the white Rook across right now how else
could uh White try to get the
attack going Kickstart it and give it
some momentum I guess with the standard
you slide your Rook over to D1 behind
you I said upon bring your Bishop back
to B1 at some point then line your
bishop and queen up on the light Square
diagonal try to threaten that Checkmate
black can always block that diagonal
with that pawn push F7 to F5 but that
creates other weaknesses namely the E6
Pawn so then that Bishop 1v1 can slide
to a new diagonal over to A2 and this is
maximum pressure on the black position
so we can see how black parries off one
thread at a time but then there are
maybe some underlying weaknesses that
will be difficult to defend yeah I like
it just uh slow and steady just bring
another piece into the game and you will
get attacking chances later I don't
think there's a need to start
calculating too much now once you see
that maybe Shifting The Rook across
Isn't So effective then you just okay
take your time out bring another piece
in save some time on the clock for later
good cash does have a minute or so uh
advantage on the clock and still very
promising position if you look at all
the pieces as well after this Rook move
all of them are so centralized for
whites these are kind of textbook
centralization pieces for white if
you're teaching a beginner how to place
their pieces in the opening you say look
at this Knight's in the center Bishops
next to them pointing at both sides of
the board yes the white king looks a bit
odd but it's almost as if it's castled
now and the white Rook isn't necessarily
worse placed here than it would be in
the center of the board so I'm still
looking very good I love this plan
Robert Ice uh the more I look at it with
just dropping the bishop back keeping
the options open also hinting at uh
pushing with D5 it definitely gives
Arjun a lot to think about
uh if he goes for it the reason that
dukesh is taking his time and I see he's
finally made a decision and made the
move Bishop to F4 instead one of the
plans that black has that white needs to
watch out for is play on the other side
of the board as white has placed
everything on the king side eyeing that
King the B4 break is a resource that
black always has to try and get that
counter play because if there are trades
the Knight will move forward the bishop
on B7 suddenly opens up eyeing that
Knight on F3 and the reason that white
has put that Bishop on F4 is that he's
taken a key square away in Black's Camp
Queen on C7 would be an extremely
strongly base placed Queen because
Imagine That Knight jumping onto H2 uh
David and maybe we can just Mark the
squares here once the bishop trades off
the Knight on F3 there are all these
forking ideas that become a reality so
Bishop F4 is actually a very strong
preemptive move taking away a key Square
from black screen
just to show that variation Knight H2 uh
that's uh some very effective winning
strategy for black I've got to say but
uh maybe there is a threat in the
position is this something to be careful
of I'm not sure we can go for it now if
black does initiate that idea that you
mentioned Tanya with B4 because suddenly
it looks like white is delivering mate
but the Black Knight can leap back act
as the hero and uh also you attack the
queen just in time uh I guess we have
prevented also uh this F5 break so now
we are threatening perhaps to shift the
Rook across if black does take a timeout
now black support push is not uh not
possible simply because this E6 Pawn
will drop off lots of variations we're
showing here but all very relevant to uh
the player's plans and I just want to
add that the bishop was protecting the
pawn on D4 but that's not necessary
because of tactics you see that if the
Black Knight Scoops off the pawn on D4
the Knight takes back and once the queen
swoops into the D4 square that Knight on
G4 is loose the queen will take it and
that Rook on H3 is doing very important
work protecting that light Square Bishop
all of White's pieces are offended black
would lose a piece and thus lose the
game so that pawn on D4 is defended
tactically and that's a huge moment for
agukesh to bring his Bishop out into the
open and I feel like with Arjun spending
this time here it's going to be
increasingly difficult because there
will be an attack you're not gonna lose
a piece in the moment but with Rook G3 a
new threat with of course Rook from A1
sliding into the action at any moment
Queen to E4 uh Pawn to D5 at any turn
you have to watch out for so many
different things that it's just not a
simple position and now that you're down
to six minutes that's where it starts
getting scary yeah wow I'm just gonna
say that H4 King F1 idea just a mock of
Genius a stamp of a really top quality
player they look like beginner moves but
he's making them look like part of a
master plan so not a must slip anymore
definitely not Mouse slip definitely not
a mouse slip David I love this idea that
you're pointing out that now after this
last move white has opened up the queen
is eyeing that E6 spawns so Rook G3 is a
massive threat on the board and if
you're on the back foot in such a
position you're on the defense your king
is under Fire Rook G3 is a massive
threat I think black has to look for
ways of trying to trade off pieces here
to try and reduce the pressure somehow
and it looks like the only way to defend
such a position imagine even if Rook to
G3 wasn't coming in but you managed to
line up a battery on this diagonal or on
the b187 diagonal with the bishop and
the queen a meeting threat on H7 it can
get super dangerous and black has to
find a way to try and trade off as many
pieces as he can as quickly as he can
yeah which pieces would you be trying to
trade off here Queens Bishops
[Laughter]
but not pawns you want to keep all the
pawns because you got that isolated
queen I am super happy to keep all the
pawns on the board well that's really an
instructive point because uh it may seem
like we're joking around but that's what
black wants to leave white saddle with
an isolated Pawn in the end game that's
not what you want Jose Raul capablanca
but look at this position and say let me
get to that end game because then white
has this Pawn that's not easy to defend
if you use your major pieces to keep it
covered so Bishop B6 is step in the
right direction for black taking Tanya's
advice let's swap pieces uh get rid of
some of the attackers and the Knight on
G4 at any moment it gets slide back to
the F6 Square so that's something that
you're gonna have to watch out for that
night Retreat it not only helps save the
black king but also starts putting
pressure on this H5 Pawn covering the D5
Square so I think that right now Arjun
is everything under control but I'm
keeping one of my four eyes on his clock
yeah he's down quite a lot now uh on
time and uh Tanya does that get your
stamp of approval Bishop D6 trying to
trade off these dot Square Bishops I was
I was thinking that I want to trade
Bishops I want to trade my pieces but I
couldn't find a way and the reason that
I wasn't sure about this move is because
of your idea of sliding in with the Rook
to G3 regardless yes the bishop on F4 is
hanging but so is the Knight and who
does this trade favor it's not so clear
in my mind Robert that after The Rook
attacks the Knight
do you do you pick up the bishop and
give up the Knight and then lose a Tempo
on the way it's getting really
complicated it's super complicated you
have to calculate everything now because
yes you might have to lose time
retreating the bishop I'm not sure
exactly where you go but if you step
back with the bishop suddenly there
could be a threat we've mentioned this
checkmating pattern several times now
but you're creeping in along this
diagonal black can only block it at the
cost of material if you block it with
your Pawn then this Pawn drops this
still looks like an ongoing attack
against the black king and uh suddenly
tactics everywhere so this definitely
looks like the acid test of Black's last
move to slide the white Rook across
maybe it forces the Black Knight to go
back oh but I was going to say you're
allowing all sorts of Tricks maybe it's
just about okay there's no time for
white to go and take the spawn trying to
use this pin because luckily the bishop
can capture this pinning piece the white
Rook so it's hanging together by a
thread for black but if it's hanging
together it's good news for Argent
arrogacy and just goes to show that what
looks like a very simple move your
Bishop sliding one square on the
diagonal there's so much more than meets
there are many tactics in this position
Bishop D6 a calm move it's just trying
to trade off one of the white attackers
and black had less space with some of
the minor pieces let's get our Queen out
connect our Rooks and then that isolated
Pawn on D4 can become a long-term
problem so leaving that F7 Pawn the go
forward F5 at a critical moment if the
black queen slides up especially it
feels like the base of Black's Mission
will be stronger and that allows black
to fend off the threats and avoid the
secondary ones yeah looks like a great
move for Arjun and it's also forced to
go cash to burn most of his time
Advantage just trying to figure out how
to proceed how to keep the momentum
going it's must win for gukesh if he's
gonna stay in the tournament the losers
in the losers coach finals will be
knocked out of the air things monsters
and the situation is the same for Serana
right now playing against Wesley so
Wesley he won the first game today and
Serana he has to win this game to to
take it to an Armageddon I see the bar
is roughly in the middle in that game is
there any drama happening still early
days Serana has got a very playable
position but maybe not the type of
Advantage he would want or that he's
used to with the white pieces uh Wesley
so hard to beat on demand we've said it
before
I struggle Wesley laws of zero games
yesterday he won two title Tuesdays and
he played five games in the car in
Nakamura and rapid and he drew all five
of those I mean the guy seems
Unstoppable he isn't a loser's bracket
because the draw he had the white pieces
that meant that a car was able to punch
his ticket to the winners final uh but I
mean Wesley so is playing unbelievable
chess right now yeah it's so unfair
actually
name him in the losers bracket with the
way he's playing yeah I like that
pankaya so unfair
so solid he is yeah and uh meanwhile wow
what a move the White Knight Landing in
the center of the board it can be
captured three different ways Arjun
reacts instantly he says no I'll let
your knight sit there and he pushes the
F Pawn
and the first question yeah is yes you
push the F Pawn but you leave behind
your e-born which is now a weakness
white can simply snap up the Knight on
G4 and hope to pick up the E6 Pawn with
a check you pick it up with check and I
guess black slides into the corner we
have won a pawn with white but suddenly
a few problems facing uh facing good
cash here your knight is attacked this
Pawn is finally gonna drop the isolated
Pawn we've been talking about for a
while everything's happening with Tempo
and uh suddenly White's position is a
bit loose to me I think I would need
5-10 minutes to just to kind of try and
figure out what's going on just to kind
of find my bearings in this position but
the players of course don't have that
luxury you could also make an argument
for taking this Knight and then going in
with your White Queen you can make an
argument for I don't know throwing this
Pawn forward at some point or other
jumping in with the white knight so many
options but kukesh he's now down on time
and Arjun playing that last move this
last committal move instantly I think
that's a huge psychology cool blue
yeah F5 it's almost as if he's
calculated all these uh tactical
variations what is very very impressive
is how fast he played it despite the
whole board hanging what it does is one
thing's for sure pieces are getting
traded off and we've been talking about
this over and over again that the more
the pieces get traded off that D4 Pawn
will be a huge weakness and it looks
like that last move by gokish jumping in
with the knight at the center of the
board so tempting might have been
actually a huge mistake yeah evaluation
bar hates it we're not sure because it's
so complicated but we're going to trust
the computer in a position like this one
I might have to come origin the
astronomer because I feel like he takes
a while in the opening he's setting up
his telescope but when there are clouds
and complications there he sees through
them so this is unbelievable stuff from
origin air guys it's like F5 when the E6
Pawn is hanging with check I mean this
is just really unreal just like Knight
takes C6 Knight takes G4 E6 Falls to
check he has seen it all he is a
tactical Wizard and he he is informed
today wow and she must have been loving
his position it did look very promising
just one or two moves ago suddenly it's
pure calculation is either going to be
very good this position for white or
it's going to be very bad nothing in
between and uh suddenly two minutes down
on the clock you have to be greedy you
have to go and grab pawns with the White
Queen in order to justify everything
you've just done but uh the fact that
arjun's blitzing playing every move
instantly he's going to be panicking
doubt is creeping in now Tanya are you
fearing for concussion this one I he's
putting
pressure a lot of pressure not just on
the position on the clock playing the
psychological game here as well making
moves fast and so far accurately the
problem it comes down in this position
is that yes you pick up the pawn with a
check but once the king sidesteps the
whole board for gakesh hangs you need to
make a decision with that Bishop on F4
your queen on E6 will be targeted with
the Rook on C6 so I think kokesh is
going to be super wary of actually going
into this line once after the king side
steps let's say you pick up the bishop
on D6 the black rook recaptures and
again White's position collapses the
queen is hanging the pawn is hanging
notice that Bishop on B7 eyeing that
pawn on G2 and it's actually White's
King that is under so much pressure no
material to call for and wow we have
this line but instead of trading the
bishop
kukesh went for the pawn push attacking
the rook and Arjun once again just
blitzes out the move just simply
sidesteps with the Rook keeping all the
threats on the board what a beast yeah
two beasts here and uh they're playing
very very high quality chess we've got
to say uh no big swings in the
evaluation bar despite uh the fact it's
so complicated right now it'll be so
easy to blunder I like what kokesh has
done he's pushed this Pawn forward it's
on a less vulnerable Square now defended
by White Knight it also blunts in this
bishop but the problem remains there's
this awkward tension between the black
rook and the White Queen and if you have
to take a time out to retreat start
running away black will at least restore
the material balance and uh Robert do
you see any chance here especially down
to one minute now for good cash I'm
wondering if we're going to see a queen
sacrifice just a quick line here of the
dark Shore Bishop slides back one score
to E3 hitting the Rook on B6 the bishop
goes up to C5 saying your Queen's under
attack you have to move that thing there
are no safe squares and white says okay
I'll take your Bishop you'll take my
queen I'll also get your Rook that's oh
we might see this bishop E3 hasn't
played that's Alaska compensation of a
rook a minor piece and a pawn for a
queen that is a lot of material with the
past Pawn both kings are kind of exposed
this is the type of position you need if
you're good cash you may be worse you
may end up losing the game but you have
serious winning chances so I think that
gukesh the biggest problem right now is
his clock if the times were reversed he
would have huge chances but Arjun has
been finding these tactics quickly I do
like gukesh's last move though yeah
incredible to make this decision to
actually give up the White Queen because
he's committed to it now but he made
this decision with one minute on his
clock and this black Rook is actually
trapped the only way to avoid that
variation would actually be to trade off
this bishop but suddenly after the White
Queen steps back takes this Knight
you're just a pawn down and I don't
think Arjun can really go for this the
black king are also weak on the light
squares long term so I think both sides
are pretty much committed to that
variation Robert starting with this
bishop move sliding forward and just to
show it one more time Bishop takes
Bishop giving up the White Queen but uh
yeah Rook bishop and pawn if we didn't
see the evaluation bar we would think
that why is maybe doing very well here
but it still looks like dynamic balance
in this position in this crazy wild
position that's actually a stunning line
uh that Robert that you're pointing out
and Arjun slowing down because it's also
not easy to evaluate you have the safe
option of picking up the bishop right
now and not sacrificing the queen but
then you just end up in a slightly worse
position that Bishop on B7 as we can see
will remain Dead with that white Pawn on
D5 which is still alive and uh it's
going to completely favor gokish if
Arjun goes for this bishop trade but how
do you evaluate that position winning
that Queen but allowing a white Pawn on
E6 looks super dangerous just the fact
that Archer needed a draw in this game
and he went into these complications
just goes on to show how Brave these two
players are yeah if we reach this
position that we're looking at at the uh
on the analysis board right now then
it's anyone's game anyone's game I would
prefer to have white I see the
evaluation bar off the sides and the
black is still better I prefer to have
white because all of a sudden you have
more forces you're aiming at some of the
black weaknesses like the F5 Pawn The
Rook is under attack uh that E6 Pawn
it's not even clear that black will be
able to stop it so I'm just looking at
this position and I don't care what the
evaluation Bar says the players they
don't know it and I just think the
trajectory of the game has been an
arjun's favor all of a sudden gooka
strikes back and he's putting a
difficult decision in arjun's court and
I think he recognizes the importance of
this moment the magnitude and he may
take the bishop but he's not going to be
happy about it just saying you know what
I don't want your queen I'll be down to
pawn I can try to defend this I don't
like that he's spending so much time
here I feel like he's uncomfortable I
think he's going to go for this line
with Bishop C5
yeah he has to he's uh now down on the
clock and we mentioned he's an agent of
chaos uh Eric I see I think he has to
embrace that chaos now you can't just
maintain this position hope that it
Fizzles out towards a draw because this
one is just too wild and I would rather
go into that where it's a big mess take
my chances there then suffer a pawn down
and now no real time Advantage only a
few seconds and uh still a few seconds
increment for gokesh to rely upon so he
needs to go for it wow any of those
options he Retreats his Knight to the
center of the board he's giving up
material here he's a pawn down he's
giving up an exchange the black Rook the
white Bishop can snack on that one now
Feast on it he's trying to argue I guess
the White Queen is trapped anyway and
the evaluation bar doesn't react which
I mean 95 was not even a move on our
radar just giving up that Rook on B6
which by the way let's point out has
been voluntarily self-trapped he moved
that Rook all the way up to C6 and put
it on B6 and says come and take it and
it all relies on peace activity Knight
E5 what is this move Bishop takes Rook
it takes Bishop it's brilliant that is
an unbelievable find the White Queen is
entombed on E6 it looks like a great
square but either the black Bishop is
going to head back to its home and
attack the queen or The Rook will slide
in the Queen's path and attack it so
what a find yeah what a fight and now go
cash down to his last few seconds okay
he takes that black Rook he shifts his
own Rook out of the corner into the
center but the White Queen is gone she's
still going to have to sacrifice her own
life once that black light Square Bishop
slides back home as uh Robert mentions
there and uh I'm trying to do a quick
count here to figure out the material
balance here we go the queen is trapped
nowhere to save her you just have to
take this black knight in his Central
the boat now yeah it's going to be
Knight pawn and Rook for the queen so
the same material imbalance but the pawn
is on D5 and blockaded by Bishop rather
than all the way up where the Rook is on
E6 that's a humongous difference uh
opposite color Bishops that usually
favors the side with the safer King uh
both Kings looking a bit vulnerable uh
the white King has more forces around it
but eventually perhaps the black pieces
will line up so it's be for a good move
by origin opening up a second wing and I
like the way he's playing yeah I like
the way both players are playing uh this
is not just super high quality chess but
also both sides just going at each other
punch after punch after punch and go
cash finally has to take a timeout play
a consolidating move he's going for this
black F Pawn it's very weak there but
he's also Shoring up the white king the
white king at some point will be given a
nice safe home white will push the
g-pawn forward at some point and slide
it to a light square but first
okay the black queen coming in how do we
stop her from delivering some nasty
checks the White Knight also Under Fire
but the nasty checks do they really
matter because a draw is not enough for
gokish right and after the bishop falls
back on E2 Bishop B4 you've got this
queen C1 big threat on the board you
can't really move your knight to any
other Square except fall back and now
Queenie one is a mate in one D5 Pawn is
hanging Ah that's uh the more important
well what's more important than the
medium one but I think that's the key
detail here uh the white king you needed
to take your time out to give it a safe
square but now the pride and joy of your
position that Central Pawn has
disappeared and with it maybe White's
winning chances Suddenly It's hard to
imagine unless there's some uh sudden uh
kind of surprise attack for whites if
you maybe imagine the White Knight
getting to G6 unless that happens
Black's not going to be in trouble at
all in this game and look at what
arjun's doing he's completely dominating
that night that night is not getting out
of there anytime soon uh the black king
looking safe tucked away the white king
is a bit more open and I feel like white
just doesn't have the coordination of
the pieces you have three pieces uh so
two pieces for the queen a rook and a
knight but they're not working together
very well and I feel like black is
stabilized only needing a draw yeah and
uh another nasty Queen slide that the
black queen controls the diagonal that
the White Knight wants to use and wow
what a move developing his Knights
giving it up but if the Knight is
captured there will be a nasty skewer is
that a skewer is that a pin and uh okay
not allowing that white Rook back into
the game not taking the bait but has he
allowed gukesh back in this Pawn drops
now and uh we might well just see an end
game after Eric likes he gives back the
queen nope he's given a check and
suddenly he's won a rook for the bishop
it's uh Knight bishop and Port now for a
queen this is a big material advantage
for black should be a fortress for white
potentially but a draw minimum we have a
result Wesley so has won also game two
in his match against Alexa Serrano that
means Serana
what are your favorites well he'll be
okay he takes ten thousand dollars home
with him so I think he'll you know be
happy about that but it was a great
match for Wesley so I was keeping an eye
in the background and these players down
to their final seconds I mean he
couldn't get more exciting here in the
air things Masters and what do you think
does white have some chances here with
the material imbalance it's hard to
imagine I mean a queen for two pieces is
just really difficult but of course
gukesh is going to play this out till
the end and try and create something he
will Target that eight six Pawn The Rook
jumping onto D6 uh trying to create a
threat I think he might I think he might
have chances here wow
it's easy to play with more pieces and
the queen is more valuable but Rook D6
being a huge threat and oh it looks like
he backtracked because if you went Rook
D6 the Knight was hanging over there so
a great move to keep chances alive he
wants to slide his Rook over I really do
think white has chances in this position
yeah it's definitely not over yet if the
Rooks disappear black is safe it should
be a draw but uh how long are you gonna
avoid it yeah he has to dodge that he
did not slide across and now the Knight
wants to jump onto F5 and hit that queen
and the pawn The Rook moves forward to
defend the 8-6 pawn and watch out for a
fork now yeah so much happening Arjun
doing the great thing of keeping his
piece on the dark squares away from the
enemy Bishop so you see the rook and the
queen all of blast pieces on dark scores
he's trying to offer the trailer Rooks
but that is what good catches the point
he's threading a rook all the way up in
the corner to pin the queen to the king
so Arden says no none of that for you oh
and still a few seconds each here white
needs to get the Rook to a more active
Squad needs to get the Knight back
involved but uh at the moment no way
through black has set up a defensive
barrier it's amazing how gakesh is
fighting
fighting creating all these these
incredible threats both players on
seconds
no chances Robert but it looks like okay
she's showing some amazing will and now
the king joins the attack as well again
two games in a row the king landed on G3
and despite having no Queen I think we
would all take white here right
at least in the Blitz game I would
officially I I love a queen give me a
queen any day I'll take black oh you are
a queen Tanya meanwhile black is trying
to get pieces off the board still no way
through now Black's got pieces on dark
squares white pieces were all on light
squares for that moment and a nasty
check kicking away the white King The
Black Queen Is Gonna Come in behind at
some point maybe start delivering some
checks maybe that's the way to salvation
but wow there's a pin uh pin here Robert
wait tonight unable to move and I'm
surprised that black brought a pawn
forward look the king is out Knight G6
check is the fourth I mean that King is
helping in the attack this is scary for
black where's that King going if it
steps up there's a the king might go up
for white as well you'd be really
careful now well who's meeting who Rook
is coming on there's actually a mate in
one on the board is Rook D7 just to
check man it will be Checkmate that's a
Checkmate Queen will come to G3 giving a
check but no he offers a rook trade
this is getting really intense and white
needs to watch out for that check on G
E3 with that Queen easy to miss from the
other side of the board but it looks
like Archer might have just survived all
the threats that gokish was creating now
we go the queen check does land as he
predicted Tanya white needs to take out
a time uh time to block that now yeah he
does have to place his pieces on Awkward
squares all of the pieces were on the G
file for a second but a pawn has
disappeared with it take the Rook finish
the game he does it that is professional
he needs just to draw he gets out of any
threats and what a game by gokish what a
fight by gakesh wow and uh Arjun he's
going to secure the draw next move for
Rook takes bishop and a knight alone is
not enough to deliver
is knocked out of the tournament Arjun
Eric icy makes it through to the losers
quarterfinals what a match between these
two you think Robert who's living on the
increment but that three second
increment that's added after every move
that came into play Arjun aragici he
used it to his benefit he is the junior
speeches Champion he beat Neil sarin in
that format so he's used to these quick
time patrols and he is a superstar how
fast is your Indian hard beating right
now Tanya I can't believe what we just
witnessed I mean that was just at a
whole different level also kokesh so
impressive having no time on the clock
down a queen for Just Two Pieces managed
to create a mating attack with his own
King moving forward that was just
incredible just start to finish both
these players have so much to be proud
of today wow what okay well here is
today's learning points
today's learning point is about how to
how to play for a win at all costs good
cash in the opening surprised his
opponents Eric icy with some really
creative and some really clever play in
this position he shocked us all here all
the commentators by playing H4 what is
this doing you might ask he's simply
going to push his Pawn forward and make
it less attractive for the black king to
Castle on the king side his next move
another shock King to F1 putting the
King on a slightly odd square but uh
committing to lifting his Rook up the
board where as we saw in the game it did
prove to be a very strong piece it was a
crazy game of course many many twists
and turns later sacrificed his Queen but
uh Eric icy at the right moment was able
to lock things down by giving his own
Queen back I definitely recommend
playing through all of this game it's
well worth a study
[Music]
wow wow wow both matches on the losers
record today have finished two players
are knocked out kukash and Serana and
two players have made it through are you
guys see and Wesley so congratulations
Wesley
yeah thank you very much thank you yeah
finally I still have yeah I still have
one life left so that's uh one thing I
like about this format I played this
format before in the American Cup last
year
but it's nice because if you lose one
you you have to lose another but does it
feel a little bit unfair to be playing
on the losers bracket when you actually
haven't lost any games
yeah that's a good point yeah
unfortunately
uh Hikaru won the bid Yesterday by 16
seconds I think the match was very close
but unfortunately the last game
yesterday I didn't really get any
chances and then I look at the games
afterwards and Hitler played really well
so big congratulations to him and uh
uh you know you win some you lose some
but I'm excited to see his upcoming
match against uh Magnus today I wish
it'd be more than four games but uh but
that's nice nevertheless yeah and Wesley
we've heard rumors that you're playing a
lot of online chess uh these days uh
obviously playing here in the air things
monsters also playing title Tuesday
yesterday winning that one as well yeah
Grandmaster explained title Tuesday but
you know it's practice it's a super
strong event it's so so difficult to win
but I took advantage Yesterday by the
fact that all the top Grandmasters
weren't playing like Hikaru or Magnus or
Fabiano they weren't there so yesterday
it was a little bit weaker but uh yeah
to win two title Tuesdays in one day if
it's totally unreal I think I've only
won uh before yesterday I've only won
two titles Tuesdays in history
so it's really difficult but I've been
trying to get some practice games in I
think if you if you're gonna spar with
somebody might as well do it in a real
tournament setting uh and uh
also during tournaments you don't want
to
you don't want to attack your brain too
much you don't want to stretch it too
much
so before doing tournaments I would like
prepare or work on problem solving or
analyze my games but these days I guess
you know played with instead to try and
relax and uh
yeah and it's nice I think this year is
going to be very exciting of course with
the urging of chess.com in chess 24. I
used to play in the chess 24th I do
before but there are not too many good
players there so I yeah it's nice and
then after this tournament I have a
classical tournament in Dusseldorf
coming up where Ian
is playing as well so that's going to be
a good practice as I said this year I'm
going to start to improve my classical
rating but it's nice to
to be able to participate in this online
event and I'm very grateful to be to be
part of the everything's Masters this
year yeah we're so excited to have you
here as well Wesley yeah and we'll see
it's a quick question you said you win
some you lose some yesterday you lost
zero games so what did you eat what were
you doing what was going on with you
yeah actually now that you
know
well I I I've been working a lot on my
chest uh
um also I think the match format is
suitable for my style
and uh
yeah I mean I love I love playing chess
I spent you know hours per day doing it
but I think yesterday I was just playing
really well uh it's unfortunate I lost
to Hikaru but we'll try again start
again today also yesterday I played your
friend Daniel nardicki in the last round
the afternoon
yeah and you want it
yeah I won it I was uh better and then I
was completely lost and then he landed a
rook for a night so you should ask him
about it that's a very fun game it was
another Italian that usually play
you're on a roll Wesley congratulations
on winning the match uh today and best
of luck tomorrow as well when you're
gonna play on the losers semi-finals
yeah play again tomorrow and uh it's
going to be an exciting match also today
and uh yeah thank you again guys for all
your hard work it must be really
difficult also doing commentating for
many hours a day
thank you for the kind words Wesley
thank you so much see you again tomorrow
and we're also joined by the other
winner on the losers record today Arjun
Eric icy congratulations
hi thank you we just had to take a deep
breath after that match against that was
intense what was it like for you
yeah I think board games were quite
incentive the first game I he walked
into my brother I knew until I did
Quincy to ATV and and I didn't know look
here but I was pretty sure it's not a
good move I was fairly happy with my
poetry but Emmanuel very well until this
night F at 95th and one critical
movement was instead of playing instead
of playing Knight F4 I thought he could
go Queen B flat threatening Knight
foreign
match this was we loved watching every
bit of it
to us it seemed like there was so much
going on now you want to zero but
is it accurate to say that it doesn't
truly reflect how chaotic the games were
oh no it's actually running half firstly
and yeah I think both the games were
very complicated especially the second
one could have gone either way at first
I I was thrown off by his head for
working F1 idea but a bit later I
realized it makes a lot of sense and I
was feeling it but when he played 95 I
was very happy because after I fighting
I was encountered dude he he did manage
to pull some practical problems you took
the match in two games uh I have to ask
you Arjun in that game one when you were
going up the board with your king what
was going on in your mind were you at
all terrified about your king position
in that one what was that all about
but then I didn't think you can just go
G6 so that it's too much I would have
probably dropped back but I thought he
should still decided rather than going
back 96.95
yeah we were thinking about that one
here in the studio as well wondering uh
whether you'd be brave enough to advance
the king to G4 but uh Arjun I won't say
congrats first of all but also we heard
there's a collection of teddy bears
behind you can you tell us the story
behind uh those ones
for some of them I got from WWF when I
made some donations and some of them
were were the doors that I played with
when I was a kid
how cool so you have support while
playing in the air things monsters we
know you have huge Support also in India
a lot of fans are you noticing that with
all the fans now cheering you on
oh yes I am aware of it and especially
it was an old Indian matchup so it must
have been exciting for the fans to
follow as well also I have played good
cash quite a few times before and it's
always
it's always nice to play again yeah what
matches was and you're through to uh day
four in the air things monsters we wish
you best of luck tomorrow when you face
Wesley so tomorrow
thank you thank you for joining us Arjun
that was it for today's losers bracket
you guys we are now gonna get ready for
the winners bracket with the big winner
is final between the two big online
beasts Magnus Carlsen against Hikaru
Nakamura tomorrow in the loser is
semi-final Wesley so we'll face off
against Arjun aragaisi the winner of
that match we'll go through to the
losers final two phase the losers or the
loser of today's winners final the
winner of the winners final today will
go straight through to the Grand Final
to be played on Friday this is a big one
Magnus Carlsen against Hikaru Nakamura
is coming up very shortly what do you
expect from that one Robert fireworks as
always these two players since the
pandemic since online chess has exploded
they have given it their all all the way
back in 2020 through the past year when
I caught Nakamura kind of took the edge
against Magnus Carlson of course the
lifetime score heavily at Max's favor
but 2022 as a car nakamura's year really
it really was that we remember the fish
around the world championship last year
and also of course the speed Chess
Championship
do you think Magnus Carlsen is eager for
some revenge against hikara David
suddenly and here we see the scores in
the past 12 months in 2022 13 to 8 in
terms of wins and a lot of these games
came in the speechless Championship that
dramatic final uh yeah I was watching on
the edge of my seat in that when it came
down to the final few moves of the final
game but uh yeah it's hard to pick a
favorite I've got to say especially in
Rapid both of them extremely good both
of them just coasted to this point so
far and uh maybe Hikaru has a decent
shot at continuing his uh his good form
against Magnus oh definitely and we're
just finished with an extremely
entertaining match between gukesh and
Eric icy what kind of match can we
expect with these two with these two
playing Styles I think you've just set
the tone this has been a great warm-up
what a match that was absolute fireworks
on the board Magnus has got a score to
settle as we've been talking about
what's happened in the previous year and
there was a time when Magnus was
dominant in their matchups he was
crushing Hikaru throughout and then
there's been this breakthrough that
hikaru's had and it's there's been no
stopping him Magnus is looking for
Revenge today yeah you think so
absolutely all right it's getting close
the first game so in the winners final
it is best out of four rapid games if
they are tied then we will get another
one of those exciting armageddons and
this should be a tight one don't you
think David yeah on paper is extremely
close it's extremely hard to separate
them they're both so good in the opening
they're both uh just end game Gods at
this point and in speed chess uh their
strengths really do shine through
remember this could be just part one of
the Rivalry in the air things Masters
because uh whoever loses today will get
another shot to qualify for the final
for a rematch so yeah I can't wait uh
let's get the popcorn out yes enjoy
exactly and Robert we've seen them now
in two matches so far in the tournament
are they playing their best chess now
Magnus and Hikaru well I think Magnus
Carlson should be happy that he lost a
game to Argentina guys because once you
get that sting and it shows you can
bounce back from it that's huge for your
confidence so I don't think Magnus has
been playing his best chess I think
Hikaru against Wesley does two very
solid players I think the best is yet to
come The Best Is Yet To Come it
hitting very close the first game in
their match Magnus Carlsen will start
out with the white pieces what sort of
opening should we expect I'll go around
the table what do you think
uh phone cloud
haven't seen that before between those
two we have I'm gonna say the Italian
game
I've seen them battle it out in that uh
in that opening so many times especially
when Magnus is white at least you can
predict that Hikaru for sure is going to
set up in that way and maybe Magnus will
come armed with a new idea what do you
think Tanya I think it really depends on
what happens in Game one we might even
see a lot of switch-ups as uh Magnus
will go forward if he starts with white
pieces might be an Italian might switch
over to the Cat Land depending on how
things go Hikaru also so hard to predict
these two players are masters of every
opening uh I think it's all going to
come down to what happens on the time
scrambles Kaya I'm predicting an
Armageddon and I'd love to see that
happen oh I agree but David sorry Robert
we know Magnus he's all about those
psychological the psychological warfare
as well in chess do you think it's gonna
open with something
dubious in this first game against
Hikaru I think he's no longer in
hikara's head so all those psychological
tricks may work against everybody else
Nakamura showed in 2022 and he can take
down Magnus Carlson whether it's in
Fisher random but as a speed test
Championship whether it's in any type of
event so I feel like for a hit Karu he's
no longer afraid that vanity has been
ripped off and so I think the magnets
just play his optimal chess yeah I have
some inside information though they
should have been logged on now both
players but Magnus Carlson uh is uh I'm
isn't logged on yet
do you think that is on purpose David it
could be far away it is Magnus so we
know he's usually late I think we've
just been thrown off because he's been
on time for the last couple of days but
uh yeah maybe a hint of Mind Games there
but uh there's so much I just want to
add to that point earlier that there's
so much respect between these two now
and uh I just think they're gonna go all
out they have to play their best
openings that's the only way they're
going to win this match but is that a
problem in online chess world with that
clocks don't start uh in over the board
chess you're often uh penalized if
you're if you're not by the board when
the game is supposed to start in online
chess uh the clock isn't started until
you're there is that a problem uh I
don't know if it's a problem but the
chess.com can always take some time off
their clocks if they're late but uh
maybe it's also an issue that you don't
have a set starting time because these
last two matches could have gone to
Armageddon which means there's some
buffer uh some time to work it out but
we see a car Nakamura on screen I'm not
sure if he's talking to chat uh telling
them about all the takes takes taken
he's going to do but either way hakari
he looks ready for this match he doesn't
look too happy that Magnus isn't ready
yet I think we saw Hikaru shaking his
head he's not happy with what's going on
right now yeah you think so like he's a
little bit upset with Magnus keeping him
waiting understandably it's a big match
and we can see him with those hand
gestures not sure what's going on what's
stopping Magnus from logging on but
definitely Magnus needs to get there on
time Kaya you've got to do that when
there is a big game waiting to happen
I'm going to send him a text Magnus uh
where are you wait so you're just
bragging that you have his personal
number okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is now logging on to get ready we know
uh minus Carlsen is situated in Toronto
he is visiting his chest press his
friends uh Eric Hansen and Yvonne
Hamilton uh
you think what do you think those days
are like with the miners visiting them
is it all about the chance or do you
think Paris I think I have the bigger
question is one of the nights like
exactly exactly what do you guys think
um I've seen some Instagram stories of
public information but they have been
out in about in Toronto a little bit but
yeah who knows maybe just bullet
marathons or nights and uh a few parties
here and there I think we can confirm
that yeah all right well we're we are
waiting for Magnus Carlsen to arrive for
the huge match today this is the
Winner's final in the air things monster
is best out of four rapid games if they
are tied Magnus Carl's Nanny cart
Nakamura it will be decided in
Armageddon they both played Armageddon
yesterday to win their matches
look at her waiting for Magnus he
definitely looks a little bit annoyed
your car
oh do we see a smile
well I think Magnus is logging in and
Hikaru and he's getting ready to play it
is kind of unnerving when you're just
sitting at a physical border online just
waiting for your opponent to get set but
I don't think Hikaru is too amused yeah
yeah it's also his background there's
such a different setup from where we
normally see Hikaru play from uh has a
lot going on there yeah he is Hikaru
usually plays from an office right like
a streaming office not really his home
yeah I think he it mixes and matches
depending on his mood but we know he's
been going through a lot we spoke to him
yesterday after his match and so of
course we wish him the best and I think
for Magnus Carlsen he wishes him the
worst on the chessboard yeah but of
course it's been a big occasion uh for a
hikar a lot going on his life yeah is
this a big moment for those two players
as well David Magnus and hikar when they
face off yeah there's so much so much
pride attached and they know that kind
of uh yeah whoever wins this match by
the public will be viewed as the best
rapid player in the world and uh yeah I
think neither side wants to relinquish
uh that's that kind of mental battle
right now so
yeah especially for Hikaru having had
this last year I think he can relax a
bit more he doesn't allow Magnus to live
in his mind as he was saying Robertson
um it did feel like a big breakthrough
but uh yeah in terms of the fans there's
definitely a big split and uh I think
neither player wants to let them down
yeah waiting for Magnus uh to arrive for
this big game we do have some questions
coming in from you guys and keep them
coming either in the twitch chat or on
Twitter using hashtag chess Champs uh
skunk Spiegel has asked on Twitter what
are the commentators favorite openings
so that's that leading up to the opening
well I like to start with the Queen's
Pawn with the white pieces so I enjoy
that strategic positional fight that
arises from it and with the the black
pieces it really just depends on what my
opponent plays with the King spawn it is
if I get the opportunity with the black
pieces okay but on the board in this
tournament I would love to see a bomb
card happen yeah but I'd never played or
advise it how about you Robert I like
being retired and not playing but when I
do play I love playing the hippo and
it's one of those do as I say not as I
do openings where instead of taking
control of the center you just put all
your pieces on the second Rank and your
Pawns in the third and then you kind of
go from there am I not mistaken isn't
that your favorite one hello David I am
on record saying it's one of my
favorites is why we get along so well I
know I'm just like an English version of
Yuma but uh yeah also shout out to
Ginger GM who's done a chessboard course
on the hippopotamus defense yeah
um oh if I countries the hippo I'll be
boring I'll say the C3 Sicilian the
elephant Sicily oh me too
we have favorite openings
good question I think I've also seen
Magnus played the hippo a few times
during the Champions chest though where
he just puts all his pawns on the third
Rank and then develops really slowly and
he often does that when he's just
looking for a game you know it's not
long theoretical lines and you just kind
of take it super slow it develops solely
I've seen him employ that as well have
you guys been training together uh no
comments anyway right guys I think it's
time he's left us waiting too long
should I text Magnus oh
see you guys in the twitch chat or on
Twitter have any suggestions yes I think
a trivia question I mean he did come to
trivia uh last week so I feel like you
know what you're gonna have a tough
trivia question to answer where are you
you teamed up with him didn't you yeah
we're on the same team we uh you know
did quite well it was a fun time so I
think you should hit him with a tough
trivia question okay I'll just say hurry
up
what's the time
well an update if you are just uh now
joining us we are waiting for Magnus
Carlsen to arrive the winners final
should have started a long time ago
actually uh first game between Magnus
Carlsen and Hikaru Nakamura in the big
Winners final match and there he is
finally Magnus called Ready in that room
in the chesborough house in Toronto he's
gonna start out with the white pieces
against his biggest online rival hikar
are in Nakamura it is best out of four
games to decide the match if they are
tied it will be decided in Armageddon
tie breaks two ghosts straight through
to the Grand Final in the air things
monsters this is a big match and Magnus
has the white piece as you can see
Hikaru getting ready as well what's
going through their head right now
for Hikaru frustration activations he
wants to get the game going for Magnus
uh maybe just picking an opening I don't
think it's anything more than that right
now
we can see uh oh there we go it started
this is the winner is final and it's the
ready opening uh White bringing the
night out on the first move also one of
my favorites I should have called that
it looks so clever but uh the reti a
very flexible move only later depending
on what Hikaru does right now will
Magnus decide which Pawn to push and uh
Hikaru here usually either occupies the
center or place copycat here we go G5 so
how will Magnus react G3 very much in
the vein of the reti you could have
transposed to a queen's Pawn opening
there you could have chosen a bunch of
different lines but this is something
that both players have fast experience
in and now will Magnus Castle is King
allowing black to occupy the center with
two pawns Black's next move nope okay
instead Magnus allows a symmetrical
position on the board what do we think
of this
and I think Magnus is keeping it
flexible with the c Pawn he might decide
to move it forward two squares or one
square I might just keep it there for a
while and that's going to be an
important decision will will which will
determine the characteristic of the
middle game at some point I am expecting
him to actually go C4 and he does it and
wow Hikaru immediately snaps up the pawn
yeah still very well known stuff and
here
um usually black moves one of the two c
pawns there we go uh C5 and the whole
sensor might just be obliterated all of
the central pawns getting traded off and
a symmetrical end game and I was looking
at this one recently there are some
ideas for white to keep the game going
but they will involve a little bit of
risk at least strategically often you
might be ended uh you might be stuck
with an isolated Pawn or two if you want
to take risks to win uh this position
very solid stuff from both sides uh
especially Hikaru here and we've got a
fan of Magnus on the screen here we see
that is such a cute photo
yeah no that is always great to hear
from the fans here and also this
position as David was kind of indicating
that it's one where at first glance not
too much has happened black took a pawn
White's gonna get it back but White's
Knight gets a little bit more active so
this Knight that was sitting at home
jumped out up the board and we'll
capture that upon on C4 so I feel like
White's a little bit uh quicker to the
punch black is very solid we'll have a
symmetrical Pawn structure and it seems
that Magnus is the I was gonna say the
first person caught by surprise but a
car did think back on move one you know
to consider his reply but now Magnus is
clear he was not anticipating a card to
play this line yeah but throughout the
world championship in 2021 Magnus was
free kind of experimenting freestanding
with these uh G3 systems fee and
Kettering that white Bishop on G2 and
they could all of a transpose to this
type of position so surely Magnus has
studied this surely he has an idea or
two obviously if it's surprising to me
at least that he's burnt almost two
minutes of his clock on this very
well-known very theoretical position uh
usually here white does capture the pawn
that has just moved at least in the uh
at the higher levels I know Vladimir
kramnik has had success with that move
but as Robert says you can also
recapture a pawn with the white knight
uh lots of choice here
and in fact the more popular choice here
is to recapture the C4 Pawn with the
Knight bringing it to the center but yes
the second most popular move is to pick
up the other Pawn uh on C5 but that
would just mean that all Central pawns
are eventually going to be dissolved I
wonder Magnus is looking at a third
option which is to keep the tension on
the board but for now just defend that
default Pawn by advancing that E Pawn
one step ahead but I have to tell you
there's just one game in the database
that I have in front of me so that's
definitely a very rare move yeah it
feels like these two are the main
options either taking this Pawn or as
you guys mentioned just capturing with
the Knight I think uh you can kind of
play that position on autopilot even if
your knowledge isn't quite there even if
you haven't studied it in too much
detail because the positions are quite
simplified but uh yeah strange to see
him think three minutes now wow attack
for Magnus down to 12 minutes in this
position which is definitely not new for
him I am surprised what's going on with
him yeah the more he thinks the more I'm
inclined to say he's going to okay he
does take this Pawn eventually I was
going to predict something wrong so I'm
glad he got there first but uh yeah
Knight takes porn and now black has a
few moves as far as I'm aware one of
them is to hit this Knight with Bishop
you can also just capture this Pawn in
the center
and uh maybe other Alternatives as well
he does indeed hit the knights gaining
some time to develop
and uh very balanced so far the reason
why these lines are tricky though is
because there's this tension between the
D4 and the C5 Pawn so at some moment if
you're not looking out for it white can
capture that pawn and you may not get it
back so that's what this position is
coming down to at the moment and if you
see Max's last move jumping his Knight
into the center of the board unleashing
that Bishop in front of this King as it
slices across the diagonal towards the
black queen side that puts some
immediate threat so I'm looking at this
position and I'm wondering for a car you
know how much more preparation does he
have here he is starting to think but
it's the type of thinking he's looking
the side I believe he's trying to
remember his variations he's not on his
own just yet and that's also because
it's an important positions David you
were about to say something no I was
going to back up what Robert said
normally when he looks to the left I
think he's trying to recall something if
he's looking to the right he's very
unsure uh it's as if he's trying to work
stuff out but yeah I'm not as good as
Danny wrench as uh kind of reading the
many faces of Hikaru that's an
interesting tell that you just pointed
out but I think it's also important for
Hikaru to slow down right now because
there are concrete threats in the
position we see with magnus's last move
of jumping the knight at the board he's
cleared the path for his own Bishop on
G2 watch out for that pawn on B7 and
again Robert Woody was saying that very
often the center tension can go in
White's favor for example let's say if
black does that with the queen to see it
or to C7 defending that pawn on B7 it
does result in white capturing the C5
pawn and you don't have time to
recapture instead Hikaru knows that the
strongest piece in magnus's Camp is that
Bishop on G2 Throwing Fire Down the
board challenges it immediately the good
news for Hikaru is that right now white
count Advanced that same drill e-pawn
all the way up the square because the
Knight and the bishop would attack it
instead Magnus goes on to pick up the C5
Pawn there's work to be done by Hikaru
to win that back yeah it looks like a
clip one advantage for uh Magnus right
now but Hikaru just looking up working
something out calculating recalling who
knows but uh he's going to try and find
ways of getting this one back for
example you could start with a bishop
trade but now big questions do you trade
off the Queens do you leave the Queens
on the board uh to be honest I know I
don't know the answer uh in this
position I don't know the most accurate
way for black to equalize but all I
remember is that uh it should be
possible to win the form back at some
point yeah I think a critical thing
though is even if you do get the pawn
back just go one move deeper if the
Black Knight comes out to D7 and we
trade Knights on that square a white can
flick in this Pawn to C6 and you can
have that pawn you're going to even up
the material but look at the resulting
Pawn structure these are isolated pawns
on the queen side which means they may
be ripe targets for white pieces to go
after it's not the biggest advantage in
the world but at this high level these
small pluses that's all you may need to
put pressure on your opponent and then
try to win the game yeah and I think
this is a dream for Magnus uh this will
be an opening achievement for him
certainly if he can break the black
structure and have something to play
against long term you just need to keep
the game alive as long as possible if
you can Magnus hasn't gone for this yet
he first swaps the Queens he captured
the black queen on d8 and only then took
back to the bishop so uh similar ideas
in store potentially if the Black Knight
does try to go for the pool now trade
off and as Robert says you couldn't now
step this Pawn forward break the
structure and hope for a tiny little at
least symbolic advantage that's uh it's
up to Hikaru what's he gonna go for how
is he going to restore the material
balance
all right this is uh the first game uh
in the winner is final after Today's
Show at 1pm Pacific time in the US
there's gonna be an ask me anything with
The Grandmaster Sam Shanklin on the
chess.com Discord Channel if you log on
there you can ask Samsung anything
basically but he's gonna focus on his
new chessable course on the Neo Catalan
is that a favorite of you guys play that
many times yeah yeah so don't miss your
chance to uh to answer to ask questions
to one of the games the very best
Grandmaster Samsung Clinton 1pm Pacific
time
yeah I think we'll all log on later yeah
I need some tips on my openings yeah we
think we can get his preparation he's
renowned for his opening Theory so uh if
we can say hey can you please send us a
file he has to answer but he doesn't
have to say yes right yeah that's true I
think the answers are resounding no
it was also on magnus's theme for one of
the world championship matches I think
the 2016 one it was against karaoke and
that Sam wasn't magnus's team that
sounds right yes so you know that's
great experience for him I mean he's
renowned as an opening theoretician and
those are the type of people you want in
your training camps to work on specific
openings uh so Sam he won the 2018 U.S
Championship he had such a great year to
cross 2700 become one of the highest
rated players in the world he's been a
Mainstay of the US Olympic team so Sam
shank go to somebody if you don't know
who he is Google's your friend and then
we'll look at his chess games some great
ones there played on the Champions chess
tour as well Sam Shanklin
you know I'm looking at the screen and
we've got this epic rivalry right what's
grown to become the biggest rivalry of
modern online chess two of the best
players here fighting each other
but we also have two streamers fighting
each other
we're we're actually looking at uh well
I don't know two of the most popular
chess streamers currently and that's
kind of funny in my head yeah Magnus
these days ever since he's relinquished
the classical title he's taken to
streaming a bit more he's playing more
online events and
um yeah it's refreshing to I've been up
very late watching him sometimes uh when
he while he has these massive Blitz
marathons on Chester we're gonna have an
IMA of our own hair so David who do you
think is a better streamer that's my AMA
question to you okay I picked sides
between Eric I see a good cash but I'm
not picking sites but a streamer in
terms of entertainment or chess
wow you're just with me on a spot but
equally good and what streaming or chess
both oh I'm a big fan I've been watching
Hikaru for years now so uh he is more
experienced in the streaming that's for
sure yeah
and one of the most popular ones of
course yeah a humongous audience you
know his viewership is Sky High so uh
he's really helped chess become
increasingly popular definitely I think
his contribution has been immense and
what's been really spectacular about it
is that he's managed to maintain his
chest strength and even better himself
while streaming which he often calls his
first profession how are you the world's
best player when you're also a top
streamer yeah that's incredible stuff
yeah and it's also he's kind of the
model for young players just the work
rate the hours he puts in with streaming
and with studying chess playing chess
everything it's as if he's committed his
whole life to the game and uh I think
anyone who wants to reach the kind of
upper echelons of any sport needs to
look at him as an example it's just
fantastic I was so impressed uh
following the the world Fisher random
World Championship
he was playing these super long days
playing some fantastic chess and then
just immediately afterwards logging on
streaming doing the doing so much work
yeah and now look at him in Boss mode
just that pose just crossing his arms
like yes I'm gonna win that pawn back
I'm gonna lock this one down with the
draw yeah
right now and also his performance in 22
in the Grand Prix qualifying for the
kind
of cancer just an amazing yeah and even
the candidates if he had not lost the
dingley ran in the final round he might
be facing off against the under
partnership for the world championship
so there were so many good moments for
ikara Nakamura he returns to his
streaming now that's a you know what he
enjoys but I not sure he loves the
position he has right now I know he went
in Boss mode a little moment ago he
crossed his arms but now he's leaning in
and diving in to the complexities of
this position and we see Magnus he's on
the clock he plays Bishop E3 defending
the C5 pawn and it kind of reminds me in
a way of the game between Arjun era
Garcia and Magnus Carlson of course
different Pawn structure different
scenario but white is up a pawn and
clinging to that extra Pawn black needs
to prove he can get it back I do believe
that Hikaru is going to bring his Knight
his undeveloped night out to attack it
but Magnus always has something up his
sleeve well the one thing he has to be
careful about is not having the move C6
up his sleeve because there's such a
nasty trick in the position we've been
talking about this resource that white
has when the pawn is attacked you
advance it on the board but be careful
watch out the bee Pawn will advance two
steps hit that Knight on C4 which is a
key defender of that Central Knight on
E5 and this is going to be an absolute
disaster for white yeah suddenly one of
your Knights is lost either the central
one or the it's mate over here it's
fellow Knights and this would be a huge
blunder of course we don't expect to see
Magnus fall into this but that does beg
the question how else to defend your
Pawn if you can't move it forward
without losing a knight how do you keep
it on the board if the pawn drops
equality should just fizzle out towards
the drawer so do you step your knight
back I'm struggling to see uh ideas to
keep that pawn on the board there's also
them upon the B4 which defends your C5
Pawn but gives up the pawn on the Square
but after Knight takes the Rook slides
one square over hits the Knight and the
pawn behind it and active Rooks are so
important in these kind of end games
where maybe even black equalizes in
terms of the material but the activity
should leave white with at least a
slight Advantage so I think that you're
kind of have several choices here for
Magnus he's trying to work out which one
gives him the best chances whether it's
retreating the Knight initially or
pushing this Pawn sacrificing it and
opening up the B line yeah this would be
uh really creative but also potentially
very strong I'm not sure whether
Nakamura had envisaged that one a couple
of moves ago to push this Pawn forward
the problem with dropping the Knight
back to defend this Pawn is that now one
of the black Rooks might simply
centralize and still an issue with this
Pawn uh still some stuff to work out for
Hikaru Nakamura but first Magnus must
decide Retreat the Knight play it safe
or potentially push this Pawn riskier
but higher potential Rewards
I think this is going to Showcase how
ambitious Magnus is on his next move if
he does advance that Bond he's making
his intentions very clear it might be an
ending the Queens might have been
swapped off but I'm still looking at the
initiative here or a safer approach
would be to fall back with the knight uh
I think Hikaru is hoping that Magnus
does go for the night Retreat to defend
it because B4
it looks like things are going to get
very heated after the trades of the
night picking up the pawn The Rook
coming on the open file and David you
can defend that Knight on B4 if you can
just have that uh on the board because
we might be seeing this and let's say
you pick up the night the pawn The Rook
comes on the open file hitting that
Knight if you fall back you lose the B7
Pawn for a move you can still hang in
there push that a pawn all the way up to
A5 but it doesn't really help does it
because white can also continue putting
pressure on that night with the move A3
yeah kicking it away and if the Knight
has to move Retreats then we do gobble
up this Pawn reason reinstate this extra
Pawn Advantage yes we might be left with
a bit of an odd Pawn structure after the
bishop is recaptured we have to
recapture with the port now the knights
have to defend each other but white does
have a free pass Pawn to start pushing
now White's Rook is on the seventh rank
this Rook which was previously passive
has suddenly opened up and uh yeah it
definitely looks like this turns in
White's favor
um these are very natural moves it's a
few moves down the line but it it does
begin with white taking this decision he
does it it's on the board he goes for
the more ambitious approach where he
might end up with less upon but he'll
have that seep on which will start
advancing down the board wow that is
making intentions very clear shots fired
yeah shots fired in Hikaru just for a
moment frowning pausing and does he have
a solution up his sleeve he didn't
expect it right that was like what just
happened there of all the moves that I
was considering with the night Retreat
maybe the pawn push things of that
nature B4 hits him and he's like oh
that's possible and it might just be
good and now you have to kind of reset
as a chess player when you are caught
off guard when a surprise hits you you
need to start thinking objectively
regain your composure and he's looking
at these variations he knows he can
gobble up that pawn but once the white
Rook slides over and tries to land on
the B7 Square removing that pawn in the
process it's going to be too much
activity to deal with I don't think it's
comfortable for hikara but he doesn't
just have to take this Pawn on B4 he can
slide his Rook up to the center of the
board hitting the Knight on E5 as well
so he has his options but it's clear to
me that he was not expecting the move
Pawn to B4 yeah that's a clever move
there Robert uh Rook to D5 just uh
utilizing this pin hitting the white
knight in the center of the board and it
cannot really move uh this would induce
a weakening move potentially for white
you have to step your Pawn forward I
guess to defend it and suddenly the
question remains can you now go in and
take this Pawn uh these are the things
going through hikaru's mind right now
it's two three move tactics here and
there a little bit of calculation you
need something now because if white gets
one more move to just create a pawn
chain for example if black wastes time
if you just get one more move connect
three here and uh this Black Knight is
just sat on a terrible Square on the
side of the board white has it an extra
Pawn advantage of course and Magnus he's
going to win this game you cannot allow
this at any cost so now is the moment
you have to make a big decision and I
expect Cara to go into the tank for
three four minutes because it is that
that tense you need to find a good
solution to this last move and then I
can bring up a question from the twitch
chat to you uh David the fans have
really been loving your story on the
Pikachu the big reveal that you are a
Pokemon fan and uh Kent Lufkin is asking
what's your most memorable live
commentary moment
not to do with Pokemon
I should confess I always dreamed of
being a PM not a GM a Pokemon Master but
anyway enough of that my most memorable
commentary moment
um in terms of the games we've
commentated on it might have been Magnus
pretty much busting out of his shirt
when he beat uh when he beat Wesley
Stone the massive comeback I think it
was a couple of seasons ago on the tour
yeah
um if it's not necessarily to do with
the games we're watching then uh beating
the Magnus app oh that was back to Stage
10 yeah getting my revenge after he
crushed me the first time and uh yeah
that's probably the highlight it
definitely wasn't dressing up as a
Teletubby that was maybe the low light
of my commentary career but uh no it's
been all right it's been a journey and
I've loved every moment yeah been
fantastic to have you in the studio
David and it's so nice to now have two
new members in the studio as well Tanya
and Robert joining the Oslo Studio to
follow the action of the third season in
the Champions chess tour and already on
day three in the 2023 season we have
this dream battle between ikoro Nakamura
and Magnus Carlsen who's getting the
best start here and it might not be the
only time that we see two of them
together and that's all thanks to the
Double Elimination bracket uh Kaya your
question about who we're seeing have a
good start I think Magnus is happy about
the position that he's gotten with this
last move he's posed some real questions
here to Hikaru but Hikaru is so good at
adapting at this shift yes he wasn't
expecting this Pawn Advance he might
have underestimated it but we often
think of Hikaru as this aggressive
attacking player but one of his biggest
chess Trends and quality is how
resourceful he is and how resilient he
is when faced with a with a question
with a pro problem situation a challenge
he knows how to take a pause and then
just give it his best and adapt
immediately and that is why he is one of
the world's best players in these
formats I see him reaching out for his
Mouse he is about to make a move he is
about to take a decision he has burnt
two minutes and he picks up the pawn he
goes for for the line which is the most
direct one and A5 on the board we were
talking about this expecting Magnus to
continue attacking that night to open up
the b-file for The Rook yeah but when we
were analyzing this it looked very
promising for white Robin I'm surprised
I've got to say maybe there were more
solid options available uh he's
definitely made a committal decision
here at Hikaru it's all based on
retreating his Knight now and not giving
white the time to go and grab this Pawn
on B7 there's tension with the Knights
but the pawn structure just looks really
bad really weak for black clear
Advantage for white you have your the
first Rook into the action he just leaps
forward with Rook to B6 putting pressure
on the C6 pawn and if your best move as
black is to defend your Pawn you're
using a very valid piece to defend the
least valuable Pawn but the issue is you
give up that pawn white has a clear
passer so I just feel like Magnus he's
attacking the C6 Pawn with his Rook the
A5 Pawn is also attacked with his Knight
and all of White's pawns are defended
for the time being clear Advantage for
Magnus Carlsen Hikaru spent about four
minutes to play Knight takes Pawn a few
turns ago and it's clear that Magnus is
the upper hand yep Magnus definitely has
the upper hand just to prove your point
here Robert if you do have to take time
out plant The Rook on a really ugly
Square then White's other root canal
into the into the freight at some point
we can switch Focus maybe to the seventh
rank uh for example this move you're
threatening a night jumper night fork
and it just looks extremely strong and
the top players they never choose
passive defense unless they really have
to and a really instructive move there
very strong move potentially from Hikaru
Nakamura he's going on the counter
attack he plants his Bishop in the
center challenging whites Bishops
control over its own C pawn and uh this
is a counter if White NOW gets greedy
and does take this Pawn then trying to
figure out exactly what he has in store
but I'm expecting potentially a nitrate
and now the black Rook can start jumping
in getting active uh maybe the Black
Knight jumps in to go for this Pawn
still looks like white is in the
driver's seat are pulling up at least
for now Magnus not risking anything but
Hikaru he's going to try and defend
actively that's always the more
promising approach I see the evaluation
bar jump just as I suggest this move so
maybe it was uh this one instead and
still manageable for black not lost yet
but you are Pawn down at least for now
active defense and the guy was showing
the part this analysis about the
position that we have right now I think
it's exactly what Hikaru is hoping for
because notice that E2 Pawn is a
weakness the Knight on C3 super strong
and let's say you make a move like King
to F3 you know kings are supposed to be
active in the end game this will
actually be exactly what black is hoping
for The Rook will slide down to see it
offer a trade of Rooks the C5 bond is
undefendable and black solves all
problems in the position so a really
nice active approach there by Hikaru to
solve his problems yeah suddenly White
had all those active pieces but they've
all been traded off yes white was a pawn
up but if you look at what remains black
has an active black has an active Knight
and white is left with two passive
pieces so um yeah the players are so
sensitive to that very impressive from
Hikaru but stylistically this is up
Magnus Carlson's wheelhouse he loves
grind them out and games where he's
slightly better Hikaru Nakamura is an
amazingly resourceful Defender but
that's typically when tactics are at
play Nobody enjoys playing a passive end
game or a pawn down end game so I think
that Magnus whether or not he wins this
game he should be very happy with how
it's gone and he is spending time here
after the bishop captured the bishop on
E3 which means he might take with his
Pawn he might double isolate his Pawns
in the center of the board to keep his
Knight on C4 active the Knight where it
currently sits hits that black Pawn on
A5 so Magnus thinking here I believe he
may very well take that Bishop with his
Pawn it's tempting it's very attempting
you also open up the white Rook on F1
you mentioned that Magnus loves grind
him out end games we even did a whole
chessable course on those and I learned
so much from just the technique just
that mentality of Magnus he's just happy
to torture his opponents he's a sadist
at us just love sitting there thinking
okay I'm a pawn up you do the hard work
you suffer just to get a draw and I
think that's what he's trying to do in
this game he's saying to Hikaru no
winning chances for you very one-sided
in terms of winning chances maybe you
make a draw if you play really well but
if not uh then I'll have some chances
and there we see the Rook trade did
happen and whoa blink and you missed it
uh all the Rooks are off the board we
did see a little transition there
White's extra Pawn has disappeared but
the white king is extremely active uh
night end games we often say they're
very similar to King and poor man games
you just imagine the knights are off the
board and that's how you evaluate the
position if you're winning without the
knights off the board you're usually
winning with the Knight still on because
they balance each other out but uh can
that white king run towards the queen
side now pick off that lone black pawn
equal material is so deceptive here it's
all about that King activity you're
talking about the main aim to try and
get that game closer to the queen side
barn and win it and then it'll be game
over the one move that comes to my mind
is F4 black has just played E5 to take
away this D5 Foursquare from white skin
to advance to the center towards the
pond but right now Magnus has the option
to challenge that E5 Pawn advancing his
own F Pawn he chooses another path he
goes Knight to D6 uh clearing up and he
perhaps wants to go Knight E4 offering a
trade absolutely brilliant Knight D6 is
showing the vision it takes to win at
the highest level he wants to enter the
king and pawn end game which will be
winning despite the initially equal
material because White's King is more
active after the Knight swaps on e4
which you don't want to do you see the
evil Bargo Sky High because the king
takes the King goes up to D5 and it can
walk on over to the queen side to win
this A4 Pawn that outside pass Pawn will
win the day for the white pieces so
Knight D6 that's on a move that was on
my radar but as soon as Magnus played
I'm like oh this guy he's devious he
wants both to bring his Knight to E4 and
to allow his King to slide back to D2
without black getting the E4 Square for
his own night yeah so one of the ideas
has been prevented black does stop the
white knight from dropping back to force
a trade and I think the second idea
might come in action now Robert marching
the king across nope Magnus goes back
with his Knight first what a maneuver
losing time but he has loosened up the
black structure and now this Pawn is
attacked if it steps forward yes you've
connected four but you've allowed the
white king into the black half of the
board and uh suddenly it will advance it
might even come the whole way around the
long way around to try and pick off this
Pawn also if this Pawn disappears white
will win that's almost guaranteed
Knights are so bad at stopping the A and
H pawns the Rooks pawns because they can
only defend from one side they don't
have another flank to defend from
instead Hikaru of course couldn't allow
the white king to get active he dropped
back to a really passive Square for his
Knight but now simple path for the king
but mag has been the king of precision
he's not sure do I want to bring my king
to D3 or back to D2 this may seem like
it's the same idea you're bringing the
king to the Queen's head but the king up
on D3 allows a night check maybe you
don't want to allow that Knight back
into the game uh it's still going to be
good for white but that is what Magnus
is calculating he knows he has the upper
hand here he knows that probably he
should even be winning in this end game
he sees the forest through the trees and
he's looking how to get that a pawn but
he wants to make sure that hikar has no
chances in return yeah I'm very
surprised I've got to say that Hikaru
looks so poker faced on the camera
because I would be terrified here for
black looks like one-way traffic again
just a simple path for the white King's
Simple Plan and it's a distant dream at
the moment to try and trade off all the
pawns and survive uh just by giving up
your knight getting rid of that final
white porn I don't see any way to save
this one to salvage this game long term
ticked under two minutes on the clock
another question from the twitch chat
from Dr mikterstein Robert who has more
to prove in this match Magnus it's the
best according to him but Hikaru has
beaten him a lot last year Magnus never
has anything to prove and I'm not saying
that Hikaru does but the question should
never be about what does Magnus need to
prove he is the best player in history
in my opinion so you know does he need
to prove that he's still going to be the
best for years to come maybe some would
argue that but I really don't feel like
Magnus needs to prove anything because
he is the best player in chess all right
even if he lost in the speed Chess
Championship to Hikaru if he lost this
match as well I don't think he would
like it he doesn't enjoy it but proving
something and enjoying are two different
things but I get the question right
because Magnus he has suffered many
defeats against a car in the previous
year over their careers of course Magnus
has a dominant score against everybody
and in particular Hikaru In classical
chess if as lopsite as it gets but a car
has proven that he is over that hump
that psychological barrier he can give
Magnus the challenge and like nobody
else can and Magnus he is looking to win
this game one because he knows that
ikaru will struggle to get back to the
match if he can land the first blow and
do you guys think now Magnus will win
this first game okay yes looks like it
he's played a Flawless end game amazing
technique there the Magnus touch as they
call it in the end game you were talking
about Precision king of precision the
King has moved to the precise Square not
even allowing the tiniest counter play
to Black to come in with the check with
the Knight the king is going to move
along the dark squares put pressure on
that a pawn and we see Hikaru looking
into nothingness but it's not going to
help him right now well that was deeply
depressing look at the nothingness I I
feel for him now that is the position on
the board and he tries to advance his
own King so the idea is to get that King
all the way to D5 so that you can try
and put pressure on White's night but
the Knight can just fall back with a
check it looks like this is going to be
an uphill task for her car to defend
this one yeah one minute against two
minutes so some Hope on the clock for
Hikaru if he can hustle slightly give
Magnus some difficult questions to
answer uh maybe initiate a race later on
because races you need time to work out
you have to go step by step see who's
quicker but at the moment definitely
objectively strong position for white uh
I would say that if Magnus hadn't won
the world rapid and Blitz titles then
maybe something to prove but uh thanks
to those victories in uh at the end of
December I would say yeah he's pretty
relaxed and he knows uh he's still the
guy to beat but as a as a triple world
champion you kind of have little bit
proof in the world you missed out on the
world uh Fisher
randomly's got that one we are we are
seeing the two world champions in this
screen right now Magnus Carlsen In
classical rapid and blitzy car in Fisher
random yeah I mean while one step away
from taking that black apple and
creating his own past Pawn no way to
stop it for Hikaru Nakamura as uh Tanya
mentioned maybe the best bet is to land
the black king into the center but the
White Knight drops back with the check
and uh it's inevitable black will be a
pawn down you just have to create
counter play you have to create some
confusion maybe box in the white king
when it does land uh on the corner uh on
the side of the board there we go uh the
king does move we see a quick Knight
check where to go with the black king
you've got to move forward you can't go
backwards anymore because white is just
gonna swoop up that a pawn for nothing
and Hikaru does it what his idea is
David he wants to actually go even ahead
trying to Target those King side pawns
so let's say white does pick up the a
football and Hikaru is relying on the
counter play with the King stepping one
more step and then another and then
trying to pick up the pawns but I have
to say it looks like it's going to be
too slow that a pawn as yasa says baby
and it's going to decide the game yeah
it's a race this Pawn is gonna run this
really hard to imagine this Black Knight
stopping it but Magnus didn't want to
calculate that one yet he gives himself
the option to repeat moves there's three
second increment at the moment so he
dropped his Knight back with the check
forcing the black king back and now we
might see him just repeat one more time
why not gain a few more seconds on the
clock and uh okay first he doesn't want
to repeat in this way first he just uh
reinforces the fact that he can take
this Pawn anytime he wants he gives uh
the option of a knight check first but
the evaluation bar drops and he
surprised the car with that one hikara
was like wait a second that gives me a
chance and because her car could push
his own pawns with his King being a
menace towards those white pawns F5 to
F4 push that pawn forward he can then go
after the other pawns with his King
instead looks like a car stepped forward
with his Knight he protects his Pawn on
A4 with his Knight I think that there
will be some kind of inevitable uh loss
of that pawn but that knight from C5
will aim towards the white pawns at 94
and I think that maybe Magnus he kind of
delayed it a little bit too long but
it's because of his clock he is down
under 10 seconds remaining five now four
he needs to make a move and he needs to
make it fast he does go for the move F3
I think he has made it a little tricky
for himself here and not clear how he's
actually going to pick up the A4 Pawn
anymore and um it might it might just be
fine for Hikaru now yeah suddenly these
Pawn pushes gonna happen I'm not sure
which one you push first you can make an
argument for both but suddenly it
definitely looks like uh the race has
started and Magnus gave Hikaru a bit of
ground there no way that he's going to
win this Pawn in the next two three
moves it will take time and Hikaru has
that luxury to start pushing pawns so
it's definitely some drawing chances
maybe Magnus letting it slip he didn't
lose on time he has a few seconds left
but he's cutting it fine he's cutting it
close he drops back his King it's the
wrong direction suddenly chances for
Hikaru suddenly this Black Knight can
try and get into the center go for these
white pawns exactly David because take a
look at the geometry and the pawn
structure once the E2 Pawn is attacked
it can't move forward the F3 Pawn is
weak but inside Hikaru continues mark
down the board with his own pawns we've
got a pawn star happening here and it's
just an absolute mess who is playing for
a win but it's a bullet brawl because
icaro he's down under 10 seconds himself
now under five he's gonna make a move
and he is going to what's he going to do
here I think he's gonna move his Knight
he does back to B3 but look at Madison's
move in return he's going after that
pawn on A4 neither side has lost on time
it's just a race at this point the a
pawn that one is distant but black stole
a Pawn on the king side so there's an H
Pawn versus an a pawn both sides have
their chances with minimal time in the
clock yeah and uh Hikaru here trying to
end this game with the draw by trading
off everything that black knight is
trapped but you can break it out of its
prison just about you just in time and
there we go a bunch of porn trades
happened and the Black Knight did find a
safe Square this one is gonna fizzle out
towards the draw but a massive missed
opportunity for Magnus Carlson no
material but that Apon I mean it should
be a draw with best play but with no
time on the clock that's a scary Pawn to
deal with and that's why car to take my
Central Pawn you're going to go up a
pond temporarily but the king will take
care of the Apon the Black Knight Will
hop into F5 to sacrifice itself for the
G pawn and that should be enough for the
draw yeah and uh Hikaru looks ready to
get out of there he looks like he's
solved the problem knows it's a draw but
still some work to do because white
tonight has actually come to the defense
and if Black's King moves forward to
attack that night the a pawn will start
advancing so you don't have the luxury
and look at Hikaru you can see from his
expression that he is in panic mode
right now he wasn't expecting that yes
seconds brilliant played by Magnus
because the king cannot step forward for
black because then the pawn runs to the
other side and that means that the king
for white defends the g-pawn and will go
up the board probably King F4 now bring
your king up to G5 and but you can't
afford to trade Knights for a car so his
Knight's going kind of in the wrong
direction he's gonna try and hit the
white king with his uh white knight
story with the black king I think that's
the idea he wants to make sure the Black
Knight defends the a pawn and there we
see it and I think even on seconds
Hikaru found the precise defense and
this is what it is the guy is so
resourceful and so good at this stuff
and just adapting to these positions
impressive play the night will sacrifice
but it's still not over
King's so far away you still have to
race across to the side of the board to
the king side now to stop that white G
Pawn of course Magnus it's going to be
hard to advance his own Pawn because the
Black Knight Will threaten to give
itself up uh at every opportunity you
have to bully that black knight away
kick it away but if Hikaru puts the
Knight on a safe Square it should still
be fine
yeah I would still be terrified here but
uh Hikaru looks like he's got it under
wraps he's still in control should still
draw this game not enough material white
Pawn isn't far enough Advanced I have to
say flawlessly done there by Hikaru he
gets the king in time to defend his own
Knight which is stopping the pawn from
advancing now and it looks like he's got
everything under control gives a check
just not allowing white to advance or
offer a night trade amazing play by Carl
Nakamura he has this under control this
game for sure will be a draw there's no
way the pawn progresses about the
knight's sacrificing itself for that
pawn but for akaru to go left and right
and back and forth and to find a way
towards this half point that was amazing
but Nakamura gotta say if it's a
repetition uh not quite Magnus has
triangulated his King he's got the same
position we've had twice already but
this time it's black to move so how does
Hikaru Nakamura wait in this position
White's not actually threatening
anything the white porn cannot step
forward because the Black Knight Will
capture it take it off the board but uh
okay he moves his Knight and how do you
get that white pawn it must be so
frustrating Hikaru knows he's about to
make a draw and finally we see it wow
finally next move is guaranteed that
white porn disappears ah he runs out of
fikaru Nakamura in five minutes game two
will start the first one is a draw
Magnus Carlson doesn't look entirely
happy he had the white pieces in this
game and Hikaru will have the white
pieces in game two starting in five
minutes Magnus Carl's not sitting there
looking over this game a missed
opportunity you said David what happened
yeah it looks like Magnus because of the
clock was reluctant to start a race
which would have been in his favor
instead he waited for one move too long
he tried to finesse it and uh the moment
passed and the wind Slipped Away it
started in this position we said the
black king was getting active he was
getting ready to jump towards those
white pawns if for example we start by
capturing a Pawn on the side of the
board uh the black king could start
advancing but Magnus if he'd had two
minutes on his clock he would have had
the time to work out that he is winning
he could move his King out of the way
yes the black king can come in but it's
simply too slow the white Pawn can step
forward now the king can take this Pawn
but at the right moment you will go and
kick this Knight away with the white
king and you'll have a safe run through
to promotion Magnus missed this job this
opportunity if we go back and uh whoops
not to this position we did eventually
see her King and Knight versus King it
was a draw
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
92 percent of games get to this position
from this position white is winning
about 60 70 of the time and I think if
you learn these lines that very easily
could be 75 or 80 for you
[Music]
the winner is final has started game one
is over game two will start in only a
few minutes we're gonna take a look at
the puzzle that Ivanka has brought with
her today but uh if you're not a
subscriber on Twitch here is a twitch
break
foreign
the action that started with the winners
final uh Magnus keeping Hikaru waiting
there for a long time I know I mean I
personally would have been very annoyed
and it's going to be very interesting
now to see how Hikaru handles this I
mean it's very good that he saved it
because boy that was very difficult I'm
very impressed but uh picara is one of
the most creative most resourceful
players around especially online and uh
talking about creative and resourceful
yeah well I think possible the puzzle
yeah I mean I see a lot of people really
getting into it oh cool and they've come
up with part of the solution but it's
super super interesting because this is
the slot this is the study it's white to
move and uh everyone has actually
spotted the trick
actually gets deeper because you have to
remember black has two pawns they can't
promote so that's a bit of a giveaway
and that adds a little like another
facet to the poll study you you
announced that saying this puzzle it
basically has a lot of twists and turns
it does it does it does and people have
spotted the main trick okay everyone is
very good on that one but uh they're
still another level to be discovered
it's almost like an Easter egg it's a
giving and we're gonna reward someone
who uh solves the puzzle especially if
you uh give us a creative answer maybe
with a picture a selfie with yourself
solving it together with friends and
family someone will get an air things
device signed by Magnus Carlsen so
tweets your answer to the puzzle using
the hashtag chess Champs all right well
game two is coming off what you expect
from Hikaru now Ivanka I think he's
going to go into boss mode he's going to
actually put pressure on Magnus he's
going to say Hey you had the advantage
on that game but now I have the white
pieces it's my turn to have the fun
well I like it game two is coming up
very shortly
oh there we go it started
winner is final
vicious approach where he might end up
with less upon but he'll have that seep
on which will start advancing down the
board wow that is making intentions very
clear shots fired
all right Hikaru Nakamura getting ready
with the white pieces do you think
Robert he already has the plan ready for
all those white games what kind of
openings he's gonna play hard to say
because yesterday against Wesley so he
didn't really get much of anything in
fact the fourth and final game before
Armageddon he forced the draw so we
haven't seen his opening preparation at
least not from yesterday's action and he
should be happy about surviving that but
Magnus obtained an advantage so he
should be happy as well and of course
the last time these two played a match
in the speed Chess Championship Hikaru
won that one uh it was just epic this
much what was it that made Hikaru win it
how did he win it Magnus was just off
form in the early going and the car
played brilliantly so that is a mismatch
in the early stages Magnus came back he
came roaring back even tied the match
but you see on that final clip there
Magnus did not have enough time it was a
clock was running against him Hikaru was
able to survive long enough in this last
game to win the mashed by one point yeah
but I think I heard Magnus after saying
after that he he enjoyed playing the
match yeah Magnus loves the challenge I
think he's tired of just crushing
everybody and he wants to fight against
the very best and he knows Hikaru is the
very best when when it comes to online
speeches yeah he he's embracing it yes
that's true yeah coming up now this is
game two Hikaru with the white pieces
what do you expect from this game Tanya
uh just what we saw in game one went on
to show the kind of fighting Spirit the
two have come with one thing that stood
out for me in that speed Chess
Championship which Hikaru won was the
strategy that Hikaru had from the start
about really letting that game time run
low there was a lot of criticism about
it but Magnus respected that at the end
and I think it made so much sense
because it really came down to that so
both players know that they need to make
the most of every single small aspect of
the game and that's the kind of fight
that we saw in the previous one it was
an end game but it went down to the wire
it went down to Absolute Duty both of
them giving it everything but I think
Magnus is more disappointed with that
and Hikaru is relieved to get a draw
yeah definitely some time trouble in
that first game today it is 15 minutes
plus three seconds increment after each
move in the year thanks monsters and
then the Champions Chester Hikaru
Nakamura now getting ready first game
was a draw three games to go to the side
the winner is final if they are tied it
will be decided in Armageddon Hikaru
thinking hard here what will be his
opening in this game with the white
pieces one E4 I'll say another record
so no b3s you say the Hikaru against
Magnus might avoid doing that
um maybe I'm not sure
I think I'll go D4 gets back diesel
you're always fun B3 would that be very
surprising if Hikaru did that B3 yes I
think it would be he usually reserves
that for Blitz Games more than rapid
games because even in the chess.com
Global Championship uh he was playing
against Grand Master uh shorter from uh
Chile and he was in trouble after
playing B3 so you know that's not an
opening that you really want to play in
the highest level
what will it be he's leaning forward
zikara Nakamura is game two now about to
start here we go yes
and uh it is another ready opening uh
playing copycat this is exactly the
strategy Magnus used in the last game so
yeah psychological warfare has begun
Magnus doesn't go for the approach that
Hikaru used in the previous game he also
feeding kittus but he gets ready to
think into his Queen side Bishop the
light Square Bishops on the long
diagonal will be facing off against each
other this often transposes to the
Queen's Indian defense or other branches
of that opening but uh Hikaru pausing
now white does have options you don't
necessarily need to rush to develop your
Bishop first you occupy the center and
that's what Hikaru is going for now
Magnus did famously lose a game in the
Queen's Indian defense against Anish
giri in at the Tata steel Masters just
uh very recently so again different
branch of that opening but uh he won't
have fond memories there so Hikaru may
be trying to remind him of those ghosts
what do you think of this Tanya the one
big difference there was that Magnus
Society to take out his Bishop to one
step ahead on A6 instead of B7 it was
slightly a different structure but a
theoretical battle that was which Anish
was just just a beast in that game I
mean he played it flawlessly and won it
and Magnus decides this time to place
his Bishop differently on the long
diagonal so definitely going to be a
slow game and we're going to see a
proper Queen's Indian but that could be
a difference Magnus can decide to franch
out on the other side as well and he
does that instead of the move of moving
that King's Pawn One Step Ahead which
would be the Queen's Indian defense he
goes for this one this is sort of like
the hippo right yeah almost if Black's
Knight was uh maybe placed on a slightly
different Square black hesitated from
castling uh this early he did have this
exact position against Arjun eragisi in
the final round of the Tata steel
Masters Magnus Carlsen and there Arjun
pushed forward one of the white Central
pawns the game became very locked up
very tense and Magnus eventually
outmaneuvered his young opponent but now
Hikaru is thinking for sure he's seen
this position before he's just trying to
pick a line he's trying to choose
something that will throw Magnus off
balance and Robert who do you think this
opening is going to favor stylistically
it's kind of a dodgy opening right
you're just like saying let's not go
into preparation but what black is
really waiting for is that Queen side
night to develop because as soon as that
Knight leaves B1 the Black Knight on F6
hops into the center to the E4 squared
that's what Magnus is aiming for start
trading off some pieces because White's
pawns are better they're more advanced
they're taking control of important
squares and we saw that Hikaru slit his
Rook to E1 E4 not available yet but as
soon as white develops that queenside
Knight that Black Knight Will hop in to
the E4 Square yeah bit of a waiting game
neither side wanting to commit those uh
commit to those plans commit their
pieces yet and any trades do help black
so okay the bishop comes out I once had
this exact position uh pretty much
myself and uh I was on the black side I
found it really difficult I was very
cramped I was playing against the young
Chinese Superstar are Wei ye and yeah
eventually I just couldn't deal with a
space disadvantage for black I just
really disliked the fact I had no Pawn
breaks I had no plan so interesting
strategy from Hikaru not initiating any
direct contact between the enemy Army
between the two sides here but uh yeah
very much a slow maneuvering waiting
game
this is what black is lacking in these
openings and there are two approaches to
try to neutralize that one could be that
you Advanced the pawn in front of the
queen just one step ahead and he does
that and what black eventually wants to
do is try and get an E5 break as well so
the Knight will come to D7 The Rook will
move to the center of the board on E8
and either the C Pawn will advance to
Quest forward or the E Pawn goes to E5
and then you start asking white
questions about what you want to do with
those Central bonds yep very flexible
and you're right it does resemble a
hippo black just wallows in his first
three ranks weights weights weights and
then we'll be ready to pounce later when
the prey comes too close
and the reason I believe that it's
called a hippo is because if we look at
the pawn formation it kind of reminds
you a little bit of a hippo just peeping
out of water does it
in New York City I don't really hang out
with too many hippos very often but uh
yeah I guess that could be why it's
called that uh-huh only only explanation
isn't there an open
able in New York City the orangutan ah
yeah I think what's that New York Zoo
someone went down to the zoo
someone needs to research this Magnus
told me the story once we literally uh
somewhere in Norway we went on a little
trip and we went to the zoo we had to
take a detour to go and check out the
orangutan just so he could tell me the
story and look at it but uh I can't
remember sorry Magnus
but there is an opening called the
orangutan that is one B4 it's also
called the Polish opening sometimes but
uh one before yeah
and this one is a different breed of
animal this one uh White will get the
space advantage in the next few moves
there's already a threat small
positional threats of pushing forward in
the center I don't think you can wallow
in the water for too long as black
because suddenly white does get the
three pawns here and uh you will suffer
long term with your pieces nowhere to
put black pieces while you face such a
strong Pawn Center so I expect Magnus
now to lash out to try and break the
center perhaps with a move Tanya
mentioned okay no I was going to say
maybe he strikes with the move C5 just
trying to break down white structure but
he brings his Knight out in front of the
encountered Bishop very very rare type
of move what is the uh what is the idea
after this Pawn pushes forward maybe
it's a tactical one yeah I think this
might even move his Knight just
backwards he might just say Let Me Go
Knight back from F6 to D7 uh it's
another night and open up the dark
Square Bishop because E4 is a committal
move even though it's a good choice look
at those three Pawns in a row the D4
Square becomes one that black can Target
and then there's no white Pawn that can
help cover that actually happens in many
queens Pond openings where you give
white the space but if you push all the
way up to D5 let's say to protect your
Pawn by moving off the attack Square
then that Bishop on G7 is a monster
slicing across the board so it's a big
decision for Hikaru you know he's been
playing for E4 magnets allowing him to
do it and now that the opportunity has
come to fruition he's like do I really
want to push that pawn forward I'm not
sure I trusted and Magnus saying come on
let's go I'm ready for it really clever
strategy normally in the hippo uh in the
hippopotamus defense you get the Black
Knights on these two squares here
they're much more active they're already
on that very nice post so very flexible
here Magnus is ready to counter with one
of these Pawn strikes in the center if
given time if given the opportunity so
uh yeah if you don't push now for white
I think Hikaru should and most likely
will push this Pawn because it's the
most ambitious but if you don't if you
take a timeout for example move your
queen then black will be able maybe to
go for the same plan Robert mentioned
that to just drop the Knight back put
some pressure on this pawn and then
strike in the center with E5 this bishop
actually it looks like a London system
but it's misplaced in this Pawn
structure because it doesn't have any
good squares to retreat to and uh yeah
Magnus really creative
solution there to the opening problem it
looks like he's cramped but very very
solid and Hikaru burning time to try and
break down this hippo defense all right
the winner of the winner is final will
go through to play the Grand Final in
the air things Masters on Friday the
loser will play the losers final
tomorrow and we do have a question on
Twitter from treyao
um and I'll ask this to you Robert
because you're so in control of the
regulations what happens if the winner
amongst Hikaru and Magnus lose in the
Grand Final versus the winner from the
losers bracket I got the answer for you
so that match the first match would be a
four game match and if the previously
unbeaten person loses then it means your
second match of two games so today we're
kind of in the winners bracket until
that winner loses and then we get a
two-game finality uh it would be six
games minimum on that day and maybe with
Armageddon even more wow so a grand
final reset to be played if the player
from the Winner's final loose so that is
basically how double elimination work
you can lose one match and still win the
whole thing but the second you lose a
second match it is over
these two still haven't lost a match in
the air things monsters but one of them
will lose the match today either in the
rapid portion with four games or an
Armageddon they are tied so far this is
game two any car did make his move yeah
and a slightly superficial night jump
this white knight is not well placed at
all on this Square on B3 uh Robert's
mentioned uh in the past that Knights
are often dominated by enemy pawns if
there's two gaps two empty squares
between them this white knight now is
dominated by the black porn on B6
nowhere forward to jump but he's just
trying to control the center just
creating some squares maybe for the
White Queen to jump forward to and I
guess that Knight will just be happy to
retreat uh in a few moments time
meanwhile Magnus good air quality good
position uh can you back it up
one of the things that the knight jump
on B3 does invite from Magnus is the a
pawn advancing down the board A5 A4
really targeting it so that's something
that white needs to keep in mind but
meanwhile Magnus continues with the idea
and the plan that we've been talking
about trying to get that E5 break in
because that's really how you want to
challenge White's position in the center
by the way guys we were talking about
the orangutan and I couldn't stop myself
but actually looking up what the story
was because David you're right it did
come up and I think um it's a very
interesting one and I couldn't remember
so I was what was it and it was a
tournament in New York back in 1924.
whoa and it was the legendary
Grandmaster tartakova who was going to
play against maroxy and before that
before that game there was a trip to the
zoo the New York zoo I think the Bronx
Zoo maybe and the players went there and
Legend has it that tatakova was trying
to think of what he wants to play
against his opponent he was watching the
animals and then he says in his
interview or it came out later that it
was an orangutan who advised him to go
one before in his next game really and
that's how it got named the orangutan
1v4 wow how cool
maybe some help is needed in that
situation of you know we're talking to
the orangutans uh yeah that's uh maybe
not the best look for the best chess
players but it's cool opening and Magnus
Carlson has played it um he has put it
in actually the Champions chess tour in
the past not a good opening but one that
is quite fun so from 1924. the Bronx Zoo
where it was found by 100 year
anniversary
all we need to celebrate that let's all
go to the zoo let's do it yeah and
nowadays modern place they choose their
openings in different ways they check
the computer they ask their seconds yeah
no trips to busy but 1924 is that
considered an A quite new opening
oh
interesting
that's a mind dirt puzzle yeah I guess
when you tell us the viewers
everything's named when were they
created probably before like what is the
newest the most modern chess opening oh
the mom's house
yeah we set it up in front of us uh here
Tanya
um The Carlson variation of the Sicilian
that I saw Levy Rosman was recommending
in his uh chessboard course that's
pretty new four or five years old
hmm I feel like it was not just let me
recommending and then a niche kind of
said oh farming views by mentioning
magnus's name and then he's posted the
chessboard course where it says the
Carlson variation so there were some
funny barbs back and forth between those
two uh but you know speaking of people
who go at it uh Hikaru Nakamura Magnus
Carlson finally a Magnus has decided to
strike in the center with Pawn to E5
there is a ton of tension and something
about that Knight that's on B3 we were
criticizing it because it's dominated by
Black's pawns my coach always taught me
that Knights on the B3 B6 G3 and G6
Square so the equivalent squares uh the
knights third square that they they get
stuck there for a long time they often
stay there for far too long and they're
easily dominated so I just did not like
the look of it when it was played I
don't like the look of it now black has
the bishop pair and is opening up the
board so I'm really liking magnet's
start to this game here in the second of
the match I feel like hikara has not
obtained any opening advantage and he's
also down on the clock yeah and Hikaru
himself actually in interviews during
the world rapid uh sorry the world
official random Championship he was
saying that a common mistake that even
top Grandmasters make is they put their
Knights on these squares in Fisher
random chess he said no no you should
never do this unless you really have to
because Knights get dominated by pawns
like this the Knight has to spend three
or four moves finding a better circuit
and now he's gone against his own advice
he's put his Knight on a pretty terrible
Square the rest of his position the rest
of the white position is fine it's solid
but you don't have an easy answer to
this uh tension in the center if you
step forward you only block your
remaining bishop and after the Black
Knight moves you can move it anywhere
pretty much even if you go back home to
relocate it the Knight has an active
Square this bishop is dead for now no
Pawn breaks for white you're just a bit
stuck waiting as black slowly improves
his position and if you open things as
uh yeah as we've discussed this only
helps the bishop pair black here for
example can recapture with the queen and
uh there's some nice threats along this
diagonal I'm kind of struggling here to
find a solution for white maybe you can
jump into the center with the Knight you
hit the queen but what next the queen
moves and maybe you relocate the White
Knight over to these uh nice juicy
outposts so these holes in the black
camp but still from there what next
eventually you have to solve this
tension in the center and it's not clear
how you should do that I look at the
position I see that black has managed to
get that Central Break in with E5 and
also Advance the a bond threatening A4
actually winning that D4 Pawn already
and it looks like the hippo has come out
of the water it's no more everything on
the third rank the pieces have moved
forward the space problem so far looks a
lot more solid for black and I think
David your plan of rerouting the Knight
to C3 makes a lot of sense because the
one drawback of these pawn moves has
been the weakness on the light squares
so imagine if White Knight did get into
C3 you can look at jumping on to D5 B5
hitting that C7 Pawn everything is under
control but you might have to calculate
what actually happens after A4 the good
news is that you can fall back with the
Knight
and D4 is not exactly hanging I see the
eval bar doesn't approve but I just
wanted to make a point here that black
actually cannot pick up the D4 Pawn
because notice the bishop and G2
actually pinning that Knight on C6 to
that Bishop on B7 yeah and Hikaru is
gone for a slightly different version of
what we're just showing he's first
traded office set of central pawns and
now he's landed his Knight in I'm
expecting the Knight to drop back there
we go and next move the Knight Will land
on a really nice Square however
the rest of his position doesn't make a
great impression especially this Knight
still stuck on B3 blacks Rooks have easy
access if black can ever push this Pawn
forward and open up his Bishop maybe
even now I was about to say ever is now
because you push that pawn off the board
to E4 uh this is a big problem for white
only black has a dark Square Bishop that
Bishop is wide open on G7 if you take on
e4 with your knight the bishop says
hello to that pawn on B2 you can just
grab that and then White's Pawn
structure is clearly worse Black
controls all of the vital squares in the
position and that A5 Pawn will continue
pushing at some point so that seems off
the table and you can't take on e4 with
your Bishop because tactically that
immediately fails and because Bishop can
take the Knight on C3 and your light
squares are horrible even if you don't
lose material you are going to probably
a checkmated so this is a nightmare of a
position and Magnus plays E4 he does not
hold back and he's a lead on the clock
and a huge advantage on the board yeah
this uh is really blocking down uh
locking down even this white Bishop
terrible piece now there's holes in the
white Camp Magnus puts his Queen on a
Central Square he's just going to
centralize this Rook he's going to
support his Pawn in the center and
White's position is in Ruins it's
suddenly turned in the space of two or
three moves we kind of hinted that the
momentum was turning in Black's favor
but I would never have imagined that
this is the position we would see on the
board from this opening suddenly
everything's gone in Black's favor I'm
loving I'm loving Black's position I
mean with the queen and the bishop lined
up and very importantly as you pointed
out Robert that white has nothing no
piece that can actually ever challenge
that Bishop on G7 which is the key to
Black's position B2 Pawn is such a big
weakness and I'm struggling to find a
way for white to actually defend it
except to defend it with his Rook but
that doesn't really help I mean Rook B1
is an ugly move that you don't want to
make you don't want to make your
position so passive black is already
threatening to push the a pawn not just
that black can also offer a night trade
with that knight from C6 jumping to B4
opening up the a file if you decide to
trade the knights if not the Knight
lands on D3 and is super happy it looks
like with the black pieces Magnus is
putting a lot of pressure on and I have
to say so far in the match the opening
battles have been won by Magnus with the
white pieces in the previous game as
well as this one it looks like uh Hikaru
has been on the defense right out of the
opening
rat to see hikarus alone the clocks
sorry about Robert uh five minutes
against nine I've never seen him this
far down on rapid chess
um definitely in magnus's favor
everything right now and he does it he
goes for the idea that oh I was
mentioning earlier Robert of of opening
up that a file with a trade you get rid
of White's only active Knight and yes
you've doubled the the B pawns but look
at that a pawn the B4 Pawn is a huge
strength in Black's Camp it is taking so
much space so many squares from White
and now White's Rook on A1 is just
forever stuck defending that A2 Pawn The
Rook on D2 is stack defending the B2
pawn it just and what is the Knight on
B3 doing it looks like it's got no
future at all yeah you can give this
white knight three or four moves maybe
if it comes around here and here and
here bang into the center but of course
this is a luxury that Magnus will not
allow and uh I'm struggling to look for
moves so I'm struggling to find ideas
here for white I feel like the only idea
I can find is me pushing the a pawn for
white because otherwise your pieces are
stuck he makes the move of was it his
move or yours his move sorry oh wow
Bishop H3 but it's because he doesn't
have ideas in the position so he's like
let me just move my Bishop over here
maybe it can slide all the way up to D7
it's a one move threat it doesn't
actually amount to much but any other
moves look like they had damage to
White's position so I do when all said
doesn't like the move I just don't see
what's next
and we talked of hippos earlier now it's
white who's cramped locked in their
first three ranks suddenly black can uh
for example maybe not now but over the
next few moves just push this Pawn
forward relocate this bishop at will and
start coming around start attacking
pawns still white Bishop now completely
disconnected from the rest of its pieces
and this Knight needs to spend three or
four relocating uh you mentioned Robert
that uh at some point Hikaru could
potentially push a pawn for it just to
release some tension to try and trade
off a set of Rooks trade-offs and pieces
I think you'll have to go for this at
some point but but uh yeah arranging it
successfully is the first problem even
if you do push it you will be left with
some isolated I love magnus's move he
just brought his Bishop up one square in
the diagonal because he wants to slide a
rook to d8 at the right moment he needs
The Bishop's defense because the queen
and the white Rook line up so he's just
trying to trade off some of the pieces
and hit car says I cannot wait any
longer if the Rooks are gonna get traded
the B2 Pawn will be lost so he pushes
his Pawn to A3 but now black can simply
capture that pawn on A3 and shatter the
White Queen Side Pawn structure we've
seen this many times throughout the air
things Masters when you have separated
pawns like this they become easy targets
because the Pawn's best friend is
another Pawn look at Black's Pawn
structure on B6 and C5 you have to
somehow get to the B6 Pawn not easy to
do whereas white pawns both of them are
loose so that means there are two
Targets and you're gonna have to take
your time defending them both yep easy
to get at them easy to start attacking
them these pawns and uh that's not just
a short-term feature that's going to
endure till the end of the game so
Hikaru who's doing he's doing what he
needs to do he's trying to trade off
pieces he's trying to some level of
activity but it shouldn't be enough with
accurate play and uh wow okay he's
traded a set of Pawns and recaptured
with his own Pawn I forgot this was
possible I've got to say I thought this
Rook would be attacked in some
variations but the White Knight does a
good job defensively so far and it does
feel like the time to start trading off
pieces starts bringing the rook in even
if all the heavy pieces disappear the
Rooks the Queens the two Bishops there
for black would guarantee a long-term
advantage and Magnus does it with his
other more accurate and there's a cool
move that black can think about playing
at some point you typically think the
Rook went to date to exchange Rooks it
may sit on the D3 square right in front
of the enemy Rook because if you're not
careful and you just start taking the
material once the E4 Pawn is gone that
Bishop opens up in the longest diagonal
there could be some checkmating threats
so be careful about that that's my
favorite thing in chess or one of them I
don't know if it's my exact favorite
when you stop one square short of
expectations I think it's really awesome
really cool idea that I've got to say
Robert just uh jumping into the heart of
White's position just shattering in that
hot and opening up lines for your
Bishops I think the reason that uh
Hikaru decided to trade with Bonds on
a3a so that the Rook from A1 can
actually jump over to the B file we've
been screaming about the only weakness
in magnus's position is that B6 spawn
you want to start targeting it and
create your own counter play as quickly
as possible Rook B1 is an idea in the
air first he says I'm gonna stop
Robert's idea Bishop to D7 a big blunder
because you can just slide the queen
back and once the queen goes back to E7
The Rook on A1 is under attack the
bishop on D7 is loose if that Rook moves
somewhere careless then the A3 Pawn is
going to be captured I think you're
actually just losing material on the
spot and Magnus wow he doesn't react
Magnus he's trying to hustle Hikaru on
the clock your right rubber actually the
bishop jumps in kicking this Rook away
suddenly the bishop hits protecting is
doomed
think he could have won material he
would have banked this game basically he
would have guaranteed a material win but
Magnus missed the moment instead of
retreating his Queen opening up his
Bishop against this Rook he simply
parked his King on a slightly better
Square decent move but is it still
available
is the idea still on oh maybe it's
different this time because when the
queen Retreats the white rope couldn't
use this Square preventing the intrusion
uh the invasion of the black Bishop
because now suddenly this Pawn is
defended the moment has passed and
Hikaru is still suffering but not lost
yet and it doesn't look like Magnus has
realized that's a good thing yeah I
don't think either player have realized
just the moment of mutual blindness as
we mentioned on previous days and yeah
has Robert says it's a good thing
otherwise Magnus would be beating
himself up and he'd be dwelling in the
past not in the present moment wow
tactics like that happen all the time
but they're so hard to spot in Rapid
chest Blitz chess in a classical game
you kind of sit there for two or three
minutes you sip your tea you realize
that your opponent's done something a
bit uh bit careless a bit loose but uh
yeah in class in Rapid chess it's so
hard to kind of stop and force yourself
to calculate but look at hikara now he's
popping his head he looks super
confident suddenly he looks happier than
he used to at least he has one active
piece that bishop and the bond is still
alive everything's defended so far also
he has made progress on the clock now
Magnus just has a two-minute lead which
isn't as much as it was and Magnus
opening up another front this is super
this is what shows the idea of the last
move King to G7 also locating that a
back rank for the Rook to slide over to
the H file when required for an attack
it's not just on one flank that Magnus
wants to play he wants to play all over
the board H4 coming in and just imagine
David H4 you trade the pawns you put
your Rook on the H file you double up
with your queen on the H file and you're
then already threatening to Checkmate
the black king and this was the idea
behind magnus's last move we were
talking about winning material Magnus is
going for her karu's King here yeah you
make it sound simple Tanya is
and the reason why is because white can
hardly do anything yes you've taken care
of your a pawn weakness your Bishop
looks active then what a Black's plan
does look pretty straightforward and if
you stop that pawn on H5 with pushing
your own Pawn to H4 you know that G6 to
G5 is coming at some point I'm not sure
right now but you're blasting open the
white king side and White's pieces are
all over the place blacks pieces are
quite harmonious so I would be very
worried very reluctant to play the move
H4 and look at hikaru's clock by the way
he is down to nearly two minutes magna's
still at five and a half minutes yes he
played a little bit too quickly but
bring his King up to G7 that was
attacked the Magnus of course is capable
of finding but now after the move H4 you
you can see all eyes I'm pushing forward
on the king side for Magnus Carlson yeah
it's about arranging that break setting
up that break opening lines towards the
white king Magnus needs to take three or
four prep moves just to get ready for
that but he will be looking in that
direction for sure and uh you're right
Robert hard to imagine what white is
actually trying to do next maybe White's
rook in the corner will at least shift
off that long diagonal that dark Square
diagonal where it is a clear Target but
first Magnus has moved to make and five
minutes against two and a half you would
assume that he's able to set some
serious problems here for Hikaru if he
doesn't win this game Magnus Carlsen
he'll look at the first two as massive
missed opportunities and suddenly the
rest of the match today will at least
feel like a second life for
hikaranakamura and uh yeah first Magnus
I'm expecting him to move a rook maybe
to slide the black queen back the
Bishops are a bit stuck right now you
need to get them working you need to
give them a job to do so Magnus how does
he activate his pieces at the moment
that white Bishop on D7 it's like a plug
it's holding the floodgates it's uh
stopping blacks pieces from pouring
forward so he does switch Focus Tanya he
makes his intentions super clear and I
think once again that move King to G7 is
super telling he has a tunnel vision
right now he's going for the king side
attack he doesn't care about the
material I see that if Alba doesn't like
it and says that Magnus has missed an
opportunity with this is asking so many
critical questions to Hikaru Hikaru
doesn't even pause he says this is my
moment to create counter play on The
Queen side opens up trying to change the
Dynamics of the position trying to
create his own counter Play Because
notice that how if there's a trade the
C5 Pawn will be weak and Magnus
immediately switches back and that
signals that he did not like what he
just did in the previous move yeah
really weird and really rare to see a
player make a move the opponent plays
something seemingly useful and then go
back just giving the opponent two moves
for free but Magnus is arguing that now
there's extra tension now those pawns on
the queen side are looking at each other
that the tactics what might uh well just
work out in Black's favor and it looks
like they might if white is greedy right
now let's jump in and see what happens
if white simply plays the most natural
move and captures upon unfortunately
this Rook is now attacked three times
Rook takes rook and uh due to the
battery along this diagonal Queen takes
Knight is a available so this point is
actually pinned and if you can't solve
the tension I was going to say move out
of it and no longer a pin this white
Rook is off the a file it's also staring
down so if Pawn takes porn now would be
met by a night jump I'm not sure which
direction the Knight goes in it can
capture one of these two pawns and
suddenly this loose piece would fall off
yes you can win the White Knight but you
lose your bishop and suddenly no more
Advantage maybe fighting for equality
here suddenly Magnus Carlsen and uh
Hikaru is taking his chance amazing
defense by hakaro but it all started
when Magnus did not pounce he went King
to G7 it was a good looking move trying
to bring his Rook to the H file but it
wasn't in the spirit of the position it
was a little bit slow and now all of a
sudden nicara says you give me that
second lease on this position I am going
to make the most of it there's problems
on the B6 Square behind it the bishop 1
B7 as we're talking about and I'm not
sure I see a good move besides capturing
on A5 because you don't want to wait to
take on B6 everything is defended in
White's camp and we typically talk about
the bishop pair being an advantage that
Bishop B7 it's staring into its own Pawn
on e4 so if we get a series of Trades it
could be black who is worse and the
Knight hopping around causing black some
problems yeah he slides back with his
Queen what's the idea then if this Pawn
is captured are there some nice tactics
maybe it's the same idea that he
actually missed earlier Magnus I think
he spotted that this bishop move is a
threat he missed this earlier he could
have actually won the game pretty much
on the spot but uh now of course uh
Hikaru has realized that this is the
threat and he prevents that after the
queen jumps back he got his Bishop out
of Dodge he retreated it to a nice safe
Square now this bishop move is simply
achieving nothing we would just see a
rook trade so everything coming off the
board maybe on the D file Rook takes
Rook is available for example but uh
Hikaru he's definitely survived the
worst and the clocks are leveling up
balancing out and that seems like the
narrative so far in the match Magnus
getting these advantageous positions out
of the opening provoking weaknesses from
white but when that moments come he's
sort of not taken that super important
decision to go for the kill at that time
he's also playing on hikaru's clock but
now that's leveling up a little bit and
Hikaru being super resourceful in his
defense and this is truly one of his
biggest Trends I think the entire
Outlook that Hikaru is only an attack
and an aggressive player is a little
dated now his uh USB in chess is just
how difficult it makes he makes for the
opponent to actually win a better
position he does everything to make sure
that doesn't happen and it looks like
he's level the game one more time yeah
and the top players they are evolving
their style all the time and uh Hikaru
you're right when he burst onto the
scene when he was making his way up
through the ranks he was known for you
know the king's Indian attacking
masterpieces checkmating the opponent
but in recent years it's all about
strategy all about end games all about
her kind of locking things down and
defending very very tenaciously and uh
yeah he's incredibly hard to beat he
takes his chances when they come still
great calculator great tactician but
it's a yeah Miss Johnson again from
Magnus Carson and he's Frozen he's not
moved for ages now down to one minute
yeah we've had less time than her car
was crazy he was leading by about four
minutes on the clock and now he's down
to under one minute is Magnus Carlsen
and I think it's because he's regretting
the situation like how did I go from
having such an awesome position to this
where we might just liquidate and if Max
isn't careful and he gets in time
trouble Hikaru will make him pay so he's
trade off a pair of Rooks he can take
the pawn A5 but now the queen and the
Knight team up on that square I think
we're just seeing a bunch of Trades and
black is no longer better yeah Black's
no longer better you actually start to
fear for Magnus both on the clock and on
the board White's King is super safe
right now the black king looks pretty
safe but if a white Rook ever gets to
the seventh rank there will be targets
and now a huge threat after that pawn
trade that black light Square Bishop
it's got to move and you don't have so
many great squares which is why first
Magnus attacks the queen so that he can
then move the bishop and the White Queen
doesn't land on the center of the board
so big question here for Hikaru where he
switches up with the queen well he's got
a lot of pleasant choices he could move
it to C2 eyeing that e E4 Pawn as well
uh he could move it to the open file and
it looks like suddenly the ball is in
hikaru's court he's completely in
control of the position look at Magnus
he now seems very annoyed
yeah he's uh flustered he's realizing
that things are turning Hikaru with such
a Time Advantage is going to turn the
screw he's going to try and put some
pressure on no chance the hikar is just
trying to lock this down and go for a
draw now he realizes uh the initiative
is on his side he's the one creating
threats and not so easy this type of
position for let's play although if
hikar runs all the way over to the queen
side don't forget about this Pawn push
in front of magnus's King he could still
push that pawn for it and expose the
white king that doesn't have too many
Defenders so both sides have to look
across the board not get tunnel vision
and I do think that that's why hikar is
thinking at the moment he doesn't want
to just bring his Queen over to A2
because of those ideas in the game
amazes you know Bishop sacrifice at some
moment if you're really feeling
adventurous but the point is that car
needs to be careful right now he is
ahead on the clock but Magnus is a beast
in all type which was including bullet
he's not going to flag and he's going to
keep posing problems yeah the question
now is which piece is worse this Knight
on the rim or this bishop locked in in
the corner behind its own Pawn they kind
of balance each other out but long term
you've got to ask yourself that and wow
he does go to the edge of the board
Hikaru that feels like the wrong
direction remember we don't want the
queen too far divorced from her King
because that will spell trouble if the
opponent can attack you uh no Defenders
now around that white king and uh is
this the moment for Magnus to go for it
to push this Pawn break open the king
side he says no he shuffles his coin
across preventing any uh Knight jumps
into his camp and Hikaru looks very very
excited bringing his Queen in now I
think Magnus has to start going for it
before it's too late it feels like
things are turning and look at this he's
actually lined up the queen and the
bishop and is eyeing that G3 Pawn David
there could be a potential sacrifice on
G3 now white has to watch out for yeah
big move if you can land that sacrifice
and get the black queen into the
position uh White takes a step back now
it's less attractive doesn't come with
track but uh Magnus now trying to lock
this game down he's forcing all the
trades on the b-file we'll see an end
game and uh here we go it's Bishop
Bishops against bishop and Knight but
endgame is gonna be very difficult for
white because at some moment black will
be F6 and G5 and try to Spring free an
outside pass Pawn so for now it may seem
level the eval bar is telling us as
that's the case but the Knight can be
corralled by the Bishops and then at
some point you'd like to go for a pass
Pawn on the king side so I think if your
car you want to trade some pieces if you
could trade the Knight for the light
score Bishop immediately the game is a
draw opposite called Bishops even if it
costs you a pawn so that's why Magnus
he's just causing hikara some problems
he's going after this Pawn C4 maybe
he'll kick the knight at some point his
King can March forward yep let's go back
to the players uh Hikari looks ready to
get out of there will they wow I think
they've just agreed to a draw and it did
look as Robert predicted like a set of
Bishops were coming off the board no
more winning chances uh so a fair
results after a half full game wow does
that mean that Hikaru offered a draw in
this position it looks that way I think
the Bishops were about to come off and
uh Magnus looking through the game now I
think he's about to realize that he
missed a win or missed a very very
strong opportunity and there we go
shakes had computer confirms it to him
wow this is definitely that moment that
he realizes that it was a big
opportunity when he played that king
move and that would have really turned
the tide in his favor he looks very
disappointed right now with what has
happened yeah it's the second game in a
row remember he's missed two big big
opportunities and within one move Hikaru
is fine and guides it to safety and that
can be so frustrating David very
frustrating he needs to get over that
needs to forget that he's actually
outplayed Hikaru for phases of these
first two games uh still everything to
be decided yeah and they now have 10
minutes before game three magnets will
have the white pieces in that game and
in this one where was that Mr chanson
missed opportunities David yeah it was
just the one move it was very very
temporary but Magnus did miss the moment
he replied instantly and he did regret
it as we saw on the camera a moment ago
it was here that uh Hikaru played a bit
of a careless move he brought his Bishop
in this is uh tempting it's very
understandable very human you want to
block the deal file this bishop is very
annoying to get rid of for black but
Magnus missed that just this one moment
he could slide his Queen back hitting
this white rook in the corner and
suddenly nowhere good to run for this
white Rook if you run across the board
preventing a move will show in a moment
then suddenly you just drop a pawn the
blackfrook will happily take this Pawn
material advantage and a winning uh
position instead if you defend this Pawn
if you keep it defended then Bishop to
C3 does pose a big problem for this
white Rook suddenly this white Rook is
tied down it doesn't have too many
squares to go to and this bishop will be
lost for example if it tries to come up
the board then you can overwhelm this
bishop due to a pin on the default
guaranteed to win material at least a
rook for Bishop and Magnus would have
guided this to Victory
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
air things is the presenting partner for
this tournament
of great air quality but you're not a
subscriber on Twitch here is a twitch
break
[Music]
I'm joined in the studio by Adam from
everything so it's the presenting
partner for the tournament and has been
a great friend of the Champions Chester
from the very beginning I mean what is
it about air things and chests that just
goes so great together good question
um
air things is a Norwegian tech company
I'm working with kind of racing the
awareness out in the world around the
importance of good air quality and with
Magnus Carlsen being Norwegian and the
world's best chess player it was really
for us just a perfect partnership to be
used to to really bring the message out
there yeah
air pollution bad air quality and
um what do we know about the effect of
bad air quality to the brain
so air quality is extremely important
for our cognitive performance and I
guess everyone has experienced sky and
sitting at work or being at school
starting to feel a bit drowsy getting
that TV studio
and most likely this is due to poor
indirect quality aha so uh for cognitive
functions it's really CO2 not so carbon
dioxide and particulate matter which we
are showing live from some of our
partners ambassadors which is the most
important factors when it comes to
cognitive problems yeah and and chess
being a sport where you're just so
depending on having a fresh brain it
must be the perfect example of having
the importance of having good indoor air
quality yeah and that's what we're
seeing throughout the everything's
Masters now that some I mean like take
Magnus as an example
he started out with really high CO2
levels which is kind of unusual for him
his last year he played with green
levels throughout the whole tournament
um but when he now moved to Canada
usually plays in Oslo he started out the
tournament with some red levels and he
did some blunders in the third game
yesterday with high CO2 levels which is
kind of unusual
I think we have an example to actually
show that okay so
red levels for Magnus Carlsen has
everything's device showing this in the
start and then he opens the window and
it turns green yes and we have seen that
several times now I mean so this is from
Monday
uh oh this is actually from from Tuesday
after a blundered in the third third
game so so he blundered the air quality
was bad yeah he opens the window takes
uh
fresh air it's re-energized and ready
for the next game wow and it actually
helps that is fantastic and we do see a
bunch of symbols on this screen as well
I've actually seen in both the twitch
chat and on Twitter a bunch of viewers
wondering what does all these symbols
mean
so the first one is CO2 so that's carbon
dioxide so we breathe in oxygen and we
breathe out CO2 so poorly ventilated
space increase then you get increased
CO2 levels so humidity is the amount of
humidity in the air
um can read their little irritations in
your throat or other factors then it's
particular matter which Stefan talked
about yesterday yeah
um which is pollution basically and then
it's temperature erroneous temperature
VOC is chemicals in the air and then you
have radon so radon gas leading leading
cause for lung cancer for the
non-smokers and then it's barometric
pressure
all right so all of these uh symbols all
of this uh
ways of measuring air quality
um how much are we learning about air
quality over the last few years with
also air things and how important it is
with also after the pandemic so many
people uh you know having home office
and sitting in their homes just how
important it is sitting at home
um you've seen that a lot of people are
sitting at home with extremely poor air
quality but now it's also people getting
back to work and they don't want to get
back to work if the virus risks or the
risk of virus spread is also high so
we're using our sensors to really
make people comfortable and confident
that they can get back to work and it's
safe yeah and we do see actually Magnus
Carlson's air quality uh sitting in
Canada he has had some missed
opportunities today it's not perfect his
air quality and we actually you
mentioned Stefan a professor that we had
on the show yesterday who explained to
us that uh doing a study they found that
the chances of making blunders in chess
Rose by 26 when players had really bad
air quality have you guys and
everything's been surprised by these
finds
uh yeah yeah we've been surprised that
they're so um so strong correlation
between the particulate levels and um
and being able making blunders and chess
um and you can see that now from among
this is numbers he was up at 11 and
Stefan talked about if you cross 10 you
increase his chances with 26 percent uh
or making a nervous move so I think even
Magnus needs to crank up his airplane
purifier now and basically so if you get
an error things device uh you realize
you have better bad air quality you do
some changes you can actually decrease
your chances of making blunders for
example in chess by quite a lot of
percent
yeah and there is both well proven that
CO2 and particulate matter are really
impacting your chances of making the the
Right Moves yeah and just and if you
don't have an error things device at
home but you want to get one well now is
the perfect uh time because there is a
special offer during the air things
Masters yeah so we'd have a hundred
dollars off on our way plus
um it and it has to be said that it was
yesterday there was so much traffic to
the side but we it was similar happened
to us that happened to chess.com in
January the site went down but I can
assure everyone decided it's now open
for business fantastic everythings.com
both air things and chess is just so
popular right now uh so the site is
going crazy but go in there and get your
air things device to monitor air quality
in your home and we did ask a bunch of
the top players what is important for
them to perform in online chess what
kind of conditions do you rely on to
perform an online chess well you need
very good air quality huh and speaking
of which I probably need an update
another on the air things device I
really try to keep it super relaxed day
generally I would wake up a little bit
later really go for a long walk that's
what I would do during those online
tournaments I've become very uh
um very conscious of the air quality uh
like whenever like I'm playing online if
it's a tournament or another tournament
like if I start to feel like my head is
not really clear and then very often I
can just look at the device and say oh
that's fine it's mostly about taking
rest because you have to be fresh now
it's a little bit preparing and yeah for
me it was taking I was trying to adapt
even before the tournament trying to get
to the schedule and that definitely
helped I mean for me it's the most
important I think just having the time
time to you know prepare and just to get
in the right mood sometimes I will start
really badly in the first day and then
make the adjustments and then come back
plenty of exercise
need good sleep but also online you need
a very good internet connection need a
good mouth and
a lot of practice a lot of training and
all those little things add up together
how cool to hear that also the players
are paying attention to having good air
quality it's important when playing in
the Champions Chester when often they
will be sitting at home Magnus Carlsen
is in Canada Hikaru Nakamura is setting
somewhere with his family this is game
three they are tied after the first two
games and the winner is final minus with
the white pieces here we go yep Magnus
with the white pieces switching up the
openings no more ready opening now it's
well it's a bit of a surprise the BOGO
Indian black giving a check early on in
Hikaru smiling is this a uh surprise
he's prepared or is this uh is he
smiling for other reasons it's unclear
what do we think of this one Robert well
hakara does he said it's many times he
does like to look at the call the video
called the see his opponent's reaction
so I don't think this was expected from
Magnus so I think Hikaru he gives a
little bit of a laugh he's doing it for
the audience he said yesterday he does
some things for the content but you know
from a chess perspective this must be
uncomfortable from Magnus Carlson he
spoiled his advantage in the first game
with the white pieces it was never maybe
easily winning but he was in an end game
where he could have won a pawn in game
two he missed a clear opportunity that
we saw on camera he was upset when he
went over the game uh in analysis so I
feel like for Magnus he's looking at
this game as a not a must win but as one
he needs to press Hikaru in and A3 this
is topical yeah and uh just for a moment
Magnus was laughing as well someone even
popped in in the background and Magnus
like shoot them away so I think you're
right Robert he's the both of them
keeping an eye on the video call and
something was happening but uh Magnus
will definitely want to put pressure on
with the white pieces and
um this one I've always thought was a
bit controversial this opening it has a
decent reputation for black solid enough
but maybe objectively slightly uh dodgy
because black does have doubled B pawns
at least did but now after this last
porn trade white has one Pawn Island a
massive pawns that can connect can link
up and start advancing down the board
black has two point Islands they're
separated the A and B pawns are uh yeah
there's a there's an island there's a
how do you say this I'm trying to think
of geography classes with this little
kind of gap between these two islands
but uh yeah I either way it's uh not
ideal for black the structure yeah I
would agree with you and it's
interesting because Hikaru is the one
who sprung this well sort of a surprise
for Magnus going for the burger Indian
but this is so thematic breaking with
that a pawn opening up the a file
keeping your Pawn Island intact but
breaking up black spawn structure and
the A7 Pawn is often Under Fire now the
move B6 that has been made by Hikaru it
of course is a development on the B7
Square for the bishop but a lot of times
in the middle game we'll see Hikaru also
trying to push that a pawn to A5 uh to
keep it defended so that the Rook can
get free and the interesting decision
that but Hikaru has also taken a little
time deciding with the trade so I was
slightly surprised with that with him
not blitzing out his moves as fast as I
was expecting yeah maybe he was
surprised by the early A3 Push by Magnus
but it made perfect sense he's just
freeing up his B1 Knight that pawn on B4
was an absolute pest I like the one Pawn
Island that you're mentioning David so I
think that for Magnus he can just use
Simple development and for Karu because
he has the split pawns right the
multiple Islands he's just gonna have to
figure out what to do will he strike
forward with D7 to D5 that feels like a
very tempting move to claim space but
that Rook on A3 is particularly active
and you may see white double up Rooks
eventually along the a-file once you
Castle yeah even line up the queen in
the corner on this a file to go for
targets
um yeah very flexible it's early days no
forcing lines here but uh who
understands these structures this
position better I think that will be the
question white has now just castled and
we are now in the middle game
yeah it definitely feels like Magnus
Carlson has been the one putting the
pressure on dictating the pace of the
games but uh Hikaru here can he somehow
find a structure that doesn't allow
Magnus that type of uh enjoyment that
type of activity that he's had so far
it's all about action today and it's
also a little bit about Pokemon yeah
because we've sorry guys my fault we now
know David is a huge Pokemon fan a
question to you David from bag Senpai on
Twitter
to which GMS would you relate to first
generation starters in Pokemon Bulbasaur
Charmander and Squirtle Squirtle
squirrel
I would say who breeds fire and Alexis
yeah Alexis shirov would be Charmander
nice breathing fire all over the board
um who's water maybe who Cara Nakamura
just uh he's such a great defender he
would put that fire out and uh Bulbasaur
who's uh more Earthly who's more I need
help here Wesley so maybe Wesley so yeah
yeah very Earthly guy very uh likable
yeah can of course evolve into a beast
if he wants to be but it doesn't
necessarily need to in order to attack
the opponents that's a good description
we have it Bulbasaur Wesley so
Kimura
I'm just glad that I wasn't called a
Pokemon I feel like I was giving other
names so that he wouldn't turn me you're
like a little Bulbasaur over there I
always thought Snorlax was my uh spirit
animal just to sleep all the time I
always liked Psyduck oh yeah
you could do this all day
meanwhile Magnus has jumped in with his
Knights uh really creative move I guess
he's at least hinting that he's going to
offer a bunch of exchanges a bunch of
Trades because he does have the more
harmonious Pawn structure long term
white is doing very well as we mentioned
and if this Knight is kicked away it can
happily step back and challenge that
Black Knight on B4 on The Outpost uh so
interesting move how will Hikaru react I
don't think he needs to commit anything
now he doesn't necessarily need to uh
Kick That Knight back it will Retreat
sooner or later
well the plans that black has in this
position is upon Advance you either want
to challenge White's Center moving that
Queen's pawn two steps ahead and asking
why to take a decision or go ahead with
what I what I had mentioned earlier
David advancing that A7 Pawn to A5 so
just make sure that that Knight on B4 is
super defended and now your idea of
bringing back the Knight to D3 you can
very often just leave that night on B4
and you don't even care you can just
slide your Rook all the way to see it
and that's a nice trick because you're
hitting the C4 pawn and it white now
trades on B4 big blunder ends up with a
fork of the rook and the night yeah big
mistake here and the game will turn in
Black's favor so what is Hikari gonna
choose this one the more look at it the
more I like it Tanya uh just kind of
keeping options open I don't think you
should rush to kick away this Knight
because you might push your pawn two
squares forward later instead and white
wants to retreat anyway as part of the
plan to evict this piece from his half
and uh yeah either way it feels like you
need to get organized maybe push a pawn
maybe just bring the queen forward open
up a line for your Rooks to connect to
swing over to the C file feels like
that's where the Rooks belong but he
does go for your move he goes for it and
I like it and this is a very thematic
idea in the BOGO Indian where you really
want to take advantage of that B4 Square
it's really the only compensation that
you've created of separating your bonds
of creating these weakened Bond Islands
so A5 played keeping that flexibility
with the Queen's Pawn you might go to D6
you might go to D5 depending on what
magnus's approach will be I think this
game three is also a lot about
psychology right now because Magnus is
definitely feeling that slight
frustration of not having converted
these two advantageous positions going
into game three he realizes that Hikaru
is up to the task of defending this
match his resourcefulness his resilience
is on point in this one and it can kind
of create this frustration within so is
it going to be a more Angry magnet or is
he just going to you know be it's fine I
created my chances it means I'm the one
who is the better player today what do
you think is going on in his mind right
now he looks a little bored and that's
because the position is completely
locked up so there's no Pawn tension no
trades being offered and he's just
trying to kind of map out the future of
the position that Rook that took the
pawn on A3 right now at some point I
think it should slide back I've seen
this in variations of this nature where
it's done its job it captured a pawn it
kept White's Pawn structure intact let's
bring it back home at the right moment
but then what like I just see little
moves here and there that B2 Pawn can
slide up one square good for you you
protect everything what is the active
plan I think that's what Magnus really
wanted out of game three he's kind of
like Zapdos he wants to control the
electricity on the board sometimes his
hair also looks like uh you know he I
could say that because my hair often
looks like that uh but he is just trying
to control the State of Affairs in the
chessboard and right now it just seems
like Hikaru surprised him and now is
playing very energetic chess himself
yeah do either of you guys play the BOGO
Indian yourselves that's one opening
I've never touched actually is black I
a lot with white and I
I'm Indian I
like white spawn structures so intact
and it feels like even this move A5 like
you were talking about it gives activity
it also creates weaknesses in Black scam
uh watch out for that B5 Square the
White Knight can jump on to B5 at the
right moment I kind of like playing
against the BOGO in there but I have to
make sure that my opponent does not
Hikaru
normally good advice avoided Curry
in these tournaments he's a beast
and uh yeah Magnus now thinking he's
been thinking for a while still nothing
too drastic on the clock but uh it's
certain that he'll be watching out for
his air quality there we see looking
very healthy uh no excuses if things do
go wrong it definitely feels like uh I
don't know I'm gonna use soccer as an
analogy but uh he's had two penalty
kicks and the goalies saved them both
times now her car has saved them both
and yes the frustration doesn't tend to
affect Magnus he's very good at bouncing
back but if he doesn't win this game if
he doesn't even create any real chances
then he won't feel great uh facing
Hikaru with black in the final game of
the day
and uh who do you think would be the
favorite in Armageddon that's a good
question I mean I hope we get there I
think we all want to see this match
really go down the line to an Armageddon
and witness that it's so hard to pick a
favorite against Magnus and Hikari these
are undoubtedly the world's best players
in speeches I mean we're talking about
the top two they're on in A League of
Their Own so David a hot call and I
don't know who's going to be a favorite
I'll tell you one thing though
I think a car was a better Flagger oh
that is true yeah yeah has the better
Mouse speed I would say in those
critical moments and he just has played
I think just the most online chess so
that's his biggest Advantage but uh when
there are fewer games that favors a car
because Magnus is the stronger player of
the two with the longer time control
there's not much separating them but
Magnus is the stronger so I think that
if we get to Armageddon that means that
it's kind of like a toss-up at that
point and we also don't know who how low
they're going to bid because Wesley was
like oh gosh I should have bid lower
than a car who went nine minutes and 28
seconds what if they both bid like nine
minutes this time I don't think they'll
dip below that just because too little
time to work with but I can't call a
favorite because uh Magnus is refusing
to even make a move right now do you
think Hikaru would dare to go as low as
he did yesterday against Wesley when he
bid 9 28 no I think that Wesley is very
solid and so you sort of can anticipate
a style from him Magnus as we've already
seen in game one and game two he already
built a lead on the clock in game two
and missed the chance in game one he had
the advantage so if a car didn't have
the time he did that game would have
gone Max's way so I just don't think I
see either player really dipping below
10 minutes which is what Magnus said
yesterday yeah and it did seem that
Hikaru had more of a tactic in his
bidding he was sort of calculating how
low he can go Magnus a little bit more
random maybe when I think he bid 10
minutes and one second yeah like this
half does have a track record of not
really reading the rules not really
thinking ahead
um there was this famous case in Norway
chess where he didn't know the time
control and he just let his clock run
down because he thought he was going to
get extra time he didn't he lost the
game so it definitely felt like Magnus
as he said in the interview thinking on
the Fly just uh picking up a random
number and uh going with it but yeah I
it feels like Hikaru would have plotted
ahead planned something and he will know
his limits where he's uh happy with I
think it's going to be a big fight to
get the black pieces okay both of them
are going to want it they'll have to
strike a balance between their bed not
to go too low on the clock as well for
getting those black pieces so it's going
to be interesting to see their strategy
right now I'm confused about magnus's
strategy in this one though he's fallen
back with the Knight he's offering a
night trade so clearly the strongest
piece in Black's Camp is that night on
B4 makes a lot of sense but I have to
say it feels a bit strange to me this
last move David Knight 282 yeah it does
feel like an awkward Square
um if those nights are traded off then
okay it's done a job it's eliminated
that black knight but you're not
necessarily guaranteed to trade off that
night and uh maybe this White Knight on
80 will A2 will be sat there a couple of
moves longer and will be a bit awkward
to reroute and very often I'm sorry go
on no no I was there ending there I just
really like the move that we saw on the
board and and what I was wanting to just
bring up is that black doesn't need to
take a decision with that Knight on B4
very often because you can just leave it
there a trade there might look like wait
a second you're creating double bonds
but actually actually you're getting so
much counter play on that a file it
opens up your Rook or your queen will
March down the board and it just looks
like black gets enough compensation for
the weakness the apparent weakness with
these two pawns and that's what he's
done with this last move D6 just hitting
that other Knight I like hikaru's
approach so far in this game yeah feels
like he's playing very well and built up
a time Advantage Robert earlier you said
Magnus was refusing to move and again uh
after maybe the most natural move for
black uh he spent what was that four
minutes or so on this night Retreat
black replies hitting a knight and he's
back in the tank back thinking he just
doesn't have a clear plan but I think in
the long term what he wants is let's say
the Knight just drops back to F3 we swap
Knights on A2 really quickly I think
that he wants like B4 at the right
moment and this leave black saddled with
an isolated B Pawn so it's a bit of a
long story but he just wants to start
trading pawns at the right moment and
say your your remaining Pawn that's the
weakness white only has that at one Pond
Island still thank you David you did a
great job of putting the position I
wanted on the board and so black will
have to defend that pawn with pieces
whereas White's pollen structure is very
healthy so magnets he tends to look for
these small advantages and that's I
think what he's envisioning hikara is
like no you're not getting anything of
the sword I'm not going to allow you to
have an advantage for 20 moves 30 moves
and pressure me I think that eckhart's
done a great job out of the gates in
game three yeah definitely and uh Magnus
just has to bite the bullet and Retreat
maybe to this Square maybe he goes back
the other way but either way he has to
make a move you can't afford to go three
and a half minutes down against Hikaru
it's uh backfired before he's missed
opportunities and we're actually going
to see the whole line that you mentioned
there Tanya Knight takes Knight on the
board I'm assuming black takes back this
way you could actually make an argument
for taking the other night uh
potentially Hikaru has paused so he's
doing some calculation but okay let's
say black goes down this line the most
logical and most natural will see a
trade of Brooks we'll see a trade of
knights and after dropping back I just
love jumping in with the black queen and
also let's point out David that in fact
white has to fall back to F3 you can't
even go to D3 to put pressure on the B4
Pawn because you can easily lose the G2
Pawn then with the queen and the bishop
lined up so an easy Miss there but of
course Magnus will drop the Knight down
to F3 and then this is what we were
talking about the activity on the A5 but
let me ask a question do you think that
hikar actually wants an imbalance so if
he has the option to get these double
isolated pawns but the activity or he
can just you know just start taking on
E5 and trading off some pieces what do
you think he's gonna aim for very good
question because actually uh this one
initially I thought was a more risky
Choice the more I look at it it's uh at
least forcing white if white wants to
keep some tension to drop back and we
could see a trade and it's very very
balanced suddenly both sides have uh two
Pawn Islands suddenly white has these
almost hanging pawns and easy access for
example if the black queen moves for the
Rooks to centralize you're right Robert
maybe this one if he's feeling safe
he'll go for this but the Rook on A3
would be happy yes
The Rook lift they saw the uh the future
with that one but look what happened I
mean Tanya's line is on the board and
all of a sudden hikar's Queen is deep in
enemy territory but what about those
double isolated pawns that's the big
question yeah Tanya doing a little dance
here because you saw what was it five
moves into the future good work there
five moves each uh impressive stuff so
doubled isolated pawns for black but is
it enough Magnus now trying to offer a
queen trade without the queen so it's
gonna be much harder to Target those two
black pawns but uh I guess the Black
Wing was too active and needed to do
something about her you just kick her
out yeah and now the Rook comes into the
a file as well and black is going to
have control of that you've got to watch
out for that B2 weakness it just looks
like this is the first game in the match
where Hikaru is not worse out of the
opening and in fact Magnus might have to
be slightly careful in this one
definitely it's all about momentum all
about the clock as well in Rapid chess
and those two seem to favor Hikaru right
now I love what Black's done with this
position gotta say easily his best game
thus far yes he showed some great
defensive resources some skill under
duress but he's kind of controlled this
game from the start and now he controls
the only open file on the board and
that's why we like Black's position that
said if he doesn't make use of the open
file imagine the queen and the Rooks
they're gone off the board that's how
black gets in trouble because some of
those end games without major pieces
that means that the pawns will be under
some threat and black does not have
anything to counter with so Knight D2
takes away the E4 square a good start
but I could see hikara just trading
Queens on B1 slamming The Rook down on
A2 after that and saying to Magnus all
right I'm gonna be the active one here
you're gonna have to prove that you
could fed me off yeah you can trade off
these Rooks as you say Robert just jump
in with the Rook this night I don't mind
where it's placed right now but it's
miles away from ever attacking this Pawn
this pattern with the kind of on the
diagonal one square between them Knights
takes so far to jump around and uh go
for these weaknesses so it definitely
feels like a car is not in any trouble
you could also make an argument for
maybe trading off and now going for a
nitrate jumping in with the Black Knight
if the knights disappear as well no
danger at all these pawns are in dark
squares can never be hit by white Bishop
very smart here where'd he goes done he
starts with 94 that is so precise uh
David because this doesn't give white
the option to get away with the Knight
to B3 the line that we were looking at
with the queen traits and let's just
bring that up because it's so
instructive this moment if you do the
same thing after trading off on B1 you
jump with your knight to E4 now Magnus
can move away can avoid that nitrate
with Knight to B3 eventually he'll also
push out black snipe from E4 by
advancing that F Pawn The Rook can come
to A1 if your Rook lands on A2 you'll
have to move knight from B3 to C1
kicking it out also heading to D3
attacking that pawn on B4 so a lot of
Knight jumps sale which is why hey Carl
and this is just class I have to say to
start with the move Knight E4 and at
first it looks like wait a second there
are two pieces attacking it but what
black wants to do is that if you do
capture an E4 now he's going to pick up
the queen and then pick up the Knight he
solves the problem of the nitrate
because in on our live borders we can
see white did not have the option to
escape with the Knight on B3 this is
precise play Hikaru Nakamura is on a
farm today yeah that's what separates
the top players from the rest of us
those little move order tricks there's
little details that most of us are just
oblivious of we don't see them but the
top players they see these details they
uh make sure they're accurate on every
turn Magnus did avoid the queen trade
but uh once the knights come off the
board I don't really see any trouble
here for black for example you can just
slide the queen back you're defending
your Pawn The Rook might come in and uh
whose Pawn is weaker maybe it's actually
this white Pawn on B2 it's very hard to
evict The Black Queen but uh yeah
what else do you do if you're Magnus
Carlson you have to agree to this
position and your Karu has a simple plan
can I try and be a prophet for a second
what if Bishop D1 here Queen takes C4
Bishop E2 we see a repetition like that
is that possible somehow it is and also
let's point now you can't actually go to
D5 after that trying to threaten a mate
that David because big trouble here the
bishop jumps into F3 and watch out for
that Bishop on B7 yeah it feels like all
the arrows go on the long diagonal and
uh here white turns it in his favor
um so wow Robert that could well be
happening on the board and uh we should
point out that's in this position if you
don't have anywhere good to go with the
queen then simply this Pawn will drop
off so if you go back white repeats and
a little dance between the bishop and
queen could be a very logical end to
this game and I think Magnus will be
glad to get out of here actually in this
position Hikaru maybe has spotted that
and we'll be looking for more if he
wants to play on
what an intense match between these two
yeah we seem to say that all the time
because it genuinely is so close I've
never really see one-sided games uh
between these two it's just uh blue for
blue matching each other this is why we
love watching them play because we know
that we're in for a treat they're just
never disappoint the fans whether it's
rapid games or they're Blitz even if it
goes into Armageddon we know that it's
going to be fighting chess regardless of
the result we've seen two draws but the
result has not been reflective of the
kind of game that we've had it's been
big fights in the first two games and
this one is the first one where Magnus
is on the back foot wow and Roberts you
need to buy a lottery ticket you've just
predicted everything we do reach that
position and uh we might be about to see
a draw wow you are profit clip it ship
it the draw by repetition is about to be
agreed and that means we still have a
tied match Hikaru Nakamura with the
upper hand in game three he probably had
more chances than Magnus did but a draw
is the fair result and yeah I'll take
that one did you do this uh you know I
do love commenting with Daniel nerdinsky
and he's the prophet but I'm trying to
take his title from him I actually
remember this one time at the speed
Chess Championship when you know what
I'm going to be talking about what I'm
talking about Robert just sadamu which
was a blunder in one it just dropped the
feast and it was a blind side from him
but again the Pandey tree and Magnus
made that exact same at that exact same
moment it was the craziest stuff that
I've seen
just unbelievable yeah we're going to
the lottery ticket after this yeah and
it is a draw Hikari is out of there he's
off for a break off to refresh himself
and uh Magnus just checking over this
game figuring out where he missed an
opportunity where he went wrong the
answer is he didn't miss anything it was
just a very balanced draw three draws in
this match so far look at manga Scrolls
and looking over this he is struggling
to find a way to beat tikara Nakamura
there's gonna be one more rapid game in
this match it's starting in a little
less than five minutes now Hikaru
Nakamura will have the white pieces if
we have a winner in that game that will
be the winner of the winners final the
one who makes it through to the Grand
Final if it is a draw then this match
will be decided in Armageddon is there
anything in this game that we should
take a look at David
um let's try let's try it okay nice it
was uh it was really instructive how
Hikaru just hoovered off all the pieces
and kept a measure of control throughout
we mentioned in this position he had a
choice he could have captured this white
knight and maybe imbalanced it slightly
kept the game alive kept the Queen's
Rooks on the board but he said no he
calculated very accurately that these
doubled B pawns were well compensated
for uh by his dynamism his peace
activity we saw the Rooks leave the
board magnus's Knight had to step out of
the attack and this queen move every
move from here till the end was very
accurate from both sides we saw an offer
of a queen trade Hikaru said no not for
you I'm uh opening well conquering this
open file and after a few moves again
this really precise move order that
Tanya mentioned dropping the Knight into
E4 far more accurate than any Queen
trade than any Rook trade and uh The
Logical end to the game was this one a
little dance between the bishop and
queen the queen has nowhere to go other
than to take this Pawn if it wants to
defend B4 and that status quo continues
for the remaining moves a repeat a
repetition to end the game but a federal
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
the action continues uh very shortly
we're gonna dig it into all the action
happening in the air things monsters if
you're not the subscriber on Twitch so
here is a twitch break
[Music]
action between Hikaru Nakamura and
Magnus Carlson and the winners final
here in division two remember there is
also a division two and division three
in the air things monsters
you're looking at that as well Ivanka
what's happening especially in division
two where we know the winner of division
two qualifies for division one and event
two yeah when it comes to the winners
brackets then uh Fabi Carona and also Yu
Yang Yi they will be facing off against
each other right in the winners final
and the most interesting piece of news
is actually in the losers bracket there
it's quite spectacular
Vladimir kramnik is having the time of
his life first of all he took out yarn
upon yashi wow there you go very
convincing school and then he also took
up Matthias Bloom balm so he will also
be playing again tomorrow so Vladimir
kramnik former world champion he is uh
playing some good chess in division two
and could go all the way could go I know
and we can't wait for that actually wow
wow so that's division two we're keeping
a close eye on that as well everyone but
action happening between nicar and
Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen one rapid
game to go they are tied what do you
expect from that final rapid battle
should I give you my unpopular opinion
yeah yeah okay well I I think the
players will agree a quick draw do you
yes because Hikaru has track record you
know yesterday against Wesley so he
agreed a very quick draw it was that
famous Berlin draw and he just wanted to
get to the Armageddon and the two
actually did the same in 2021 when they
faced off against each other and the
score was level Hikaru Magnus happy to
take it to Armageddon
and even if a quick draws this uh you
know unpopular opinion Armageddon
between these two would simply be
fantastic I would be insane wouldn't it
would just be absolutely red hot
um I like the panel I'm actually
completely undecided who is the better
player because Hikaru Magnus are just
the players who are just in A League of
Their Own no one else matches them and I
have to agree with Tanya if it comes
down to the clock I do feel that Hikaru
is the one who possibly could flag
Magnus all right more action to come in
this one game four between Magnus and
Hikaru is coming up very shortly
this is game three they are tied after
the first two games and the winner is
final
I think we do reach that position and
see a draw the draw by repetition is
about to be agreed and that means we
still have a tied match
we certainly do it is tied three draws
but a lot of entertainment between
Magnus and Hikari so far today one more
rapid game
to go Hikaru with the white pieces in
this one and here we go if we have a
winner in this game that will be the
winner of the winners final if it is a
draw then Armageddon is coming off you
guys what will happen here we go here we
go and do we have two proper it's in the
studio will your Banker be correct it is
the Spanish opening will Magnus reply
with the Berlin and uh will that draw
happen on the board Magnus is pausing if
he doesn't bring out the Black Knight on
the king side now we're guaranteed the
game this one uh is not gonna fizzle out
anytime soon uh Magnus here is going for
his favorite uh reply to the Spanish
opening he often allows the martial
attack he goes for the martial attack
it's a Gambit here and uh Hikaru smiled
what do we think that smile was about
still a well-known theoretical position
white has won a pawn
it's one of those disadvantages of
playing in the World Chess Championship
everybody studies your games everybody
studies your openings and here Hikaru
says all right let's go into this
well-trodden path we see that black is
not threatening a check on H2 the bishop
and the queen line up it's not quite
Checkmate but it will not be good for
white to allow so this often is met by
the pawn in front of the king pushing
forward to blunt that Bishop's axis
towards the king side but in these types
of positions we saw Peter leco and
Vladimir krumnik they played this in
their world championship match very
famously uh it's a dynamic position
black has given up a pawn but gets a ton
of activity and some attacks against the
white king yeah and it's strange to see
Hikaru post to think I thought it was
automatic that you push that point in
front of your king one square the G Pawn
to block the attack to gain some time
against the black queen Hikaru must be
uh contemplating his moves after that
white does have a bunch of options some
are more testing than others some just
fizzle out towards equality some you
might be a pulling up but black will
have long-term strategic and maybe even
Dynamic compensation but uh hiko
reflecting that just uh picking his
poison uh choosing which line to go for
there is only one line you have to make
the move G3 because after H3 that's a
super soft spot and there are often
sacrifices that happen with Bishop takes
H3 so you don't want to allow that uh
equally surprised that he hasn't played
G3 yet but Hikaru is definitely looking
ahead right now the Marshall has taken
him by surprise now this is the last
rapid game between these two and a
result would mean that one advances one
goes to the losers bracket how much risk
are each of them willing to take in this
game and my feeling would be not too
much but magnus's opening going with the
Marshall does imply that he's ready for
a fight and not going for those
opening drawers Berlin draws these
options that he has which I think a guy
would have been happy to go with and we
do have a move G3 Queen H3 on the board
yeah I don't know Tanya these days the
top players they play the Marshall for a
draw it's known to be very solid despite
the fact you've sacrificed the pawn
white has this extra pawn and often we
see for example the White Queen come
over and offer a trade later on the
Queens might disappear and uh there are
lines such as this one where the White
Queen steps back and at some point black
just takes back the pawn we go down to
an end game and you can test the
opponent there but it will be a draw
there are many other popular moves in
this current position uh bringing the
white Rook forward was very popular when
I was younger uh sliding The Rook across
potentially to hit this queen to evict
it from the white camp and of course
other options available too let's say
Hikaru thinking if you want to fight in
this position rookie 4 is the main move
with this idea to go Rook to H4 is what
you really want to do in this position
and then one of the replies that black
has is to already fall back with the
queen to F5 here which is the most
popular response if Hikaru chooses to go
with the other idea that you mentioned
Queen to F3 it would imply that he is
playing it well very practically and
doesn't want to take too many chances so
if Queen after he's on the board we know
what Hikaru is happy with yeah he's
pausing though it's uh strange it's
confusing Robert it's really surprising
given that he played E4 went into the
Spanish it's not the first time he's
ever seen the Marshall so he's probably
trying to remember his variation this is
a dangerous opening let's say the White
Queen slides up to F3 trying to
safeguard the king and the bishop comes
into G4 to attack the Queen the queen
slides back we're down to pawn we are
not trading Queens the queen goes back
to H5 and suddenly their threads like
Bishop going into F3 or the H3 the white
king does not feel very safe and that's
why hikar brings his Rook up to E4 uh he
finally makes a move and look at Magnus
he quickly responds with Knight F6
challenging that Rook on its place and
The Rook slides the H4 the queen runs
away and now that Rook is really oddly
placed G7 to G5 push pushing that pawn
in front of your king can be an option
in some positions that Rook is almost
trapped over there the white king
doesn't have many Defenders I've worried
for Hikaru but I also feel like he is
remembering his preparation he's not in
completely new territory yeah it depends
on his mindset as well if he was coming
into this game Thinking okay safety
first let's just lock this down maybe
even make a quick draw then he does need
to switch things up now he does need to
switch away from that and at least play
the most principled moves you're not
gonna see this game uh end in a draw
anytime soon there's no Safety First
approach now he steps his Pawn forward
getting ready to retreat along this
diagonal with his Bishop very very
cunning move but uh yeah it depends on
Hikaru it looks like he's composed
himself after a few minutes doing the
right thing just pausing maybe taking a
deep breath and now it's a completely
different type of game I'm still curious
whether this is opening preparation or a
bit of a bluff but either way it seems a
decent try for white still upon up
pressure on Magnus Carlsen to justify
that sacrifice well D4 the last move by
Hikaru is not the most common move in
this position what usually continues
with the development of the knight from
B1 to D2 and the D3 Pawn
helps that Knight to land on that
Central E4 Square so D4 is definitely
going to take Magnus by a little bit of
a surprise and he'll have to try and
think how he wants to counter this
threat of the bishop moving back that
you pointed out and then that Knight
eventually Landing up on e4 remember
that white is upon up the more pieces
that get traded it does suit Hikaru and
that's what he wants to do he wants to
try and trade off as many pieces as
possible to make sure that the main
compensation that black has which is an
attack peace activity as we can see that
Bishop on D6 the queen is out a rook
will land on the open file on E8 it does
get neutralized you need to trade pieces
here with with white yeah very sensible
move and Magnus pausing you would think
that as part of his world championship
preparation he studied this a few times
or at least this variation he's gone in
depth with engines with coaches uh I
know the Marshall Gambit was his main
repertoire in 2016 against kariakin
who's his main repertoire last year
against yanduponishi and uh yeah it's
autism
I surprise him so early Magnus and Jan
Gustafson who is a martial expert has
also been in magnus's team for so many
years so all that knowledge that Magnus
has off the Marshall definitely comes uh
from Jan as well so shout out to Yan
it's one of those situations though
where Magnus might have forgotten more
than I've ever learned you know he's in
his position now that is tricky he's
down upon his compensation is on the
light squares and against the white king
but upon is upon us they say and if he's
not careful he may not find full
compensation sufficient compensation for
the materials and I think that's what
Magnus is trying to figure out is can he
try to open up his light Square Bishop
maybe on the A8 H1 diagonal all the way
across the board feed and keto that
piece or will he slide oh I didn't even
get to finish my Ascend he does slide
The Rook to E8 as Tanya was suggesting
trying to use the open file to his
Advantage but I'm starting to see how
the players are reacting after the
initial opening stage and I have to
think that Hikaru should be the happier
of the two right now and where do you
move with that Queen oh David it's a big
question Bishop C2 I really like that
move that you suggested The Rook is
already on H4 eyeing that seven square
so always be very of that yes you have a
knight which is defending it right now
but you need to watch out for threats
against it after Bishop C2 do you put
the queen on the centralized D5 square
is that what Magnus wants yeah let's
let's uh let's give Magnus the
opportunity to answer because I'm not
sure either uh I only see two safe
squares or maybe three safe squares for
that black queen not many uh squares to
retreat to and uh let's jump in to try
and figure out what he's about to do as
we see his awesome air quality still
very healthy stuff okay he makes the
decision before we can get there he does
land it in the center are we gonna see a
repetition again are we gonna see Bishop
B3 Queen F5 Bishop C2 it is happening it
is happening Robert said it it has to
are we heading to Armageddon we are
heading home again
Robert the prophet
well most Rhymes there we have it wow
another draw between Magnus and Hikaru
for draws and that means the Winner's
final will be decided in Arma get on
between the two online bosses Hikaru and
Magnus we have to be excited about that
Robert yeah I think Magnus can be
excited because he's sort of thinking
for a while there it felt like the
pressure was on especially considering
game three did not go his way despite
the draw so Magnus heads to Armageddon
of course all the fans say free chess
let's go and Magnus is still sitting by
the computer do you think he is now
starting to make some tactics Tanya to
find out what he's gonna bid he is
thinking about that big bid I think it
really comes down to both players
wanting the black pieces uh but what
time how much time are they willing to
sacrifice to really get that is the big
question I think this last game made it
pretty clear that both didn't want to
take too much risk which so much at
stake and said you know what let's just
uh get that Armageddon going let's not
forget we've got two streamers fighting
against each other do it for the content
yeah uh Robert you're the expert on all
regulations what will happen now with
the bidding okay the players will bid
they will submit a number and the side
that has the higher number of the two
gets 15 minutes as their base time and
the side with the lower number gets that
amount of time will likely choose the
black pieces and get draw odds if the
game ends in a draw that means the
player with the black pieces moves on to
the Grand Final all right so David
what's your expectations what will be
the bids who will bid the the lowest
time it's going to be a serious bidding
war actually Hikaru he I think half
jokingly yesterday in his interview said
he might go very low against Magnus
because he's desperate to get black
um so I think he's going to go around
the nine uh nine and a half minute Mark
just like yesterday all right it will be
revealed shortly you guys Armageddon is
coming up the action continues in the
winners final
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chess the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the points King to win oh wow though
there's no stalemate but still wait
there is still meat but the still made
the player wins ooh if only that was
real chess I think I'm getting the hang
of this game I think I think I actually
am getting the hang of it I think this
works oh that's a horrible blunder oh my
God I just blundered so I have to move
something else first then dark and
Knight will take my king this is the
best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there's some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chess That's so exciting oh no no
no no no no no
no no no no no no I won
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
so much fun happening on chess.com if
you're not a subscriber on chesscom
Twitch then here is the twitch break
[Music]
you and Robert just uh predicting
everything today I only got one
prediction rights and uh you can see my
big smile that's because I get all the
feels I'm predicting that one yeah I
knew it I mean how could it be anything
other than Armageddon right do you think
they're both looking forward to that
yeah I reckon that Hikaru has probably
thought about it quite deeply he's come
with a game plan and uh we'll see you
know what he has in store especially
when it comes to the time bits yeah you
uh brawl with you an awesome puzzle for
the viewers today Ivanka and it's time
to reveal the answer yeah and I have to
say to everyone I mean what an amazing
try everyone actually got into it and
they solved quite a bit of it but uh
very few people saw the whole puzzle
because as I mentioned there are loads
and twists and turns okay so it looks
like a straight up Pawn race it's white
to move white pushes the Deep on and
there you go one step forward black does
the same or of course and now here was
the pitfall the pitfall was you must not
promote to a queen because if you
promote there the the pawn will actually
promote as well to a queen and then this
is the crunch point that once the queen
comes to give check and you think hey
this is going to be an easy win the king
is going to protect the queen but the
answer is no the king can actually
capture the pawn on B3 and after Queen
takes Queen it is the dreaded stale mate
so this was a big twist number one so
you could not promote to a queen so
let's go back to this position and so in
this one loads of people got this one
right it was a very neat idea that you
promote to a bishop
and then the whole point is that after
the pawn does promote to a queen you can
give that check in safety and the King
takes porn isn't that scary because this
bishop takes Queen no cell mate for you
today and uh but then there was another
twist so let's go back and this is where
I feel like this is like part one and
then there's part two because after D7
it wasn't actually compulsory for black
to go running with the a pawn he could
actually trap and play King takes pawn
and uh if you were to promote to a queen
that would also be a big because after
porn moves to A2 and the queen comes out
to just defend against their promotion
of that pawn black would promote
anywhere anyway and after Queen takes
Queen stalemate once more
so
here it is
and this is so so cool in this
particular position white promotes to a
rook so we've had like the bishop under
promotion now we've got the Rook under
promotion and now the coolest line here
is if the black king steps forward to A2
this is so nice and then the race begins
so David is going to put those boots and
then the Rook Gets behind the pawn and
here it comes porn promotes Rook takes
queen king takes work
white actually runs with the pawn
nothing for it and here comes the final
promotion promotion to a queen
I know we've had the bishop we've had
the rook and now we've got the queen and
then the whole point once black promotes
to a queen oh dear
Queen comes to C2 and it is Checkmate
and this is the kind of puzzle that
gives you a Big Thrill when you solve it
you get this kind of ah Eureka moment
you share it with your friends and it's
just a fantastic study by vitelli
kovalenko fantastic wow what a puzzle
that was difficult twists and turns and
we do have a winner of someone solving
this puzzle that will get a signed
everything's device signed by Magnus
Carlsen and who is the winner the winner
is GG solving this very difficult puzzle
I have to say with so many twists and
turns congratulations on everything's
device is coming for you Magnus Carlsen
he's gonna need some good air quality
right now because Armageddon is coming
up and it's a big year for Magnus
Carlson he says 2023 will be a lot about
online chess
if you could list your three goals that
you pulled to achieve in 2023. Magnus
Carlson is looking ahead to yet another
year with exciting chess but first let's
go back to 2022. I would say on the
board it was mostly Pretty good overall
I think it was one of my better years
but off the board it was turbulent times
first Magnus announced he would give up
his classical world championship title
and then there was a big Scandal when he
accused Hans Neiman of cheating causing
Neiman to sue Carlson what was all of
that like no it comes with you know
experience that I'm able to to focus
pretty well even though things are are
happening around me and having a lot of
strong tournaments to play is always so
nice distraction from everything else he
definitely seemed focused at the board
as the 32 year old finished the Year by
winning back the rapid and Blitz world
championship titles was relief a part of
what you felt there heading into a year
where you will give away your your
classical title the timing is perfect
like if there was one time that I really
that I really wanted those titles within
hours yeah it just gave me gaming joy
and like still when I I think about it
must be smile uh it was a really great
moment
the world's best chess player wants more
of in 2023
you know to play and have fun I feel
like that's true more than in a long
time especially now that
I have these rapid Blitz World titles
now I can just relax and have fun I
think I look at it at least sometimes a
little more philosophically let me
borrow that you know if I have a bad
event I have a bad event then I'll hit
back in the next one
number one let's win a game with 1v3
and second is to have fun and the third
one is to win the game from
-10 position that's for the tour
cool right Magnus Carlsen with some nice
goals for 2023. I love the minus 10
position yeah yeah that would be fun to
watch yeah the other two I think he's
accomplished so maybe now it's time for
resolution number three all right well
Armageddon is coming up and let's reveal
the bids from Hikaru and Magnus look at
that Hikaru has been eight minutes and
59 seconds beaten by one second Magnus
Carlsen spinning eight minutes and 58
seconds and this is hikaru's reaction
when that bid came in Magnus has chosen
to play of course with the black pieces
Hikaru will have 15 minutes with the
white pieces he has to win it Hikaru
Nakamura Magnus Carlsen with eight
minutes and 58 seconds needs a draw to
win the match
I can't believe what we just saw winning
the bid by one second and this just
shows how well the two players know each
other we've got liftoff and how much
they wanted the black piece is bidding
that low Robert and I completely
understand From magnus's perspective
because he wasn't put under so much
pressure uh when he had the black pieces
so he's saying I don't feel like I am
worse I don't feel like I'm gonna lose
give me those draws wow what's your
reaction David uh I'm a bit shocked I'm
a bit go
against Hikaru Nakamura having a six
minute deficit and the black pieces it's
not going to be easy it is Magnus of
course but I think we'll see some
serious flagging if Hikaru can't win on
the position which is quite likely quite
possible we've had four draws the one
thing's for sure that this one is going
to be a result so Hikaru has to win on
demand he's got the white pieces he's up
on the clock by a big margin Magnus
Carlson needs just to draw and the
moment you say that since then it's kind
of it's hard to believe it's hard to
believe that you can fight this but you
can see what hikar is doing he's playing
a very close position because he wants
to do what David is suggesting he wants
to be a dirty Flagger he wants to win on
the clock not on the board I mean you
look at the position black has
everything under control what Hikaru is
relying on his lead on the clock he just
wants to keep the position as ambiguous
as possible yep no trades no exchanges
no clarification of the position he's
just trying to force Magnus to go into
the tank at some point which is
guaranteed happen and only later maybe
put him under pressure on the board or
make him uh kind of force him into those
difficult decisions worse comes to the
West win on time but I mentioned earlier
as well Hikaru the first iteration of
Hikaru Nakamura when he was young King's
Indian player on the attack and he's got
the same position with the white piece
and it wasn't just that it was also
hikaranakamura flagging the bots on ICC
because he would close the position and
make a million moves then upon move and
things like that to beat the boss on the
internet chess club so here in this game
uh he's not a bot he's only human but he
plays like a bot most time Magus Carlson
only eight minutes on the clock no
pieces have been traded yeah no bonds
have been traded as well so super closed
position here uh David you said worst
case scenario flag I think that's the
best case scenario here when you're in
the Armageddon when you're up on the
clock you've got to play the clock as
much as the position and look at Hikaru
this is when he's gonna make Magnus
thing Harry the H Pawn goes up the board
G4 coming in next
and uh White's light squared Bishop
which is a problem piece can also
activate there we go on a nicer diagonal
now for Hikaru he knows these inside
these ideas inside out he's been playing
these ideas since he was a kid yes with
reverse colors normally he's on the
black side but it's the exact same Pawn
structure Magnus he's got a promising
position he's got more space black has a
really nice Pawn chain in the center but
what do you do with it maybe less
instinctive here uh Black's plans and
he's burning time the time differential
here is increasing if anything in
hikari's favor this is really worrying
times for Magnus I've got to say but
trades help and so he just brings his
Knight in contact with the White Knight
on C4 he can swap off those Knights he
can bring his Queen up try to trade the
light Square Bishops and as the position
becomes simpler and simpler then Magnus
can find moves and what he really wants
to do is trade trade trade because if he
can force a draw somehow or get in
neutral position he'll go for that the
problem is if we get King and Rook vs
king and Rook which is an obvious draw
Hikaru Nakamura will try to flag him so
Magnus he's to keep his eye on the clock
he can just play quickly every single
turn
you've been talking about that white
Bishop on H3 one plan that black has to
follow up with the trades would be to
move the queen ahead and then to defend
that Bishop coming to E6 but look at
this the position has blown open hikao
says now is the time I try I strike in
the center F4 that is one committed
decision by Hikaru yeah I'm surprised
he's gone for it so quickly Hikaru
because finally there is a trade finally
Black's drop here or at least the next
few moves have become clearer they have
become more obvious and yes the
evaluation bar shoots up on white side
but he needs to back it up on the board
now Hikaru can't just rely on the clock
there is a threat Black's Queen black
star Square Bishop are lining up against
the white F Pawn so do you just Step the
White Queen forward do you bring that to
a safer Square maybe white is the one
now attacking on uh on the king side the
black king is on this G file what's King
at some point we'll take a timeout
Shuffle to the corner and realign his
Rooks but it's not the king that uses
the corner it's the Knight one flexible
move everything in the night bring up an
analysis where I think there was a
pretty critical moment here for Hikaru
he decides to step backwards but I think
he could have said sacrificed upon going
E5 and after Pawn takes Pawn F5 this is
a thematic Pawn sacrifice you throw your
knight to E4 you control all of the
squares in the position and you have an
attack I don't know if it would have
worked out it does involve sacrifices
and material but a current set drops is
my back top forward yeah and he uses
that phrase rotate the knights he's
definitely done that here it's not clear
the Knight is necessarily better placed
on the G3 square but it does hint at
jumping in later Magnus has to watch out
for the same idea that Robert mentioned
still on tap later but also a night job
even a sacrifice later to open things up
first he'll bring his Bishop to a better
Square bring his Queen to a better
Square line up keep the tension and
force Magnus uh to make difficult
decisions I I'm not sure who I prefer
here to be honest but I do like White's
position in general at least the chances
of a longer game it just feels like it's
easier to play with white the moves that
you're suggesting are appearing on the
board David he takes the queen out
expecting the bishop to come out the
Rook to come out here by the square and
at some point Hikaru will strike down
the board with H5 uh you have to make
sure your own King is safe first
meanwhile Magnus just waiting for that
break as well getting all his pieces
ready for what we're anticipating on the
board because once all the pieces come
to the center of the board Magnus also
will be ready to answer that break yeah
it's uh building up to its uh its
breaking point it's climax this game and
uh it's up to Hikaru how to initiate the
plan how do you prepare these Pawn
breaks that are imminent well the good
news is he wants to initiate something
to win the game but he can win on the
clock so if Magnus doesn't do anything
to initiate some trades then hikar can
Shuffle forever before throwing the pawn
forward I feel like this position is
actually quite difficult for Magnus
taking into account he has so much less
time so Hikaru he's spending his time
wisely right now he still remains about
four and a half minutes ahead I think
he'll slide his Bishop out develop his
Rook things of that nature and only
strike at the critical moment because he
wants to keep digging into Magnus
remaining clock yep it looks looks
almost automatic just bring the bishop
out throw the move back to Magnus but
Hikaru he has frozen he has gone into
the tank not moving quite yet and uh
okay four minute difference now between
the two players time Advantage
disappearing slightly but uh still a
very very relevant Factor uh Magnus
playing very quickly he's trying to
avoid any calculation it's clear so far
Magnus just playing intuitive moves just
solid moves but not really challenging
the white yeah well there's one weakness
that I see in hikaru's position and that
is the C2 Pawn which can be targeted
with a jump from with that knight from
C6 coming on to B4 and that is perhaps
what Hikaru is trying to look at how
dangerous is that once you take out that
Bishop because you really don't want to
trade the bishop for the night he just
first sidesteps with that King to H1
really hinting at that move H5 right now
which will make Magnus uh go into a bit
of a think because he needs to be
prepared to respond with that Magnus
immediately plays to move Bishop E6
we've been talking about the importance
of trade in this position he is afraid
of the attack a little bit the best way
to respond to this to this is to trade
off your opponent's pieces I like this
approach actually Bishop to E6 yeah it
makes a lot of sense it does depend on
whether white can trade off those
Bishops and then stepping uh step
forward with his pawns I'm not sure why
it's ready especially while the dark
squared Bishop sleeps while that rook in
the corner is still not participating
but uh yeah in general following the
strategy both players we called it
before they have come to the game with a
plan white keeping the tension black
Magnus trying to trade off pieces trying
to reduce the tension try to at least
make his game a lot easier to play in a
six minute lead on the clock has been
shrinking and shrinking now it's below
three minutes so Magnus Carlson is doing
a fantastic job of cutting into that
lead on the clock and he's playing great
chess he is sturdy and strong now white
will need to start launching pawns
forward the Bishops are staring at you a
card doesn't want to trade but if he
backs up that gives Magnus the hand at
the initiative so I think that hikar
recognizes the danger that his position
is in not just the match situation but
his actual position that if he does step
back he feels like it's going to allow
Magnus to take control and Hikaru making
faces he's not too happy he has been
playing a couple of very tentative moves
just shuffling that King into the corner
didn't feel like it helped his position
too much now he has to start making
concrete decisions actually put pressure
on Magnus on the board now is the moment
uh if you do start stepping backward
everything it will be too late
especially now it's only two minutes in
it and uh yeah turning in magnus's favor
perhaps it's getting more and more level
on the clock and Magnus that looking
very relaxed with this last move and
understandably so it just suddenly seems
as if the pressure has diluted imagine
if the light squared Bishops were to
come off at some point black can
actually strike those Central pawns with
his own F Pawn coming to F5 again it
comes down to him having bought his
Rooks already to the party they're all
ready for the central break black will
be the one who will have control of this
F and the E file Magnus looking good on
the position I think he's done
everything right to neutralize White's
initiative and Hikaru big thing that by
him it's what over a minute over two
minutes already very long think only one
minute in it now and if you don't trade
off these pieces which does guide Magnus
closer to that draw if you Retreat then
I think it's bad news suddenly Black's
Queen for example can move you can see
jumping in with your Bishop maybe even
Tanya's idea of playing this F sorry
this F5 break will become very relevant
black can open it on his own terms but
uh let's go back Tanya you predicted the
future this time and uh this is the
current position F5 on the board trying
to open up lines for Black's pieces
David I love Black's position we've been
talking about how ideally the Rooks are
placed and take a look at this now after
F5 I don't see a way in which white can
actually open the center that looks like
it would be great for black if Hikaru
decides to trade you take it with the
pawn the G file is open the queen can
swing from C7 to G7 at the right time
you can double up on the E5 it looks
like white might have to make the
decision to push that E Pawn and he does
it it's E5 the bishop on E7 and now this
H4 weakness suddenly appears out of
nowhere yeah uh he's at least hinting
that he might trade off these set of
Pawns now and maybe shift the white Rook
across towards that black king still
enough pieces left to create an attack
for Hikaru Nakamura but he needs to do
it quickly now he needs to rely on his
Instinct stop being in your own head
stop calculating you just got to go for
it no if someone liked the position
actually for a car because closing it
down it may make it difficult for Magnus
to find quick moves and then take our
could play for her that is why mags took
this Pawn on H5 that is a huge decision
by him because it opens up his own King
but look at the white king in the corner
now that's exposed there's a rook on E6
ready to slide over to the H6 where if
that Knight captures on H5 you may lose
that piece if it gets pinned so black
can start taking control of the G and H
files and that's why Hikaru says no no
no no you can keep that pawn there it's
sort of an umbrella for my king I'm
bringing the Rook to the G file first I
want to play Rook G2 Rook A1 to G1 maybe
bring a rook to H2 as well bring all the
pieces to the party before you start
taking a pawn that is double and
isolated and Hikaru was really surprised
by magnus's decision to break his own
structure to take this Pawn now long
term actually black is the one suffering
with all these isolated pawns here and
uh it's definitely time to follow the
players and as they make these quick
decisions it's a question to Magnus how
do you consolidate how do you set up a
defensive wall the black king white
trucks are coming for it and okay he
chooses to slide his Rook across and
these are exactly the kind of positions
where the eval bar is so deceptive don't
believe it I mean look at the chaos on
the board Black's King side is
absolutely destroyed that pawn on F5
h587 all of them are weak currently
black was a pawn up I was gonna say is
but Hikaru snaps up that H5 pawn and
that's a big blunder yes because there's
a tactic I mean I would not have seen it
without the evaluation where when Knight
takes Pawn on E5 that is a game changer
because once the pawn takes the Knight
on the Square the queen slides up one
with check and then the Rook slides from
G6 to hick no matter what white does
he's gonna lose his Queen so if Magnus
Carlson spots Knight takes E5 it turns
the tides in his favor and I think he's
looking at the way he's looking at this
position and he's kind of in a little
bit of disbelief Knight takes E5 is a
huge oversight by Karma Nakamura oh he
doesn't find it he moves his Knight away
same threat but it would have been more
effective to catch reporting the process
you would have been winning on the spot
another missed opportunity not the first
time we've said that today by Magnus
Carlsen he brings this night the other
way so this threat is still on uh on the
cards Queen check followed by The Rook
shifting Hikaru still needs to defend
tenaciously to avoid that one but uh wow
there's missing shots again that would
have been game over on the spot because
you create the exact same track but on
the way you win a key Central Pawn night
before well it still hits the C2 pawn
and you have this massive threat is
Magnus going to end up with an extra
Pawn even though it's not the amazing E5
bond with the c21 yeah and uh suddenly
Hikaru is trying to jump into his
computer screen shaking his head he
knows this one is still difficult still
the same threat on the board maybe he's
realized he dodged a bullet there but uh
isn't Black's F5 Bond hanging random
question it is well I can go and take
that pawn okay he doesn't Hikaru
Nakamura is stepping back that move
shows uh that he really is nervous he
does allow black to grab a pawn now Max
support up it's a little bit deep but I
think he didn't take the pawn of five
there might have been a draw by
repetition had he done that I don't know
if we have time to show it but that's
probably why he took a step back he
knows objectively maybe it's not the
right choice but he needs to win this
game and uh often in Armageddon chess
let's show that Robert just while we
were there Knight takes Pawn you can
bully your opponent with the thought of
a repetition uh how do we get that we
give a check I guess and then sacrifice
The Rook on F5 and then go Rook H6 check
and that's King on H2 is In Harm's Way
it can only go up to G3 in the position
and ideas with Bishop H4 check or Rook
G6 uh maybe I guess that was the wrong
one but the problem is this white king
is in huge danger yeah simply the King
has to go back if the King goes the
other way then you drop the bishop in
with the deadly check uh so the King has
to move another check and another check
and no way out it would have been a draw
so Hikaru that's why he was shaking his
head it was very deep stuff there
instead he had to give up a pawn this is
the current position uh Black's position
hasn't changed too much except you've
gobbled up this YouTube Pawn so long
term you're doing very well and we were
a little critical about Magnus missing
Knight E5 and now I'm just wondering if
this was part of the bigger plan that he
knew that Knight F5 he had calculated
his way through knowing that it ends in
a repetition he ends up with an extra
point and while we've got a lot of
Trades that have happened that cannot be
good news for Hikaru can't be good news
the Queens are off the board as well
things are disappearing there is a one
minute difference in it right now but
Magnus should be able to Hoover for the
pieces at least lock down for a draw
with his remaining time did see him
react though maybe realizing he has
missed an opportunity in this game but
he only needs a draw Magnus to win the
match he's now two pawns up but he has
let the white rook in that white Rook is
active now on the seventh rank is going
to start gobbling up some pawns Magnus
has he lost control suddenly Hikaru he's
hustling he's just trying to pose
difficult questions to his opponent that
Knight on D3 though I think is helping
Magnus out because that Rook would love
just take off that pawn next to it on A7
but the Knight would jump to B2 it can't
go there right now because the Rook is
aiming back at the square so I think
that he's going to use his Knight and
just mop up some of the white pawns and
the one minute difference this happens
in regular Blitz Games that's the good
news for Magnus it's stressful right now
with so much on the line but you get
down a minute on the clock all the time
in Blitz over the board and uh on
chess.com so I feel like for Magnus here
I mean he's at home because he knows his
position is good yeah and it's less than
a minute now in it uh no increment
nowadays over the board increment is the
norm but uh this one is a race to the
Finish it's sudden death and uh okay
Hikaru you gotta move you got to make a
decision if you can't go and take that
black a pawn maybe push the white a pawn
just hint that you're gonna promote it
later okay we see a trade of knights
getting rid of the very strong black
knight but every piece that disappears
from the board every trade guides Magnus
closer to that draw he's still two pawns
up remember and the evaluation bar still
in the middle can Magnus guide this one
to safety still big questions to be
answered okay he does put his Pawn on a
safe square but it's not going to be
safe for too long once Rook will go
after it eventually there we go and
what do you guys think predictions now
ah this this is stuff and it does look
like the clock is almost level both
players are under four minutes Chicago
has got an extra minute on the clock now
just look at how calm they are and that
is what is so amazing for me to watch
because you know this is pressure
expectations all eyes on Magnus and
Hikaru right now Under Pressure
unexpectation everyone chokes but these
guys are really bringing their A-game
Hikaru making decisions that keeps the
game going and that's the key to this
Armageddon look at him just pursuing
that pawn Marcus moves it one more step
ahead and now the bishop comes back to
attack it and I think he's making he's
creating his chances if that a passer is
on the board it's game on yeah an Under
Pressure great song bad feeling and you
see there's a passport for black but
white is ready to take away the A5 pawn
and credit past Arizona so we look at
the clock situation uh Hikaru back to
nearly a minute lead and it's not easy
choices from here on out so I feel like
Magnus has to be nervous given the
circumstances guys got to mention the
whole day magnus's air quality has been
great but as the pressure has increased
his air quality has got worse and worse
and worse and that might be affecting
his play and uh look at that suddenly no
green circles there for him if he goes
down to defeat maybe that would have
been one of the reasons meanwhile a set
of Rooks have been traded and uh Black's
pawns up all week they're right for the
picking Magnus he's just been playing
too slowly right now if he had better
air quality maybe he would be a bit
faster and every second counts at this
level the margins are so small the one
thing that he's relying on is if white
does pick up that A5 Pawn the black Rook
will swoop over to the a file hit that
bishop and along with that also win the
A4 Pawn if these a pawns get traded then
life is good for Magnus Carlsen he goes
easy towards that drop but it's all
about whether Hikaru can create that a
passer or not but I think that black has
an idea of his own Max will slide his
Rook one square over the d8 use the king
to protect the bishop and then bring his
Rook d8 to D4 and go out for the C5 we
did see manga us just bring his Rook to
date after his car stole a pawn so
magnus's plan is now clear will he have
enough time to execute it that's the
essential question with two plus minutes
on this clock I do think it's looking
like a task that he is capable of
handling yeah two minutes so on the
board he's fine but is the clock gonna
tell the decisive Factor here I think
you can jump in there we go the
BlackRock has landed not just as this
brought up for grabs the pawn behind it
and white has to bank everything on this
past Pawn you have to run it through
somehow you have to break the blockade
somehow evict this black Bishop kick it
away and uh somehow cause some problems
for the black king but on the board it
definitely looks like Magnus is in full
control and uh here we go position
progressing white Bishop is actually the
one being kicked around black has two
connected past pawns Hikaru doesn't look
happy at all and the clock is about even
so hit card doesn't even have his lead
on the clock he's down material that is
terrible news for someone who needs to
win this game yeah he needs to win it
but actually he should be the one
defending look at the evaluation bar
dropping down in Black's favor those are
two Runners those two black bonds
they're going to cost quite some
material and there's no stopping them
and we see Hikaru that he is worried
about his position but he's still wow
what just happened things are turning
again this will happen a lot throughout
this time scramble but the black pawns
are running they look quicker to
normally run it slower than one but
those two connected plus pawns are so
close to becoming Queens well I can give
a check and move his own Pawn one square
closer to the queening uh point at eight
but blackstroke just saves it and you've
got these two pawns which are
unstoppable how do you fight these two
Central pawns devastated Hikaru looks
like he's actually ready to resign
almost all you need to do is Magnus
steps and pawns forward if you don't get
flagged you're guaranteed to win this
Armageddon and now we have kind of a
blitzed game where it's about even on
the clock and Magnus only needs a draw
and we saw the bar go about level but I
think the reason that it wasn't actually
equals because a draw is bad for a car
it might have been a forced draw and he
can't have any part of that yeah Hikaru
is simply a pawn down now neither of
those pawns became Queens but it did
come at the cost of more trades more
exchanges and look at this classy move
from Magnus he's just trying to swap
things off he's now managed to get rid
of the Bishops rid of a set of Pawns and
Hikaru is he going to try and flag
Magnus the answer is no it's a draw
Magnus takes this Armageddon and the
match and believe it or not Hikaru is
actually the one who offered a draw
that's the ultimate sign of respect he
wasn't going to try to flag somebody he
was 10 seconds behind the clock against
that is a good show of sportsmanship wow
we see a big smile on Magnus Carlson's
face and he got her shaking his head the
big match is over Magnus calls when's
the winner finals with a draw in
Armageddon hikar Nakamura what a fight
he gave it but he had to win and the
Armageddon with a draw it means he loses
loses the winner is final
what do you think is going through his
head right now Robert disappointment but
I do think that Magnus played the better
chest between the two it was close uh
but I think that when we had this final
game set up a Magnus was never really in
trouble over the board so Hikaru
probably upset he didn't maximize some
of his chances it just wasn't meant to
be yeah
should we take a look at what
what in this game David yeah there were
many twists and turns in this one Magnus
did play a really exemplary game we
should mention Hikari tried everything
he tried to throw a Magnus off balance
he tried to hustle on the clock but to
no avail and it was actually here that
Magnus had a winning shot he didn't spot
it it was difficult we should mention it
was Knight takes Pawn just to open up a
check against the white king this check
would have been deadly if the Knight had
been recaptured a check the king moves
in maybe the one that Magnus hadn't
spotted is that you first have to push
this Pawn forward to break the white
Bishop's connection with this H6 Square
next The Rook slides across to win and
uh if we fast forward
to the end game magnet here was in full
control he had these two running pawns
he should have been winning for black
but he found a really nice way to guide
it to safety and Hikaru never got a
chance to win on the board
quite a match this has been Magnus
Carlsen wins the winner finals and goes
through to Friday's Grand Final Hikaru
Nakamura he goes down to uh tomorrow
play the loser is final there is still a
chance Hikaru Nakamura can win the air
things monsters what do you think of the
match we've seen between these two
giants Tanya that's exactly what we
expected right so much drama on the
board Magnus had his chances in the
rapid potion as well I think overall
today Magnus was perhaps just slightly
slightly the better player in this match
if anyone had the chances in Rapid it
was him and in the Armageddon What was
amazing to see was that one second win
by Magnus to get the black Pieces Just
goes on to show how much they have the
understanding of each other's mindset
here and then playing with the black
pieces I think that was a brilliant
Armageddon game uh Hikaru tried his best
he tried to create chances made a mess
made a chaotic position on the board but
but Magnus was completely in control
today yeah we raised our eyebrow brows
when we saw the bids Robert Magnus with
eight minutes and 58 seconds How brave
was that to bid that little time against
Hikaru extremely brave because in the
game that we saw Hikaru almost put
Magnus under incredible duress uh Magnus
thankfully for him was able to open the
board up and his plan became easier but
it almost worked to Perfection for his
cars that little time that's dangerous
against someone of Speedy as a car yeah
definitely
we are hoping to get reactions from the
two players Magnus Carlsen is the winner
of the match how will you sum it up
David this whole match between these two
oh it's just fantastic to watch first of
all as a chess fan myself it was so
close very high quality both kind of
trading blows with each other he covers
only blunder today I would say was
bidding uh eight minutes 59 rather than
eight minutes 57 but uh yeah fair play
to Magnus he took its uh small margins
but uh he did did deserve the win and
we're joined by Magnus Carlsen big
congratulations on a big match win
yeah thank you I think what I deserve uh
the most credit for is my bid that was
the soul read definitely take us through
your uh thinking they're bidding eight
minutes and 58 seconds
I thought it was one seconds less than 8
55 which I thought was going to his be
his bit so there you go impressive
impressive but did you feel that was
taking a risk bidding that little time
against someone as Speedy as he car
Nakamura
yeah I think playing Armageddon is a
pretty big risk to begin with uh and uh
I believe that he's a lot more
comfortable playing Black in these
situations so I thought uh playing Black
uh would be um the main goal and this
was uh
I thought
um this was I thought the amount of time
that I could the most amount of time
that I could bid I'm still be black aha
now did you have a plan for this bid
from the get-go today or was it
something you came up with just in those
minutes before the Armageddon started
the drift at all I was thinking about it
before the fourth game because I was
sure that he had forced to draw and
um because of that I was not focused on
the game and I just made the wrong move
in the opening which could have cost me
dearly aha yeah there were a few missed
opportunities for you today Magnus how
will you sum up the match as a whole
um you know what uh this is one of the
days that I I mean I woke up uh after a
long long sleep
I I had some breakfast maybe some too
much breakfast because afterwards I was
spent and I could not recover for the
whole game so I think
uh the match was of
really really poor quality
uh and I think he probably would agree
as well uh so normally uh especially the
second game
I get an opportunity which I should
never in a million years Miss and also
in this first game I was was much better
and it didn't feel like he was playing
it nearly his his best so uh I think the
chances are
pretty high that I'll be facing him
again and then I think we'll just we'll
uh we hope that I hope that we both can
it's a bit better because this was I
think I much that it was not
representative of any hour of our levels
okay and uh Magnus you mentioned that
the breakfast uh kind of caused some
issues this morning what do they serve
at the chatsborough house for breakfast
no we actually went went out you know I
had some uh
uh I had some eggs some bacon and some
some veggies so that's you know close to
what I normally eat so I should have
been fine the other days I've so I've
come out come out here uh
without eating breakfast and then I felt
a lot better so like then I've been just
you know munching on some some uh nuts
and raisins uh during the games and some
carrots in between games and that's
worked a lot better so maybe I should go
back to that
and Magnus was the good breakfast that
you were having was that the reason why
you were slightly late for the star
CH and did you read David's text that he
sent you right at the beginning
no I didn't see them it's text so I I
thought it was going to start at 12 45
so I was a bit shocked when
when I was told
that you know
we're starting so I I I I should have
been ready of course but also like not
having set starting times is less than
ideal for the players and Magus now that
you're a streamer you know chat isn't
always focused on the chess so a big
question that was coming from them is
what is your favorite Pokemon
Psyduck
magnets no yeah
the whole Chess World has really enjoyed
this battle between you two today
together you hold all the big world
championship titles with Hikaru being
the fish random world champion you've
had so many awesome battles in online
chess over the last few years is the
Rivalry with Hikaru something that keeps
you motivated
uh yeah I mean the games are a lot of
fun and especially
especially in the last few years they've
felt very very important so yeah anytime
I got a chance to play him it's uh it's
a privilege yeah and uh winning today
you get a day off tomorrow you are
already ready for Friday's the big Grand
Final so how will you spend the day of
tomorrow
I'm not telling you that's for sure okay
respect that Magnus big congratulations
on the big matchment today and good luck
on Friday
enjoy your day off
all right why do you think Marcus will
be up to tomorrow you guys
might have the answers
but uh maybe studying some chess may
play some Pokemon you know he seemed
pretty happy to answer with Psyduck so
maybe he'll go do some Pokemon go maybe
you'll play duck chess if you love
Psyduck
it's a good one yeah I don't think it's
going to involve a lot of Chess let me
just
enjoying his time with the chess bras in
Canada my name is Carlton is ready for
the Grand Final in the air things
monsters let's take a look at the
bracket we are done with uh three days
in the air things monsters two days to
go we started today with the losers
quarterfinals Wesley so was dominant
winning two games against Serana to
knock Serana out and to go through to
the losers semi-final it was an intense
battle between Arjun everybody see and
yukash the two young Indians eventually
or guys he made it through to the losers
semi-final he will face Wesley so
tomorrow the winner of that match best
of two rapid games will go through to
face Hikaru Nakamura and the losers
final so that is what is coming up
tomorrow the winner of the losers final
will may meet Magnus Carlsen in the
Grand Final on Friday so we do have
Wesley Seoul still in here we do have
Hikaru Nakamura still in her Magnus
Carlson's still in here and Arjun Eric I
see I guess the the underdog
yeah to make it all the way to the final
now definitely an underdog but somebody
who we saw great chess from today he's
playing with confidence with passion as
fireworks all across the board so he's a
dangerous opponent for Wesley so who
prefers a solid game yeah what chances
do you give ordinary guys you know Tanya
too
phrase and upsets against these Giants
in online chess well undoubtedly on
paper Wesley is a big favor going into
that match fit you know what Kaya last
year if anyone would have predicted that
we'd find Arjun aragassi in the finals
of the Champions Chester few would have
believed it but there we had it we saw
him make his way through through that he
had a brilliant performance he's capable
of it he needs to believe it and of
course everything that he's been showing
so far he needs to come in with that
same energy same effort same precision
and fearless play yeah what do you think
so far David of the Champions Chester
2023 well I was expecting a lot and it
really has lift up lived up to those
expectations we're really lucky to be
enjoying the Giants of modern chess
playing in our tournaments and uh yeah
whoever wins this double limb uh will
prove that they are at the moment in
time the best rapper chess player out
there yeah fantastic day of Chess thank
you so much to our experts for excellent
commentary remember that in actually 25
minutes the grand Master Shanklin is
doing and ask me anything and he's going
to focus on his new chessable course
that is out starts in 25 minutes on
chess.com Discord so check that out and
join us again tomorrow for more chess
it's been so much fun today we'll see
you again tomorrow bye for now
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
nice
thank you